day six days are passing and we are
steadily upscaling great to see you
again and we are really happy with such
a tremendous response from our dedicated
learners
today is day 6 of software development
week by simply learn so far we are done
with data structures and algorithms
c plus plus core java and advanced java
object-oriented programming languages
have really streamlined and secured the
process of software development
yet c plus plus and java also known as
giants of programming with their
well-structured coding paradigms bring
complexities to light that many
beginners feel hard to synthesize
what if you were given a programming
language that could simply outperform
java and drastically decrease the code
length from thousands of lands to a
hundred what if i say there's actually
one existing that stands as the flag
bearer of simplicity so much so that it
sets up its runtime environment and
environment variables eliminating all
the hassle for you
yes that's how python is today's session
is all about mastering the python
programming language so without any
further ado let's allow our experts to
take over the session so we will start
by learning the history of python and
understand the top 10 reasons to learn
python
you will look at the job role of a
python developer the skills they need to
possess and how the resume of a python
developer should be then
we'll see how to install python and the
anaconda distribution of python
then we will shift our focus towards
learning the basics of python such as
data types variables operators lists
tuples and dictionaries next we will
understand about loops and conditional
statements after that we'll get an idea
about object oriented programming
concepts
and functions in python we will also
cover some important advanced python
programming concepts such as iterators
modules generators as well as packages
finally we will see the important python
interview questions that are often asked
so let's get started let's begin and
learn about the development of python
and gain insights about the current id
trends python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and english like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language
python has interpreted high-level
general purpose programming language
developed by guido van rossum at
national research institute for
mathematics and computer science
netherlands in contrast to popular
belief that python was named after the
snake python was actually named after
the show monty python's flying circus
guido van rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the abc
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference cycles
python 3.0 was released on the 3rd of
december 2008.
undoubtedly python 2.x and 3.x have
proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top id companies like google
facebook instagram spotify and netflix
among others use python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi keras tensorflow
django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code
a few popular open source python
projects include fit env statistics
solving the traveling salesman problem
using self-organizing maps and python to
bpm converter some of the trending
python repositories on github today
include nlp ml from scratch pytorch
transformers 100 days of ml code among
others popular websites on the internet
like reddit and quora are built using
python civilization 4 battlefield 2 sims
4 and world of tanks are some popular
games developed using python
according to indeed the average salary
of a python developer in india is about
5 lakhs per annum and that in the us is
around 124 000 us dollars users and
admirers of python especially those
considered knowledgeable are referred to
as pythonists pythony stars and
pythoners
since its inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the id industry so what
really is python programming language
python is an object-oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it supports multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by guido van rossum
and its implementation started in
december 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994
python 2.0 came out in october 2000
while python 3.0 was released in
december 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the python programming language
let's now look at the top 10 reasons why
you should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to java or cc plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in java
as you can see
if you have to write a program in java
you first have to declare
the class name along with its scope
next
using curly braces you need to pass the
main method along with its arguments
and then using
system.out.println method you can print
hello world that's quite a tedious task
isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here
you can write the print function and
pass whatever you want to display inside
the brackets and that will print the
output it is so simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at nine we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language
python has large community support
it has an extensive and active community
to assist engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum
the community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the zen of python
written by tim peters that represents
the guiding principles for python
development
up next at 8 we have portable and
multiple cross-language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on windows and they want to
execute on a mac operating system or
linux operating system or solaris they
can easily do it without any amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java dot net c and c plus plus
scores with python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next reason to learn python is
testing frameworks
python supports several built-in
flawless testing tools and frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and frameworks
supported by python are pi test selenium
and splinter
this is the reason for which every
tester tries to use python-based tools
and frameworks to test any application
or code or to validate it in an easier
manner
pi test is the most recommended testing
framework for functional integrational
and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
python programming language to automate
various tasks and splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting urls and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
tasks simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation
web development machine learning and
data science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software
python provides the default package
called pip anaconda is a third party
python ecosystem other examples include
numpy
scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later
further it is interpreted by the machine
and checked for errors at runtime the
machine is used to read and interpret
the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program
or the same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to learn python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are xango flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie etc
these frameworks are written in python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in php
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scripting
django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out url routing etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
pinterest and linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask
it will assist users with url routing
and authentication support
turbo gears
is a highly recommended and scalable
framework that supports features such as
authentication
caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand
python is robust scalable and provides
extensible visualization and graphics
options hence it is widely used in data
science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data
pandas for operations to manipulate data
on numerical tables and time series it
also provides simpli for symbolic
computation and scipy for technical and
scientific computations
it has another library called pi brain
which is sought for python based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is a machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms
and finally it provides by torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to learn python which is
career opportunities and salary
python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
giants
industry leaders using python are amazon
google facebook ibm nasa netflix and
youtube
next you can see the google trends
but i have considered three programming
languages python java and c plus plus i
have compared them for the past 12
months
you can see it clearly on your screens
that python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the youtube
search
there also you will find that python
programming language is the most
searched language on youtube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
google
it is a leading indicator
the raw data comes from google trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
java then javascript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph
shows the popularity of python and java
over the years starting from 2004
till the current period which is 2020.
worldwide python is the most popular
language
python grew the most in the last five
years by 19.4 percent and java lost the
most by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into if you learn
python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second
you can become a web developer here you
will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic
python web developers usually develop
back-end components
connect the application with third-party
services and support the front-end
developers by integrating their work
with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python
as a data analyst you have to gather
data from multiple sources using scripts
analyze that data develop and implement
databases and data collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of scopes if you learn
python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer
you can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the united states
while in india you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
if you learn python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 130
000 per year in the united states while
in india you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at
eight we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven
we saw the testing frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
science at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer
let's answer this so here are some of
the technologies used by a python
developer
pandas anaconda tensorflow python ides
django web framework and python
a python developer is one who develops
back-end components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web frameworks like
django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science
so basically a python developer develops
deploys debugs and maintains a project
so let's go through the skill set of a
python developer
now the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs
there's oop concepts like inheritance
classes and objects and abstraction
there's packages and functions that is
importing external packages into a
python code
database and its connection that is
connecting a python backend to a
database like mysql when it comes to
data science skills there's numpy that
is a library for performing mathematical
calculations
there's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently there's sci-fi and then
there's matplotlib which is a library
for plotting charts and graphs for a
given data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised etc now coming to web
developer skills there are frameworks
like django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's api handling which is basically
handling api requests for a web
application to perform server side
operations and finally there is back in
connection which basically involves the
backend part of a web app
usually handled by python frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
frameworks like django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements develops
the server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlib
numpy pandas etc carry out data analysis
collect using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including pi test pi unit
perform complex system tests
troubleshoot code issues create test
scripts design the automation framework
perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles
to perform statistical analysis of data
put machine learning models into
production
research and transform data science
prototypes
research and implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools
perform ml tests and keep updated with
the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe the average salary of a
python developer in india is around 7
lakhs 55 000 rupees per annum
the average salary of a python developer
in the us is about 79 000 us dollars per
annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resuming
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for
and do not write anything extra that's a
big no the recruiters are smart enough
to know that
so do not lie and do not write extra
firstly let's look at the pressure
assuming so if you're refresher these
are some of the points that you need to
know
first you have the resume header
now the summary is supposed to be clear
and concise
just say what exactly you want and some
of your strengths next is the profile
links and your portfolio so you can
mention your linkedin profile link and
also your github repository link if you
have next up is the projects now clearly
depict the goal of your project so just
in case you worked on like c5 projects
make sure you keep it concise and crisp
next up is your education do not lie
here make sure you give a relevant
education with grades next you have the
certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down
next you have the technical skills now
again prioritize according to the job
role and lastly you have your
non-technical skills this could be your
communication analytical skills problem
solving skills etc moving on to an
experienced developer so again mention
the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links
coming to experience now here you have
to clearly depict your work you will
have to make sure that you write down
all your responsibilities in that
company do not go overboard and write
extra keep it very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job role and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very
it's a very readable program code
readability is very important it's one
of the design philosophies behind this
when it was being developed it's very
easy to learn which is why python is an
entry point for many people that are
just beginning to learn programming and
as i mentioned earlier it's a high level
language in python we since python is
open source as as i already mentioned so
it gets it benefits from all the the
benefits you get from any open source
technology now it's also portable
so what this means is that if we create
a code in python and we create in a
particular system say on windows
we don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or that
same piece of code on some other system
say on a linux system or
a mac system python itself comes with a
very large standard library this this
facilitates us
a lot because we don't need to
create our own libraries or modules or
have to download very specific libraries
most of the problems that we do
encounter
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python write right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will uh encounter what is the meaning of
a data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and
as as you will see later
python has one of the most user-friendly
data structures
that can be found in any language
especially compared to some of its
contemporaries now python is a
dynamically programmed language and this
is very important and what this means is
that in most compiler based languages we
there are certain processes that can
only happen during the compilation stage
so
what a dynamic programming language does
is it takes all those
compilation specific
tasks and processes and
it does it for us as we actually type
the code so we don't need to waste time
or spend extra time to do something that
would otherwise be needed to be only
done in compilation we would have to set
out specific uh runtimes just for that
uh so this allows us to create our
programs and solutions much faster and
allows us to debug much easier and uh
yeah so it's a it's a very important
feature about python now quickly i will
just go over some of the uh areas of
python where
like
areas of um or
different domains where python is very
heavily implemented and the first one
the first few ones that come to mind are
like web development and
ai and machine learning so you have
technologies like django and flash that
are
built on top of python that
are used extensively for web development
when it comes to something like
artificial intelligence or machine
learning you have
distributions such as anaconda you have
pandas and many other libraries like
scipy and numpy that are used
extensively to so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
use in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays
because of
again some of the libraries that i have
already mentioned such as scipy
interestingly if you are into game
development or gaming in general you
would see that python actually has
certain libraries and certain
technologies that facilitate game
development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python uh some of the other
applications are of course desktop uh be
creating desktop gui image processing
graphic design applications and uh
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses
there are many technologies in the
environment of python that
were almost designed for the specific
purpose of
being able to present certain concepts
or to be able to
teach certain classes and
i can't think of too many programs or
too many environments outside of python
that are better to solve these education
and training course related uh problems
and situations let's uh let's get to
actually installing python so now that
so i will show you how to install python
on windows since i have a windows system
uh however i will also point out uh the
way you you would have to install python
on aim on mac os or linux or even on
mobile so uh yeah let's get started so
to install python on your windows
computer it's as simple as going to the
website python.org and selecting the
downloads section when you do click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that
this webpage that i'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version
but of course if you for whatever reason
if you needed a particular version of
python you can download that as well
by just scrolling down and choosing the
option that you want now it's important
to note that whatever option you choose
of course i would recommend the latest
one but no matter what option you choose
i would recommend you choose a version
of python three point something because
uh previous versions of python namely
python 2.7 and uh and basically every
version of python two point something
has it will not receive any more
maintenance and updates uh because uh
the developers have decided that python
will they are trying to shift towards uh
maintaining and updating python three
point whatever completely right now so
yeah
let's not delay this uh any further and
just download python 3.9 so once you
select the option out here
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now i would of
course recommend just to install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into
the drive where your windows is actually
installed your your main drive so as you
can see now that once my setup is done
it should give me a pop-up soon so my
setup is done for python and this is
essentially how you would um download
python on your windows system uh but
what if you had mac os or if you were
using linux well for mac it's a it's
actually almost as simple you just go
if you see out here below this download
button python option you get the website
asking you are you looking for python on
a different os and it gives you the
options of linux mac and even other os's
but for mac
if you wanted you would just open this
tab and
just like the windows option you would
so choose a version and you would choose
an installer for that version so if i
wanted to say python the latest one i
would just download this installer and i
would install my mac system now when it
comes to linux i cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
would just choose the linux option out
here it would take you to a page with
different installers and
essentially packages for linux systems
in specific what i would recommend to
you if you are a linux user and you need
python is to go over to the real
python.com website and
they have a very good uh essentially
instructions on how to install python
and since i don't have a linux system i
cannot directly show you how to install
python on linux so yeah if you do have
linux please head over to this website
and this should be of a lot of help to
you now
as i had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an ios user you
would go to the ios app store and
download an app called the python is the
app for ios it essentially is like a
full-fledged
python environment where you can develop
in python on your iphone or even ipad
and if you were an android user you
could you would go and download an app
called the pi droid 3.
there's a free version and a paid
version for this app and of course the
difference between the free and paid is
that the page supports
code analysis and code prediction these
are certain details you don't have to
worry about right now and
honestly if
i wouldn't worry too much about
installing python on your mobile devices
currently since
i am assuming most people would be
learning programming and programming in
python on their pcs or laptops what i
had actually showed you was installing
what is called an implementation of
python on your system an implementation
is essentially a program or a software
or an environment that allows you to
actually work in python so what i showed
you was how to install the by default or
the most basic or reference
implementation that has been created by
the developers which is actually called
c python uh even though you would not
you would not have seen the word the
letter c or the prefix c uh but yeah
that implementation that i had i had
downloaded myself and i had shown you to
download uh is actually the c python
implementation which is python built on
top of c the the c language essentially
there are other implementations such as
iron python which uses the dotnet
framework and jpython that uses java
virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that i would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python i want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you
this distribution is called anaconda
anaconda is a very important
distribution especially if you are
looking to
use python in data science and machine
learning and ai which i am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards the
moving towards data science and if that
is your goal or in any case whatever
your goal may be i would recommend that
you install anaconda distribution now do
not get confused between anaconda and
python their anaconda is python with
i
in the form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that i had shown you
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and technologies and
software's as well so of course this
means that would you need to download
both of course not if you download a
python you do not need anaconda to work
on python and
if you have already downloaded anaconda
which i will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so i'll just speak
about anaconda little briefly so as i
said it's a distribution it it it
contains a bundle uh which includes a
basic python implementation and a lot of
technologies and softwares and
applications
that
essentially help us to use python in
in in specifically managing their big
data applications and uh data science
related projects so so now i will show
you actually how to install python i
mean anaconda on your system it's as
simple as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if i did
a quick quick google of anaconda
so the website that i'm looking for is
anaconda.com and i'm looking at products
and i'm looking at individual edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial team edition these are for
companies usually or
for more professional sort of projects
so of course we are looking at the
individual edition and if you selected
this page you would be taken to
this particular webpage where it will
ask you if you want to download and
again there are options depending on
which machine you're using after you're
using a linux you would choose one of
these two if you are using mac os you
would use one of these two and since i
am a windows user and i have a 64-bit
system this is the option i would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been uh downloaded so
upon opening it it will open up this
installation thing
you can just click next on most of these
again if you want to specify your
destination folder you can change it
here mine will be with a default folder
in the c drive and you can leave this
unticked you can you can change these
options much later so
this is how you install anaconda windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done i
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that anaconda contains
that are not there if you
installed python
like the way i had shown you earlier
just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete
and
now i will open anaconda and i'll show
you what how you can actually use this
anaconda
so if i search for anaconda in my system
i would look for something called
anaconda navigator to actually get
started with this and when i open that
it should open something like this so
this is what opens when you click on the
anaconda navigator and as you can see
there are a bunch of applications you
don't need to worry about what these
mean
right now
just understand that this this is
essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install anaconda navigator now now
that we have actually tackled
where we've seen how to install and i'm
hoping and i would recommend definitely
that everyone is watching this video
installs anaconda not just the uh normal
python uh installation or implementation
uh now that we have gotten all the
introductions and the basics and the
installations uh regarding python aside
let's get right let's get down to
actually creating our first script so
now the question is uh how do we
actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed a python like uh now let's how
do we start doing something so
the answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic things that
you can do is create a python script and
execute a script a script is essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give
for python to run and execute to give
you a certain result so i will show you
how you can create a python script now
there are multiple ways of creating a
python script you can create it directly
from command line which is obviously
something i would not recommend because
it is not convenient and easy and it's
not very useful for the beginner another
way is using a text editor such as the
one i have opened right now which is the
notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused
between notepad plus plus and the
standard notepad that comes with your
windows
or wordpad for that matter in fact text
editors such as
notepad and wordpad
that you are more familiar with create
text and files in a form that is called
rich text now rich text is
something
is text that
contains formatting and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text
plain text is obviously text which does
not contain these fonts and the
formattings
and it only respects white spaces and
indentations those two being actually
useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents and that is very
that was actually created with uh
programming in mind
obviously you can use a bunch of other
text editors such as wim and atom and
you can google for these there are
plenty of them so
without any further ado let's create our
first python script so one of the most
common one of the most famous examples
of
a first program in any program for that
matter not just python is creating a
print statement that gives us a
statement saying hello world so in
python this is how you would go about or
this is the syntax you would use to
create the statement
all right
now where it is very important when you
are saving your python program that you
use the dot py prefix so if i were to
save this i can choose whatever folder i
am going to choose yeah this folder
seems fine so now i give the file name
over here as say i want to keep it as
test i need to prefix this with dot py
and this
tells any uh sort of interpreter or
anytime we need to read the script to
know that it's a python script we need
to add a dot py otherwise it will not be
treated as a python script it will be
treated as some normal document sort of
a thing so now that i've stored it as
dot py
i have created my first python script
now
obviously the next question is i need to
see
what happens when i execute this line
when i run this script essentially so
to see that
there are multiple ways the first way
that i will show you is a command line
method which is obviously again before
we get into it it's not something that i
will be using to teach you it's not
something i would recommend you to
immediately start using
but for the sake of showing i will show
you how to execute a script in command
line well to do this you go since i have
installed anaconda in my system and i
will be using anaconda to
work in python what i will look for is
something called the anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that i
get anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this
now i'm already in the folder i believe
that had my script so
how do i call this script or how do i
run the script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so i enter test dot py if you
if this was in a different folder you
would have to change your folders and
command line which is again something
that i might show you later but since my
file is already in the folder that i am
in in my command line i would just have
to enter this command right now so if i
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what i wanted i wanted it to
print this
these two words and of course the
command line is now waiting for the next
command for me so this is uh one of the
most simple ways of or the most
rudimentary ways of executing a python
script now another question would be
well
this isn't the most visually appealing
or
not the easy to read or easy to use way
of
executing scripts and i would agree and
that's why i'm going to introduce a
another technology or a software called
the ide so the ide in python or in any
programming language stands for
integrated development environment it's
essentially a software that not only
allows us to run scripts but it allows
us to create the scripts it allows us to
debug it allows us to see outputs it
allows us to see intermediary outputs
it allows us to do a wide variety of
tools and tasks and it comes with a
bunch of robust features to enhance our
python programming experience so let's
let's see so i will show you a an ide
called spider which comes bundled along
with the anaconda distribution that i
had mentioned earlier so if i open the
anaconda navigator
as you can see the anaconda navigator
shows me a bunch of technologies and
options and i'm looking for something
called the spider ide which is over here
as you can see here it's a scientific
python development environment
this is exactly what i'm looking for so
i am looking to launch this so now that
i've launched it you can see out here
this is what an ide looks like now this
looks very sophisticated and it's it's a
one and any almost any ide is a
wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider id in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have already created our
script in notepad plus plus and i want
to open that script and i want to see uh
how and i how it would the result of
that script would look in an ide so
let's just open it so we can browse for
our file and as i had
named it test this is the file over here
i open this and as you can see out here
in the left hand pane
my script has opened and the command
that had given or had written is out
over here now if i want to run this
application i press this green button
and as you can see the result of my my
execution essentially is over here it's
in slightly small font but as you can
see over here uh it says hello world and
it's very and the next line is
essentially it's it's waiting for me to
do another execution of the script and
then it will give me new results so
let's actually give the system new
results so now that i have printed
something called hello world let's let's
change what's written over here let's
say i will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what i'm exactly doing these are things
that we will actually cover in the
in upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a
let's store a a number three let's
create a variable b story number five
all right let's create another variable
c
uh which will store the result of what's
in a and b in the addition of a and b
all right and let's print the result or
print what's in uh this variable c or
what's the result of a plus b i will
print a statement saying the result of
the addition
of three and five is all right and i
will put my result over here
as you can see i should get the result
in this pane so let's execute this and
you can see uh
my first line is executed saying i will
perform basic maths and the next line
says the result of the addition of three
and five is eight so uh this in this
script what i've done is i performed uh
two print statements and i've performed
a basic expression some variable
assignments all of these things we will
be doing later this is what i what i'm
essentially trying to show you is that
uh ides are a very convenient way of not
only creating the scripts but actually
seeing the results and then making
adjustments as well we can com we can
create a completely new script we don't
need to create a script from some
special file or text editor uh i can
just create a new file here and this is
my new script essentially so i can start
working on this new script right over
here from the get go so ides are very
powerful spider ide comes bundled with
anaconda there are other ideas such as
the i idle ide it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the ideal ide comes
as part of the
basic python implementation that i had
shown you in the previous video where
you if you just installed a basic uh
python
implementation it would come along with
a basic ide known as idly or integrated
development and learning environment
but of course since we are using python
and that is what i would recommend uh it
comes with a more robust ide called
spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific
and numeric applications
and was designed specifically with that
in mind
now
this is not the only way we can actually
work with python there's another very
interesting and
a very educative
method of creating python let's say
python programs and it's something that
i will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called
notebooks
now
before i get into the details i will
state i will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the jupyter
notebook and when i open or when i
launch the jupiter notebook this is what
i get now
a very important
feature or a
a feature of notebooks is that notebooks
a web browser a web-based application
so you it's not something that you can
use if you are offline or disconnected
basically if you're disconnected from
the internet it is something where which
for which you would need an active
internet connection however it is way
more robust and it has very very good
properties that allow it to be used in
education or for presentations and such
so as you can see this is my jupiter
notebook these are a bunch of folders
don't need to worry about what these are
right now i will show you how to create
a fresh notebook so if you go here now
you go to new and you select under
notebook the python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see
this line is essentially waiting for me
to enter some sort of a command or a
statement that i would give in a normal
python thing now if you would have
noticed that
in
uh until now everything that we were
doing involved us
creating a script which was the whole
series of commands and functions so if i
go back to my spider ide as you can see
like this is a whole script and this
script contains multiple different
tasks and functions that are
individually
being performed so this is a separate
print function this is a separate
edition another separated print function
and for longer
programs or larger programs you like you
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like uh what
is the result of just this print
statement or just this uh it's not
typically
what an ide is used for and this is
where notebooks come in super handy
if i had to break down my previous
script essentially where i first did a
print statement where i said some random
thing say hello
yeah so if i execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now i want to do what is 5 plus 3
it should give me the result over here
8. now the next
another part of your program might be
storing 5 and 3 into variables so i can
do this and i can do this so now this
line will store the variables now i want
to do the addition of what is 5 3 but i
want to use the variables and i want to
see what's the result as you can see a
plus b means five plus three which is
eight and i've essentially broken down
various different parts of my previous
script into
into its individual tasks and i'm able
to see what each part of that script
does and this is very good when it comes
to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so i will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
different concepts when it comes to
python and i would recommend that you
get used to
notebooks in general because uh it's an
amazing way to learn python programming
or programming in general in fact
and again as i had mentioned earlier
notebooks are something that it's an
online
application it's a web-based application
so i will have to need a active internet
connection to be able to work on a
notebook which could be a disadvantage
if you do not have a consistent internet
connection and in that case you would
probably use your ides or text editor
which can be used offline as well in
this video we will be introduced to the
concept of variables and expressions
let's start with expressions well an
expression in python is anything that
results in a value
its difference although the difference
between an expression and a standard
statement in python is that a statement
in python is something that results in
an action or an execution of a command
there is no calculation per se or any
sort of manipulation or as i said
earlier calculation
resulting in between two different say
numbers or other objects that results in
a value and this happens in the case of
an expression so for example if i were
to add two numbers say five plus ten
this is an expression which should where
two objects five and ten are being added
and a result is being given to me which
is 15. now let's see an example of a
statement well a statement could be
something like a print statement so when
i ask python to print something for me
it's not calculating anything it's not
evaluating anything it's simply
performing an action that i have or a
command that i have given the system
which is to print whatever i have
entered over here as you can see so this
is a statement similarly there are
another type of statement known as
assignment statements which we will
learn actually right in the next section
well let's move on to variables right
now now earlier you might have learned
about objects in python so
objects are essentially data
that
we can work with or manipulate in python
now variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually
it's much easier to
store objects in python instead of using
the objects explicitly themselves
because objects may be very completely
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply
very are named in a very simple manner
so that we can use them quite often in
our programs now it's important to note
that in python we do not have to
explicitly declare or define a variable
to create them in fact variables are
created in the same statement where we
assign some object to that variable in
python the assignment of variables
happens using the assignment operator
which is the equals to sign so if i were
to if i wanted to assign a number say
100 to a variable say b
well it would be as simple as doing this
now anytime i want to know what is
stored in b i just have to enter b
and i will get the value that is stored
in it and we can store different types
of objects inside a any variable let's
say i store i want to store this
particular word in the form of a string
now this is stored in x and if i want to
know what is an x i can just see what is
here and it's a string hello which i had
stored earlier now it's very important
that we follow certain naming rules when
it comes to naming our variables in
python or else we may be thrown errors
or we might get some problems in our
program so the first rule is that you
cannot start your variable name with a
number so if i were to give a variable
name like four num is equal to something
say
the same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and i will get an
error when i try this so if i were to
choose a num for
is equal to hello this would be
perfectly fine i won't get an error the
second rule is we are not allowed to use
any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if i were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and i
say i said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if i
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if i have a variable called num
or say num if this was one of my
variables and i stored say the value of
50. this is not the same as me writing
num all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in python is
that you are not allowed to use what we
call reserve words in python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are used as identifiers
for certain special functions in python
that we that have a special purpose like
that particular word has a special
purpose within the python programming
language and we cannot use them to name
our variables so a list of them either
you can see over here some of them are
like false def if
uh de l rays and there are like there
are around 33 of them and sometimes some
of these words are taken out sometimes
there are more words added as python
gets updated now let's let's move on to
a concept uh where we try to really
understand
what do we mean by storing data inside a
variable now when i say that we are
storing something inside a variable you
get an image or you get an idea in your
head that this variable is like a
container where we store or we put a
particular object inside it so does this
mean that variables have a place in the
memory are they also an object that is
placed in the memory where we can put
other objects inside of well i'll show
you an example where this idea is kind
of disproven or where i'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say i'm storing the same object
i will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and i'm going to
store it into two different variables so
i take x is equal to 100 over here
and in the next line i will store 100 in
y as well now if objects were i mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then x and y should have two
different ids but let's see what happens
when i check the id of x
and the id of y they should be different
in case variables were their own objects
however as you can see the id of x and
the id of y are exactly the same so
well obviously we know that two
different objects in python cannot have
the same id so
does this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
i said x is equal to 100 and y is equal
to 100 what i'm actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called x that i want to refer or
point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and i do the
same thing with another variable y so i
am not exactly creating it a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when i do id of x and id of y
it's not giving me the idea of something
called x or the id of something called y
it's giving me the id of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in x and y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what i'm trying
to say and similarly if if i were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see i've used the
value of 50 to explain my point so as
you can see initially x and y are
pointing towards this value 50 because i
have stored 50 and 50 in both x and y
now what if i changed the object that is
stored in x well that means x is now
pointing towards
this new object and i've stored this new
object called hello the string called
hello as you can see here so now x is
pointing to a new object in the system
and it's called hello
and
i haven't changed anything with respect
to y so y will point towards the same
thing and i can also make the pointer of
y different or what i'm trying to say is
i can store something else in y see i
stored this list in y 50 60 100. when i
do that now y is pointing towards a
different object in python and x is also
pointing towards something else so what
happens to this object 50 well now that
there's no variable referring to this
object 50 it becomes what we call an
orphaned object and we can actually see
that when we do the id of x now let's go
back to my example on the right where i
stored x is equal to 100 so as you can
see it gives me some id represented by
this number now let's say i stored x i
stored something different index say 200
now if i do the id of x it should give
me a different id because as you can see
the values are different and this is
because this object 200 is what is
stored in x and when i do the id of x
i'm actually getting the id of this new
object now 200. so as you can see
point as you can see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers uh instead
of containers for a particular object in
this video you will be introduced to the
concept of objects in python now what
are objects in python well all the data
that we manipulate or use in our
operations in our code are represented
as objects or relations between objects
so if you want an example two numbers
that you add in your code well both of
them are objects and they're usually
numeric type objects similarly if you
want to store someone's name or an
address of your hometown in your code
you usually store it in a form of text
and that text is also an object usually
a string similarly you might want to
create a container of different smaller
objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in python has three
important properties that kind of define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change once once it has been
created so for example if i took an
example of say a string called hello i
can use the id function which is this is
how you use the id function to find out
the id of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the id of hello is this integer
23264 766 23024 similarly all objects in
python have an identity
we have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially
what defines what kind of values and
operations
that that object can have so for example
a numeric data type in python such as an
integer would allow us to do arithmetic
operations and similarly string object
type in python will allow us to do
concatenation operations much like its
identity the type of an object cannot be
changed as well now let's see what's the
type of that particular object that i
had shown you above as you can see it
should be string str stands for string
similarly if i did a type for a number
say 50 it should give me int
as you can see now the third property of
an object in python is its value now the
value is the actual data that is
contained in the object it's the thing
that we use that we display that we can
manipulate and that we can perform
operations on so for example if i were
to talk about this string the string is
hello so the value of the string is the
word or the sequence of letters that
spell out hello and similarly this
particular object is a numeric object
with the value of 50. let's see in this
in this pictorial representation i have
shown you that you can assume this dutch
blue area as the memory of the system
within this memory we have objects
created called 50 and hello and this
list containing smaller objects called
cat pen and 40. now what i'm trying to
show you here is each of these objects
have a type an id and a value and let's
see what they are if i wanted to see as
we had already seen the type of 50 now
let's find the id of 50. as you can see
we get this unique id for the object 50
which is obviously not the same as the
id of the object hello above and the
value of this object is the valuable 50
itself so that was a brief introduction
into objects in python in this video we
will cover the topics of numeric object
types and type conversions in python now
let's get started numeric object types
in python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real-life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent numerals that contain decimal
points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8
and so on then there is the complex
object type which is used to represent
complex numbers in python and this is an
example of a complex number 3 plus 7j
this is a complex number three plus
seven j where the real component is
three and the imaginary component is
seven all complex numbers have a real
and imaginary component and this is how
we denote them now it's important to
note that this j is a very common symbol
in maths and engineering used to denote
the imaginary portion of a complex
number and it's the same in python as
well so moving on let's talk about type
conversion in python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider
my example string to be
some something called 145 and i'm sewing
this within a string for a reason
because i want to convert a string to an
integer so as you can see i have stored
this 145 within my within a variable x
and if i were to confirm that it is
actually an integer i can use the type
function and see that it is actually an
integer str now let's convert this into
an integer using the int function so how
would we use it is
simply passing the end uh sim by passing
the variable that we want to convert
into the in function and as you can see
this is what i've done over here but
before this i will also store it into
another variable all right now let's see
what's in y well y gives us one four
five but are we sure that is an int we
can just check it by using the type
function and as you can see the type
gives us
the answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly
we can convert something and
also specify what base we have to treat
the number as
by default when we pass something in the
in function the program or python will
treat whatever we have passed
within the string as something in base
of decimal but what if we were to pass
something that is well not in a decimal
well we could do it like this now let's
store y
and ny let's store
let's do this and i will show you what
this means x
and i will give a comma and 8. what this
tells python is well i want to convert
the string in x
into an integer but i want to treat
whatever is an x as a number of base
eight so 145 is actually 145 in the base
8. now when we
see what's in y
we get 101 which is different to 145
because
well 1 0 1 is actually the decimal
equivalent of 1 4 5 in the base 8.
similarly if we were to give it in the
base 2 we would just replace 8 with 2
over here now next let's talk about
converting something to a float now as
we know float is just simply something
that has a decimal point so let's
convert an integer into a float how
would we do that simply by using the
float function so if i give 120 and i
pass this integer through the float
function i should get 120.0
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the str function
we can also use the hex and the oc
function if we want to convert a
particular number to a hexadecimal or an
octal string respectively let's look at
all three examples say i have a number
688 and i want to convert this into a
string i just use the str function
around this so as we know just to
confirm let's see what the type of 688
is this is
this should be an end as we can see but
when we pass when we let's say
we convert it into a string 688 and
let's store it into some variable let's
call it a all right now let's see what's
in a it gives a 688 in the form of a
string but we can confirm by checking
the type of a it is an str so it is a
string similarly we can use hex
if we wanted to convert an integer into
its hexadecimal equivalent in the in in
as an output of a string as you can see
this comp this sort of this sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero
should not be treated as anything it's
more like a an identifier which says
that
the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2b 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths
you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688. similarly if i
did oct if i use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first zero is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this zero is the base of
the number following these two uh
following these two characters so as you
can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an oct
represented by this letter o
and the number itself that we are
dealing with is one two six zero and one
two six zero in octal system is the
equivalent of six eight eight in the
decimal system so this is how we've
converted a an integer in
an integer into a hexadecimal or a an
octal string now what if we wanted to
convert two
numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if i passed complex 5 and say
say something like 3.1
let's see what this gives us as you can
see it gives us an a complex object
where
our real part is 5 and our imaginary
part is 3.1 so what this does is
essentially
you pass two numbers the first one is
the real component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if i
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
i will use the tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say i have a
string called
random let's call it random all right
now if i want to convert this to a tuple
i will use the tuple function as you can
see over here the output will give me
tuples where each individual component
of this tuple are the individual
components or the individual characters
of my string random similarly if i
wanted to convert the string to a list i
would use the list function
this will give me a list of the
individual characters
of the word or the
string random and i could do the same
thing with the set function to create
a set of
individual characters of uh the string
random as you can see here
so yeah these were some of the basic
python
type conversions that i have shown you
as we learn about more complex data
types and different object types in
python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
python which contain components placed
one after the other where each component
is given what we call an index a numeric
index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and
disposition within the sequence now
since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index zero the second
is index one the third is index two and
so on now let's move on to defining
strings how do we define them well
strings are defined using what we call
delimiters and delimiters occur in pairs
an opening and a closing delimiter in
python these delimiters are pairs of
single or double quotes so for example
if i were to use single quotes to define
a string i could i would do it like this
this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if i were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if i wanted to include a
single quote within my string well
if i tried to let's see what happens if
i try to print a statement with a single
quote naturally inside it so
say i'm saying it's
my
birthday
all right let's see what happens if i
try to print the statement it says
invalid syntax and this is because as i
had mentioned in python single quotes in
double quotes are delimiters so they
have a special function in python and we
cannot simply just use them within a
string because python will treat them
specially for a special purpose so what
python will do is it will pair this and
this delimiter so single quotes and say
okay this looks like a string to me and
it's not going to understand the rest of
this and then it will find a random
single quote and it won't find its pair
and it will basically throw us an error
because of this so one way or one
workaround to introduce single quotes
into a string is simply to delimit our
string itself using the other type of
delimiter or double quotes so if i want
to include a single quote i will close
my string using double quotes so if i
did this instead of what i had done
earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and i could i
would do the opposite if i had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string i would use single quotes to
close it so
if i were to write a speech statement
she said
i
am hungry all right i have i want these
two double quotes to
essentially show that this is a speech
and i'm going to close this string using
single quotes and this is a valid way of
doing it as you can see my string has
these two double quotes now i had
mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how are they
sequences so first of all all sequences
in python are a um it's a essentially a
sequence of smaller objects
that form the sequence right so let's
try to understand like how do how are
strings to be treated as sequences some
sequences that we will learn later are
like lists or tuples and in all
sequences we can retrieve any particular
object or component in that sequence
using its index and how do we use
indexes in python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what i'm trying to talk about
by this example now say i'm storing a
particular string called say random
within now my variable name here is test
and i'm storing the string random within
it all right and this is a way of
retrieving a particular uh index from
test i write the variable name and then
next to it i put the square brackets now
i'm supposed to put
a numeral within the square brackets to
tell python like what a particular index
i'm looking for so let's try zero now as
i said python is zero index based
language so
the zero index essentially means the
first part of for the first component of
a sequence so let's see what happens
when i ask python to retrieve the first
part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string r in fact it's just one character
r and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is r so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
random is essentially a collection of
the string r the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if i wanted the character at
the third position of this thing i would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in python i would
use the index 2 and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter n so this is how we can
show that
strings are also sequences in python
well now let's move on to um certain
string operations and functions that we
can perform well as you have seen
already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we want to know what index
is a particular character at and we can
do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and i want
to know where or what position the
character d is in my string random so
this is how i would use the index
function index and within the index say
i'm looking for the character d and now
i it should give me the answer 0 1 2. it
should give me the answer 3. so if i
execute this it gives me the index 3 so
this is the index function that we can
use for our strings now what if we want
to
say slice a string into a into its into
a smaller part we want to slice it and
we want to retrieve only that particular
size well here is an example say i'm
gonna i'm gonna use the same string
called random and it's stored in test
right so let's
so one way of so the way of doing this
is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if i went to my
string random a and d is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what i
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice
from the first position uh the first
index which is the character a up until
the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when i index like
this every every time i put something to
the right of this colon i am not
including this itself all right
so it's essentially one when i say uh
one colon for what i'm telling python is
give me the first the second and the
third character but not the fourth one
so it's given me a n and d and it's
that's this is how we do a slicing
operation in python similarly if i were
to say slice
from the first if i wanted only the
first and the second character i would
do this is what i would do
if i wanted the first and the second
character i would do one
two three so this way it says python
that i want the first i want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
i get a and n now so this is a basic
slicing what if i wanted the portion of
a string from a particular point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where i want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way i would do
this is
test now since i want it all the way to
the left i don't enter any index to the
left of my colon sign and since i want
everything to the left of the fourth
character i enter 4 here so as you can
see it gives me a r a and d which is
everything from the fourth character of
my string random to the left similarly
if i wanted something to the right of it
i would just do it like this i would
enter some index here and i would leave
the portion to the right of the colon
blank so this will give me everything
including the third character since this
is how we treat the
indexing in python everything including
the third character all the way to the
right so this is dom as you can see now
another perfectly valid um
slicing is say i want to slice or take
out
different characters from the string but
i want to skip certain characters like i
want this one then i want to skip one
and i want to take the next one and then
i want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step
so one way of doing this is now how do
we read this so as you can see i have
written 0 colon 6 colon 2. so what this
is telling python is i want every
character from my string test
starting from the 0th character up until
the 6th but not including the sixth
after skipping or taking two at a time
taken toward a time can also be assumed
as uh skipping one at each step or
skipping one character at each step so
what this will do is it will go to
random it will take the zeroth one it
will take r and then it will skip the
next one so it will not consider a and
then it will pick n and then it will not
consider d and then it will consider o
up until the sixth character whichever
that may whichever that may be and if
you see the output it gives us rno which
is exactly what we wanted we wanted r we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
a and d or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of
slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of
a sequence or a string uh we can use
negative indexes so if i were to for
example show you let's see what this
what this gives me test what what is a
minus one index it gives me the
character m now remember a string is
random so minus one gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if i used test
minus two it would give me the second
last character which should be the
character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in python for that
let's create another let's get another
string let's call it upper
lower all right i'm storing it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when i use the upper function
and what happens when i use the lower
function
now i'm going to use the lower function
for this
these two functions will respectively
give out or give us the result or give
us our string in uppercase and lowercase
respectively so as you can see the upper
function created the first string in
full upper case and the second one
created this bar the string in full
lower lowercase now another important
and probably one of the most important
methods that we use for strings
especially when it comes to data science
is
the split function so let's see what i
mean by split function let me create
another string let's call it hello world
all right and i'm going to use a split
function and i'm going to see what
happens when i
use this function essentially so what
i'm doing in these in this these three
lines is i'm creating the string hello
world i am storing it in test and then i
am using the split function on the test
and whatever result i get i'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
i'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
this string hello world is that i have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and i've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or add every comma so for example
if i wrote hello world using comma and
if i put a comma inside over here and
now if i try to execute this
like for example i'm going to find i'm
going to look for commas in the string
and then i'm going to try to split it as
you can see there's no splitting
happening i have one list with my
original string itself because it's not
found a comma what if i introduced a
comma over here now let's see what
happens as you can see the splitting has
happened it's found this comma and it's
caused a split between hello and world
similarly if i in my string if i put
this comma again and i put something
else it should give me the split over
there again so we can define our split
using some whatever we put
between these circle brackets after the
split function it's just important to
note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if i have two
strings first and say another string
second
and i want to join these together well
the operator i would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing let's see
what is the result
as you can see what this has done is it
has combined the first string first and
the string second into one string called
first second so this is the concatenated
concatenation operator now finally uh
the last topic in this lesson is the
topic of escape sequences now escape
sequences are special commands that tell
python to either suppress special
meaning of some character or symbol in a
string or give or give the special or
give some special meaning to an
otherwise ordinary character
in a string so let's look at the first
example now remember my in my for
earlier in this video where i was i was
telling you like
what what is the way of writing or how
do we introduce single quotes or double
quotes into a string and i had told you
the trick if i want to use a single
quote in my string
i just close it using double quotes or
if i want to use a double quote i close
it using single
well another way of doing this is using
what we call an escape sequence and an
escape sequence in python
is the backslash character all right so
let's see what happens when i use the
backslash character where i want to
introduce my single quote so if i use my
previous example where i wanted to
introduce a single quote and say
i'm going to close it using single
quotes
as well so i'm gonna go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if i
used the escape sequence that i
mentioned the escape sequence is just
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where i want my my
single quote so i introduce the
backslash now i have my single quote and
i continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python
to not read this
special character or the single quote to
not treat it specially and let it be as
a part of the string so as you can see
that's what's happened here now the next
case or the other uh use case of escape
sequences is when we want to
give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so
let's take the example of the character
t and the character n we use the
character t to introduce tab space um
and we use the character n to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
t has no special function so the
character t within a string will just uh
be outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here i'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does
it introduces this thing that we called
a tab space which is a larger than
normal space similarly if i were to use
the
backslash n combination this would
introduce what we call
a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where i have this combination of
backslash n a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other
escape sequences that you may choose to
learn and
these are just two of the probably the
most common ones that are used in this
video i will give you an introduction
into lists and tuples starting off with
lists lists are a collection of ordered
orbit arbitrary objects that are similar
to what we call an array in other
programming languages but lists are way
more flexible when it comes to python
python lists are a type of sequence and
we might have you might have seen what a
sequence is when we were learning about
strings and much like in sequences or
any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to uh
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way
or a simple list that i have just
created and assigned to a variable a
which contains three objects one two and
three let's talk about some of the
features of python lists python lists
are ordered and what this means is that
even if two lists contain the exact same
elements if they if the elements are
placed in a different order the two
lists are actually unique and different
and i can check that over here i have
created a list one two and three and see
if i create another list two
and one and three the same elements were
in different order i will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when i use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see i
get the value false because even though
i have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where i
show you list operations the next
property is list are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making or as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can
contain any arbitrary objects so if i
created a list right now where say if i
want to store some numbers
say some floating point numbers now
and i can put strings
as well into my list all of these are
valid
when it comes to objects that can be put
inside a list we have no such
restrictions so we can put any arbitrary
objects inside our list the final
property that i want to talk about is
that lists are
they can be nested to any arbitrary
depth what this means is that i can put
a list within a list and i can keep
nesting it essentially by putting
as many lists i want within my list and
i'm only essentially restricted by my
system's memory so if i created a list
like this
within this say i put another list and
within this list i put another list i
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and i'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that i'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where i'm storing six numbers
so now say if i wanted to retrieve a
particular element say if i wanted to
find out what's on the index 3 this is
how i would do it if i wanted a slice of
my original list and much like strings i
do it the same way so what this does is
it tells python that i want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it will
give me 1 2 and 3 index
objects so it should give me 2 3 and 4
in this case as you can see here 2 3 and
4. i can do the same thing by
considering elements
say 2 at a time if i wanted to consider
elements or consider every second
element what i would do is this syntax i
would use this syntax and when i give
this command to python what it tells
what it understands is i want every
element from a
from index 1 2 and x4 but not including
index 4 but i am going to consider two
uh every second uh uh element
essentially so what it will do is it
will go here and then it will skip one
and then go here and then skip one and
that's essentially what we uh what it's
essentially what we call start
slicing by using strides so i'm taking
strides i'm not considering elements
consecutively but i'm skipping certain
elements in between if i wanted to
consider every third element i would
change this to three and fourth element
i would change this to four all right so
let's see what happens when i take every
second element it should it should give
me uh it will consider say from one to
index three right so it should consider
essentially
this section but since it's going to
skip one it's going to consider this
skip this and then consider this it
should give me 2 and 4. as you can see
it has given me 2 and 4. and like in
other
sequences we can use negative indexes as
well negative indexing essentially
starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when i say a minus one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
the object six if i did a minus 2 it
gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
1. what this tells the
what this tells the system is i want the
list a but with all the elements
reversed so as you can see i get my
element
my list a but the elements have been
reversed right now let's move on to
uh concatenation and replication well
concatenation much like in strings is
done by using the plus sign so as we
know on either side of the plus sign
should be two similar objects so if i'm
doing a plus something a being a list on
the other side it should be a list as
well so let's add a list like this
now let's see what's in a
as you can see my original list has a
789 added to it and i can also add
things to the beginning of a list
similarly so if i wanted to add say
zero you know at the beginning of a list
i just do it like this
and i get the element zero added to it
it's very important to note that i
i i actually added zero within a list
because if i did 0 like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an int object and it's
not a list but when i put the square
brackets i make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if i did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where i'm repeating
the values in a twice if i did a star 3
it's the same function
but now i'll have the elements repeated
thrice as you can see here let's move on
to modifying list values
this also shows the mutable property of
lists that i had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so i created
a list with elements where there's three
strings eggs apples and carrots and i
have
five int objects one two three four and
five
now if i wanted to change say the first
element all i have to do is take the
zero width index
and say if i want to replace eggs with
say mango this is how i would do it
now i've replaced eggs with mango if i
check what's in b
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly i can
use these slice syntax to replace
a particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so
let's look at this
i'm replacing i want to replace the
first three elements i want to replace
mango i want to replace apple and carrot
so what i will do is i will consider
this since this carrot is the second
index so i will consider 0 to 3 because
the third is not counted now i'm going
to replace this with three different
let's see tv
and say sponge now let's check what's in
b you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact i don't have to
replace like for like if i want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if i want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how i'll do
it let's say
wine
now let's check what's here as you can
see three elements have been replaced
with one line i can do a vice versa as
well i can replace smaller number of
elements with a larger number of
elements but here there is a slight
caveat that i want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if i wanted to replace the first element
wind with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index
and then put whatever objects you want
say i want to add instead of wine i want
to add beer i want to add
ball
and
say
club yeah well let's see what happens
now if i say b
check what's inside my now you can see
my elements have been added but they
seem to have been added as is you know
i had entered a list over here and that
whole list has been replaced uh or this
vine has been replaced by this whole
list in the first position but that's
not exactly what i wanted i wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what i'm going to show you now
if i want to replace one if i want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 i would give this statement a slice
statement where i will give 0 colon 1 so
when i do this and if i
so let's create my old scenario again
where i had wine and i had one two three
four and five now if i do this b
zero but i give a slice then this slice
is essentially a single object slice
it's essentially the zeroth index again
but because of this uh formatting or
this this type of syntax that i'm using
what python will do is now when i say
beer
and
ball
and club now what python will do is it
will not consider this whole list and
add it to in place of
wine or whatever i want to replace it
will actually consider the elements
inside of this individually and then
replace so if you see here
now if you see my list i actually have
the
i've removed wine and in place of it
i've put beer ball in club but these
three are actually individual objects
within my list and not objects within a
list that is then placed within my
original list so this is an important
caveat that you should take note of so
moving on let's talk about certain
methods associated to lists let's take a
simple list now one two and three the
first
operation that i want to show you or the
first method is the append method so
when i do a append and say if i want to
append the list by one object called
four
i just do it like this now let's see
what's in a i put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if i wanted to
append
three different objects i want to append
five six and seven now let's see what
append function does
oh no as you can see it's done a similar
operation to what we have seen earlier
when we gave a single index or the
single element replacement
that we saw earlier it essentially put
this whole list into this particular
spot into the list and this is not what
i wanted i wanted 5 6 and 7 to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what i'll
show you next now if i want to extend
say the original list by three different
elements 8 9 10 when i use the extend
function it will not put this whole
thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what i wanted now the next
method that i want to discuss is the
remove method
so the remove method is what you how you
use it is within the parenthesis you put
the
object that is present in the list that
you want removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if i want the object 8 all
right
this number if i want 8 itself removed
what i will do is put the value 8 here
and it will remove it from my list so if
i check my list a as you can see the
value 8 has
it's gone a next another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value
and that value is what we have popped
out of the list so by default it will
pop out the right route right most value
of a list or rightmost element of a list
and in this case that element is 10 so
it should give me 10. but of course if
we want to pop out any particular object
in this case we do not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if i want to remove this
this list object from my bigger list
as i can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4
it's the fourth index so if i want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index i give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two key properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parent thesis instead of square
brackets so this is how i would define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that uh
differentiates tuples from lists is that
tuples are immutable and what this means
is that once we create an object of type
tuple we cannot make any modifications
to it we would have to only create a new
object if we wanted something different
and this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this
every operation that we have done on
lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so any operation that we did to
lists that did not modify the list or
that does not do any modification we can
actually apply to tuples as well so if i
wanted the first element of this duple
all i have to do is call it by the index
0 it should give me the value 1 as you
can see if i wanted a slice
i can do that as well it should give me
2 and 3. and if i wanted to reverse my
tuple well i can use my same neat
technique that i've used for lists and
that i can use for the sequence i mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use tuples over lists well one important
difference is that when we con when we
make a program execution where or where
we are manipulating a tuple if we do the
same thing for the exact same objects in
uh that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster than a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over list
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an ordered list of
objects that we don't need to or we
don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is
when we are using dictionaries
dictionaries as we will see later is a
data type in python that needs an
immutable component
while we are creating the dictionary so
if we
want to use
something that is like a list but since
lists are mutable we can use a tuple
instead and use that when we are
creating our dictionary and we will see
like what uh what i mean by uh the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuple
over a list a brief section on tuple
unpacking and packing is what i would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when i create when i give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be
me packing this tuple into a object or a
variable t now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that i can unpack a tuple
onto another tuple so let me show you
what i mean by that so now that i have
packed one two three and four tuple into
t let's unpack it into another tuple
let's call this let's
put these elements into this tuple and i
put this into t all right now let's see
what i mean by unpacking something onto
something let's see what's uh what what
what happens when i put a if i just want
to see what's in a it actually gives me
the value 1 if i see what's in b it
gives me the value 2. if i see what's in
3 giving value 3 and d gives me value 4.
so essentially if you think of it what i
have done is i have matched this tuple
then put it into t and then put that
tuple t into this tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been um
or a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a 2 has been unpacked on
to b 3 has been unpacked onto c 4 has
been unpacked onto d to show you what i
have done in a single line is
essentially this
this is essentially what i've done
i have assigned
1 to a 2 to b 3 to c 4 to d i have
matched these two tuples together like
this and this is a very neat feature of
tuples the only only important thing
that you have to keep in mind is the
elements of this tuple and the elements
on this tuple
should be equal so if there are four
elements here there should be four
elements here all right i
in fact another very important thing
about or a neat feature is that we don't
really need to mention the parenthesis
when we're doing this
unpacking or packing so if i did x
comma y comma z if i did it like this if
i put say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a
valid way of packing and unpacking so
now if i see what's the value in x it is
actually 5 if i see what's the value in
y it is 6. if i see what is the value of
x and z it should give me a tuple
containing 5 and 7 as you can see over
here so this is a neat feature of tuples
called packing and unpacking in this
video we will cover concepts surrounding
dictionaries dictionaries are another
type of composite data type in python
there are also a collection of objects
much like tuples and lists and like
lists they are also mutable dynamic and
can be nested however a key difference
and property of dictionaries is that
they are unordered items in dictionaries
are paired using keys unlike in lists
and tuples where the objects are
assigned numerical indexes to define a
dictionary we use curly braces each key
value pair in this dictionary in a
dictionary is separated using commas and
the key and values themselves in a pair
are separated using a colon let's look
at an example this is a dictionary where
i have three key value pairs as you can
see they have been separated by colons
and each of the pair themselves are
separated by commas and these are
enclosed in curly braces to define the
whole dictionary in this
example
these are the keys banana apple and
grape and their respective values are
yellow red and green so this is very
important that in this particular data
type we have what we call a key and that
key is assigned a value and we can have
multiple such pairings and we have three
such pairs in this particular example
another example or the or another type
of way to define a dictionary is using
the dict function this is how we use it
as you can see i have inputted two value
or two object tuples this is a tuple
this is a tuple and this is a tuple and
when i use it in a dig function
when i place it within a list what
python will do is it will consider the
first element of each tuple as a key
and the second element of each tuple as
its respective value
now if i check what's in d as you can
see the key banana has a value yellow
the key apple has a value red the key
grape has a value green this is another
way of defining dictionaries an
important
note over here is that
the
the objects that we use for keys have to
be of an immutable data type so we
cannot use for example lists
as an example of keys but we can use say
integers or strings for our dictionary
keys also keys have to be unique when it
comes to a dictionary you cannot have
two different keys with
or should i say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have a mutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if i
created a dictionary with a key say
banana
and if i gave if i associated with it
a value green i cannot create
another key banana and associate
a value yellow let's see what happens
when i actually do this if you actually
see
what has happened here is
python has considered the second case so
it's it first looks at the first pair it
goes okay so my dictionary has a key
banana with a value green but right
after it sees another key banana with
the value yellow so it overwrites my
first key banana with the second key and
it overwrites the first value green with
the second value and we essentially get
one key banana with the second value
yellow so obviously this is uh python
does this to avoid duplicates however if
i
created a dictionary with a key banana
again if i created i gave it a value
yellow or say green
if i created another
key and if i gave this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not
nothing special will happen in this case
because values do not have to follow
such rules let's speak or let's see
certain dictionary operation operations
and functions now so let's
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if i wanted to
we can use keys to
essentially do these operations and
functions let's see what happens when we
so much like how we use sequence how we
use indexes in example of sequences we
use keys when it comes to dictionary so
let's see what happens when we use a key
over here
so we as we know banana is a key in this
dictionary let's see what happens when
we do where we give this command it
actually gives the value associated with
that key which is yellow what if we
wanted to change a particular value
associated to a particular key i would
give i would do this i would give the
key and assign it
the value that i want to change it with
all right now if i check my dictionary
you can see the key banana no more has
yellow value but the value of gold what
if i wanted to add a new pair you know a
new key with a new value completely i
would do it pretty much the same same
way as i did in the previous step i
would
essentially write my new key whatever i
wanted say if i wanted a new key called
watermelon i would assign it a value
red
and now if i check my dictionary at the
end of the dictionary you will see that
my
new key pair key value pair has been
added watermelon red as you can see over
here now what if i wanted to remove if i
wanted to remove a key value pair from
my dictionary i can use the delete
function which is
called by using this the del function
now how do i do it say if i want to
remove the key value apple in red so all
i have to do is do d e l
d and within square brackets i have to
only mention the key i don't even need
to mention the value just the key so
you can probably draw parallels in how
we use indexes when it comes to lists
and tuples and even strings and how we
use keys when it comes to dictionaries
they are quite similar so if i did this
and if i um oops i think red is actually
not a key as you can see red is a value
my
key is apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if i see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operations that we can do
for dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is uh
enter a key inside the parent thesis and
it will get the value associated with
that key so
if i gave the key great let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green
there is also a function called items
that returns the key and value pairs in
our dictionary as a list of two object
tuples where the first object is
the
key and the second object is the tuple
so let's see what it does as you can see
it gave me a
list and in this list the
objects inside the list are two object
tuples where the first object is always
the key and the second is the value and
it's the same for each of the tuples so
this is what items function does let's
see what
the next so the next function is keys
let's see what the keys function does as
you can see it returns a list of all the
unique keys within our list i mean
within our dictionary similarly we can
there is a function for values as well
and as you can see it returns all of the
different values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say
a particular value say i had another key
where its value was green again so i
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the
pop function in list
it gives us the last entered
key value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon
key watermelon with the value red and
that's what has popped out when we give
this function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if i had a dictionary let's say i'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where
i have say
some key called kv so as i had mentioned
i will use two object tuples in this
case and um let's say i give this also a
value green all right and another
pair would be
say mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with the value yellow
and i already have a dictionary d with
these values all right
now if i want to merge these two
dictionaries i can use the update
function what i do is say if i want to
merge d with x or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if i want to merge d
with x i use d update and then inside it
i put my target dictionary now when i
check what's in d i have the
the dictionary x and its key value pairs
merged inside my original dictionary d
as you can see i have my original ones
here and i have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video i will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type hierarchy in python it's also known
as the data model in python and it
probably has other names so essentially
in the what we do or what we speak about
in this is uh how the different types
that we use in python are categorized
and classified and what are their
subtypes so it's important to note
before we continue further that they're
in future versions of python there might
be new types that are introduced or the
existing ones may be modified but it's
safe to say that
what i will speak about in this video
will still form the core of what we call
python standard type hierarchy so let's
begin so the first type is the nun type
uh it's accessed through the built-in
name none its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote um
functions or it's you it's returned as
the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it
then there is the ellipses ellipsis is
something that you might encounter later
it is accessed through the built-in name
ellipsis
it is used to indicate the presence of
this particular
syntax this particular symbol or
expression
or syntax in a slice its truth value is
true again don't worry too much about
ellipses right now next is numbers and
numbers is something that we are very
familiar with we have seen we've worked
with numbers a lot they are an immutable
type they are created through numeric
literals and they are the outputs of
arithmetic expressions and built-in
arithmetic functions its subtypes are
integers floating point numbers and
complex numbers
within integers you have plane integers
that represent numbers in the range
this number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation in two's complement and
this is the equivalent
for the the negative the negative side
long integers on the other hand are used
to represent numbers in an unlimited
range that is only subject to the
available memory of your system so these
are two types of integers and as we know
floating point numbers represent machine
level double precision floating point
numbers or numbers with a decimal point
and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating point number that represents a
real part and a floating point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed
by natural numbers so each element in a
sequence has an index and that index is
a natural number the different types of
sequences are based on the mutability
whether the objects can be changed or
not is essentially what we mean by
mutability right once we create an
object whether we can modify it or not
and that is how we differentiate
different types of sequences so there
are
mutable and there are immutable types
now the different types of immutable
ones are strings we know what strings
are they are sequences that contain
characters unicode is the other
immutable sequence and then there are
tuples tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and
there is only one currently there is
only one built-in
mutable sequence in python and that is
lists
lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects
finally we have well not finally but
next we have mappings and mappings are
again
sets of
objects but these objects are now
indexed using arbitrary
index sets you know the difference
between a mapping and a sequence you
could consider
sequences are ordered but mappings are
not ordered and
the indexes given to the objects and
sequences are always numbers they are
natural numbers whereas in mappings they
are not natural numbers but they are
certain arbitrary objects that we can
set for ourselves again in python there
is only one built in
standard
mapping type that is the dictionary
dictionaries are
there they represent finite sets of
objects indexed by nearly arbitrary
values the only condition is that these
indexes must be of an immutable data
type so
these so what i have mentioned until now
are probably the most common data types
that we encounter
or that we have encountered now so next
types are like callable types such as
user defined functions user defined
methods built-in functions built-in
methods classes and class instances so
again callable types as a whole are
referenced using the call function and
this is something that we will learn
when we start learning about functions
when we learn about object oriented
programming
and methods and functions and such the
other type are modules so modules are
module objects or modules essentially
are referenced or called using the
import function again modules can be
considered as these large libraries or
larger pieces of code or applications
that we
that contain various different methods
and functions and objects and classes
within them um again modules are
something that we will think about a
little later files are data types that
are called using the open function so
anytime we and as we will during the
course of this uh tutorial we
or during the course of this uh
this this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using
the function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types
finally there are internal types that
are used by python interpreter again
this is something that
does not concern us right now but just
know that
the interpreter for python uses these
data types for its functioning in this
video i will show you some of the
categories of operations that are
possible in python so let's start off so
the first category of operations are
arithmetic operations and as you can see
in this table there are different types
such as addition subtraction
multiplication so let's go over them one
by one so a simple addition operation
would be like 5 plus 6 giving me the
value 11 i can do 5 minus 3 that's
subtraction similarly i can do a
multiplication using five say five into
two there's division where i use the
backslash so say i did division of eight
divided by two now you might encounter
another type of division which is called
the floor division where we use a double
backslash and what this does is it
returns us the largest whole number that
is lesser than the result of our
division uh so the division difference
between the float division and the
normal floored and uh the floor division
or the single and the double backslash
is this say i did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when i do 9 double backslash 2. it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
flow division essentially finally we
also have
if we want to raise something to the
power of something so if i want to do 5
say 6 raised to the power 3 so i would
use double asterisks and this is how i
would do it it give me 216 as you can
see if i wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers i
will use the percentage sign so if i
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how i
would do it i get the answer one as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end all right so let's see
uh what we mean by this i am creating so
as we know the and operation returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so
that's actually let's actually do this
for an example let's give this variable
the value true and this the value false
actually should be done like this
false so now uh think of it like one and
zero so one and zero is obviously zero
right so if i did a
and
b i should get the answer false or zero
because i'm doing true and false so it's
like doing 1 and 0. so if you see this i
should get the answer false if i change
this to true as well now if i do this i
will get the answer true as you can see
the next logical operation is the or
operation where
well
logical or is if either of the operands
are true then we should get the
answer to our order operation as true as
well so in this case obviously if i did
or over here it will naturally give us
true if i change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us false if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is the logical not
it's done by using the not operator so
in this case the
value that we get
is true if the opponent is false so
let's take a as we know a is false over
here so if i did not a i should get the
answer true but if i change this to true
now if i do not a i should get false as
you can see so this was the
logical operations let's move on to the
next set of operations that is
comparison operations so there are a
bunch of them let's go over them one by
one if i want to check if two operands
are equal so if i did x is say equal to
2 and now y is equal to 3. if i want to
check if they are equal i will use the
double equals to sign and if
they are equal i will get the value true
if they aren't it will get value false
as you can see since x is 2 and y is 3
as you can see x and y are not the same
so there's false they are not equal if i
change this also to 2 now i will get the
answer to another the next comparison is
the
uh not equal to or where we use the
exclamation sign so over here this is
this um the result of this is true if x
and y are not actually it's the same so
i should get false over here as you can
see but if i change this to say 5 now i
will get true because x is not equal to
y in this case the next one is greater
than so if i did x greater than y as we
can see 2 is not greater than 5 i will
get false over here similarly there is a
lesser than if i did x lesser than y i
should get true over here as you can see
well there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if i say x is
less than or equal to 3 i should get
true because x is 2.
and if i put 2 here i should also get 2
but what if i put 1 here since x is
equal to 2 and 2 is not less than equal
to 1 this is a false statement and i can
do the same thing with like this using
the greater than equal to now it's true
because 2 is actually greater than equal
to 1. and so this was comparison
operations the next set of operations
that we can do in python are assignment
operations we've already seen a whole
bunch we've already been assigning
values to variables we've been doing
assignments throughout already but let's
go over them and see some of the
assignment operations so as we already
know the equal to operation is assigning
everything that is on the or the value
on the right hand side of the equal to
sign to what is on the left so if i did
a is equal to 5 plus 6 it will assign
the value of 5 plus 6 or 11 to a let's
check what's in a as you can see it is
11. there is a plus equal to sign and
what this does is so for example if i
did
say a now since a is 11 let's create
another variable called b and call this
five all right so now if i did a plus
equal to b what this will do is it will
add b to a and then store it in a so
let's see what this does once i do this
now let's check what's in a it should be
5 plus 11 as you can see 16. so this a
plus so this plus equal to sign is
essentially the same as doing a is equal
to a plus b it's essentially the same
thing they're both the same
there's a similar thing for this the
negative sim or subtraction as well
minus equal to so now that a is 16 and b
is still 5 of course if i did minus
equal to b now i'm subtracting the value
5 from 16 so i should get a is equal to
11 again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus b a is
equal to a minus b i mean as you can see
so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say b is equal to
i will say 2 all right now if i do a
star
star equal to b what this does is it
multiplies b to a and then assigns it
back to a so if i see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if i did a is
equal to 6 and b is equal to 2 and if i
did a sorry for division so if i did a
division symbol and
equal to sign and then if i give b what
it will do is it will divide a by b or
six by two and it will assign that back
to a so my value in a should be three as
you can see here 3.0 obviously this is a
single uh single backslash so this is a
float division the resultant of a single
backslash is always a float i can do the
same thing with a double backslash so
let's see if i did a is equal to 7 now
and then b is equal to 3. now if i did a
double backslash equal to b now it will
do the same division
but
it will do a floor function so it should
give me 2 in this case if i did the same
thing
with a single backslash just to show you
the difference between single backslash
and double backslash division in this
case it will give me um
the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment um say a is equal to say 5
now b is equal to 2 now if i do a
percentage symbol equal to
two i mean the it should give me it will
assign the uh it will take the modulus
on both sides and then assign it to the
left hand operand now let's see what's
in a as you can see it it did uh a
divided by two the modulus symbol is
basically the remainder of the division
between two objects so in this case it
will divide a by b and then give me the
remainder and then put that remainder
back in a and as you can see the
remainder of five divided by two is one
and we get that over here similarly we
can also do exponential so if i have a
is equal to say
5 b is equal to 2 and i want to raise a
by if i wanted to raise the value of a
by the value of b and then store that
back in a this is how i would do it so
it should be 5 to the power 2 which is
25 as you can see here so this is
assignment operations so finally we move
on to
uh two special sets of operators one is
the identity set identity operators and
the other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands
have the same location in the memory
essentially this does not mean that it
does not check for whether two objects
have the same value and this is very
important so let's look at this if a is
equal to 1001
and b is equal to 1000 plus 1 all right
if i did a is equal to this is an
equality check are they the same values
true now if i say a is b let's see what
happens as you can see it's false this
is because this object and this object
are not the same and this is what the is
operation does
we can confirm this by checking the id
of a the id of a gives us some value
like this and the id of b gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place in the memory as we have seen
using the id function and that is what
we check
through the is operator and the is not
is essentially just the opposite of that
so so that is the identity operator now
the membership operator is used for
checking whether something is present in
a sequence or not so let's create a
sequence i will create a list to show in
this example my list is one two and
three basically simple list with three
integer objects one two and three i will
check whether now say two in a so is two
in a if it is it will give me true as
you can see is 5 in a it should give me
false because 5 is not in a and the a
not in operator is just the opposite of
that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in python in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in python so starting off
what is this math module well the python
map module is an important library or a
feature that is uh designed to deal with
mathematical operations this math module
is part of the
basic python installation so you don't
have to install this separately
to use this math module all you have to
do is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import
math and this will import your math
module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video i will be showing you certain
concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the mass module some of the
arithmetic functions the logarithmic
functions um power functions and even
trigonometric functions that we can do
using this math model and the functions
inside the math module so starting off
let's look at some of the constants that
are part of this so as you can see
the standard constants are available uh
in this module are pi there is tau there
is euler's number nan which is a special
it's a it's a programming specific
concept and infinity uh so let's look at
these one by one so starting off uh our
first constant is pi um
pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circle's circumference
to its diameter and
pi is an irrational number you know the
value of pi is 3.14 something since it's
an irrational number it does not we
cannot
define it in terms of a specific
fraction but it can be approximated to
the fraction 22 by 7. so how do we
access this
pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the maths module
all you have to do is do match.pi and it
will give you the value as you can see
so as you can see the value returned to
us is a float this is important to note
and
the number of
number of decimal digits
the number of digits after the decimal
point that we can see here are 15 and
this is like a by default uh thing for
python that if you call the pi constant
it will give you the value of pi correct
up to 15 sma points so an example of
where we can use this thing is say we
have the radius of a circle three it can
be in any units three meters or whatever
you want and you want to find out its
say circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if i had to find the
circumference of a circle in my in my
code for some application with the
radius 3 or all i would have to do is
use the formula 2 pi r and to call the
value 2 pi r instead of specifically
writing 3.14 something i can just use
this function math
dot pi over here and then i can enter
the r as you can see it will return me
the radius as you can see so moving on
uh the next constant that we will talk
about is tau tau is uh similar to pi in
fact tau is the ratio of a
circle circumference to its radius pi is
the ratio of a circle's circumference to
its diameter and tau is the ratio a
circle's circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
two times the value of pi this is by
definition and
much like pi if you call the tau
constant in you from the math module it
will also return you a float number and
to find that this is the function that
we use or this is the syntax so as you
can see this is this is actually 2 times
the value of pi 6.283 and even this is
returned correct up to 15
places to the right of the decimal point
and this is by default uh next constant
is the euler's number uh the euler's
number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of sci uh in the scientific community in
the mathematical community um you will
be using the uh euler's number probably
a lot as uh if if you move into data
science or ai or something like that so
what is the euler's number it is uh it
is the
base of the natural logarithm if you
know what the natural algorithm is it is
used to calculate rates of growth or
rates of decay and as with numbers or
constants like pi and tau even the
euler's number is an irrational number
with infinite decimal places uh the
value of
the euler's number uh in short it's
denoted by the small letter e so this
value of e is
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this uh constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because infinity
doesn't it's not really a number there
is no number called infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive infinity something that
is higher than any known number to us
and negative infinity is lower than any
known number to us
so this is the concept of infinity and
how do we call this
function well so let's see what happens
when we call the math function math
constant infinity so this is how we do
it and as you can see it will return us
this
it might look like a string to you but
this is actually a special type in
python um which is not a string this is
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this uh infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can
you can consider as an equivalent to a
float but um it's not it's not a typical
float that we know like you know 3.14 or
2.71 the value of mather.if will give us
inf and this is this inf is actually not
a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when i do a
typed when i check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in python 3.5
a special type known as math.inf
it returns this inf data type
which is equivalent waste float
so this is this is how we use infinity
if you wanted to get the
value of say minus infinity all you
would have to do is math dot inf with a
minus sign preceding this constant and
you will get minus i and f now let's
check if uh the concepts or the
properties of infinity are uh maintained
you know like every a positive infinity
is greater than any number that we know
and negative infinity is greater than
any number that we know so let's just
confirm this um so i will take math
throat in and i will do a check
is this greater than say some really
large number something that comes off
the top of my head immediately okay so
let's see if it's if this is true then
uh this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact i can
change this number to anything as large
as i want this will be true because
infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know uh and similarly if
i did minus math dot in
inf uh and i checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus uh 10 to the power something right
this should also be true uh sorry it
should be a smaller sign symbol this
should also be true because i'm checking
minus infinity smaller than any node
number to us and it is true as you can
see so uh it's very uh also if you did
uh if you did something like so let's
say if we do
let's add something to this you know
it's a number so we should be able to do
arithmetic on this let's actually see
what happens when i add say 10 to
positive infinity it actually gives us
the same value back infinity because uh
intuitively we know that infinity plus
anything is still going to be infinity
right and this is exactly what python
does for us even if we add a number to
this the math dot inf or the infinity
constant in python it will still give us
uh the same value the same data type of
inf or infinity similarly if we
subtracted something from the negative
of math dot inf you know
say minus say again let's say minus 100
so if we subtract something from minus
infinity we're technically still minus
infinity itself so this will again give
us minus and then
minus inf as you can see and this is
absolutely what we need and this is a
very very interesting feature in python
finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the n a
n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant uh
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to
is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate a certain places where say a
variable that should have a
number um it's been corrupted for
whatever reason and it it now has a text
or a symbol and our code throws an error
then in these in these cases where
python expects a number from us or from
your code and it does not get it it will
throw you a n n-a-n
value and this is usually used in cases
where you have errors in your code so
again just to check like what this this
constant how like how to call it this is
how you actually do it math.nan and it
will give you a data type called nan
also much like the infinity constant
let's see what's the type of this um
this constant again might look like a
string to you but of course this is not
a string this is a
numerical concept and as you can see
it's still a float so this is like um
it's another special uh data type that
was created for specifically this case
where uh it's some it's the equivalent
of a float but um it's not really the
typical float that we are that we
associate with so this was a constants
in the math module so our next topic
will be arithmetic functions that we can
do in the
using the math module so some of the
common arithmetic functions that are
available to us are factorials the
ceiling operation floor operation
there's permutations there's
combinations you can find the greatest
common divisor or the gcd and the lcm or
the least common multiple and you can
truncate numbers so let's look at them
one by one so starting off with the
factorial operation the factorial
operation is done using the factorial
function as you can see here actually
defined like this math dot factorial all
right so now what we pass in between the
parenthesis will be
what we calculate the factorial for as
you know factorial is so factorial is
always for a positive integer and the
factorial for say a number 10 would mean
10 times 9 times 8 times 7 so on until
the number one obviously factor is only
defined for positive integers uh it is
not defined for uh negative values or
it's uh and it's also not defined for
decimal values so uh let's see let's
look at an example so
as we know um so let's say we pass
math dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so
this is exactly what we expect so we
expect the value of six times five times
four times three times 2
that is actually 7 20. let's see what
happens when we pass 0
this should give us 1 since we know 0
factorial is 1. now let's see an error
case where we pass say minus 5. as you
can see this will throw us an error
because factors are not defined for
negative numbers now moving on let's uh
so the next function that we'll talk
about is the sealing function so the
ceiling function is defined using math
dot see
seal as you see here so again we pass
the number that we want the ceiling for
in between the parenthesis so what is
the serine function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if i gave you 6.6 and
i asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at another negative number so
minus 12.3
an integer that is greater than minus
twelve point three uh is minus twelve
the smallest integer that is greater
than minus zero point three and this
should give you twelve as you can minus
twelve as you can see here uh a similar
function is the floor function which is
defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if i gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2.
again if we pass integers
it will
just give us the integer itself again it
is to reiterate this ceiling and floor
functions uh they give you integ
integer values so the floor function
will give you the largest integer that
is smaller than what we pass over here
so let's look at 6.7 so the largest
integer that is smaller than 6.7 is 6.
and as you can see this is our answer
over here uh the next function that we
will look at is the truncate function
the translate function is defined using
this truncate is very similar to what we
have seen this is how we define the
truncate function uh it is very similar
to the ceiling and floor
in the truncate function what we do is
we pass a decimal value a float number
to the
between the parenthesis and what we get
back is the number without the decimal
component so only the integral component
so if i gave it 7.8 for example it will
give me only the seven part it will
return me only the seven part and it
will chop away the point eight part um
if i give it minus twelve point three uh
it will chop away the point three part
and give me only minus twelve back so
let's look at an example 8.9 it should
give me only eight as you can see here
see i did minus eight
or minus six point nine this will give
me minus six so you can think of
truncate function as
it does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions
let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis i
have to pass two values n and k so i
have to pass n n and a k
the k has to be less than or equal to n
because the permutation as you know is
uh the number of ways in which we can
permute
from n objects k tie uh k different
objects uh so what this mathematically
what this is is um permutation of n and
k is n factorial divided by n minus k
factorial so if i pass say 10 and 6 it
will give me the permutation of 10 and
6. so let's look at what's the value as
you can see it's a very large value
15 150 1200 similarly is a combination
function and this is a combination the
permutations are used a lot in
probability so if you're going to move
into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in
machine learning ai you will be using
these functions quite a bit um so the
combination function again you pass an n
and a k again the n should be greater
than or equal to this k what this
evaluates is n factorial divided by n
minus k factorial times k factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6 so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section um our gcd
and lcm as we know gcd is the greatest
common divisor lcm is least common
multiple so as of the newest version of
python in 3-point python 3.9 the math
module gets these two new functions that
were very lately added actually um since
i i cannot show you that because i don't
have the absolute latest version of
python on my system but using the math
dot gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
would do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if i gave these say for
example if i gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the lcm
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst
whatever we pass over here so if i
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is their sim of
20 and 30. so again these are it's uh
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or
if you have python 3.9 or after that
you will have access to these functions
as well if you when you import the math
module so that was for the arithmetic uh
functions let's move on to the next
section which are power and logarithmic
logarithmic functions so let's start off
with the power function um there are two
there are uh multiple ways you know you
can actually do a power functional math
in python so you can do something like
this which is the equivalent of 2 to the
power 3 or you can use the inbuilt
module math and you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and uh if i had to do
same 2 to the power 3 i would just pass
2 and 3 as arguments like this and it
should give me the value as you can see
8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
model but it's still part of the
base python you use this as well and you
can do the same thing pow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
you know you might ask what's the
difference between these two functions
well it's not much for at least in a
beginner's standpoint it's not that much
uh just note that the math dot
power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah
moving on there next topic would be the
next function that we'll discuss is the
exponential function which is defined
like this again exponential function is
again e to the power something so if i
did exponential of 3
this would give me e to the power 3. as
you can see oh of course i did not
define the module beforehand so math.exp
now when i do this it should it will
give me some value which is basically
euler's number or e to the power 3. so
this was the exponential function and
let's look at uh an example so we will
look at the example of rate of dk and we
will use the uh this function in that
example so the exponential rate of decay
for
is used to calculate the amount of
radioactive elements that is present in
a substance after a certain amount of
time so the the
the the the expression is uh something
like the initial amount of radioactive
elements that were present
right at the beginning times the
exponent of minus 693 times t
t for time divided by the time period
the half lifetime uh so let's just write
it down to make it simple so again as
you can see the uh so this will give me
the remaining amount of radioactive
elements right so let's uh let's write
down the remaining let's assign this to
a variable remaining so the initial
again um initial is the initial amount
of radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100 um
the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
half-life
is
around i don't know let's give some
value say three or something again this
is uh the details are not important so
this will uh i'm using the
math.exponential function over here as
you can see and for these values uh now
when i check what's the value of
remaining after i calculated it it's
something so this is it's basically what
this tells me is that i started off with
100 units of some radioactive element um
and in 10 years if this is what is left
so yeah so this is how we would use say
the
exponential functions in a particular
example of ours so next the next type of
again functions are logarithmic
functions so let's look at some of the
logarithmic functions that are part of
the math module so basic log function
would be written like this math.log in
between this i would pass the number
that i want the log for by default if i
just pass one number it will it will
calculate the log of 8 to the base of e
as we know e is the euler's number so
let's see what it does in this case it
gives me some value what if i wanted to
specify a particular base well i would
pass a second argument in this case i
want to find the log of a to the base
two this should be the value three as
you can see over here
there are two specific functions that
are also provided in this math module
that is log 2. uh what this will do is
again it will again i have to just pass
one argument and this will automatically
find the value of the log of 8 to the
base 2 as you can see here
similarly there is a math dot log 10
function if i give if i did this i will
find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math uh the square root function is
math.sqrt
again we pass the what we want over here
if we want the square root of say 49
this should give me the value seven as
you can see finally maybe move on to the
final set of functions that we can do
using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
we can do sine we can do cosine and tan
some of the basic functions
the way we would do it is math dot sign
in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular
angle and this angle must be passed in
radians this is very important to note
we do not pass it in degrees but in
radians so if i say past
sine of
3.14 as we know 3.14 is an approximation
of the value pi
uh my sine pi is uh supposed to be uh in
fact it's supposed to be zero so let's
see uh we get something close to zero
again since this is an approximation it
won't give us the exact value
similarly we can use math dot cos to
find the value of a particular angle um
if you want to find
if you want to find the value of the
sorry the cost of a particular angle we
can use the tan function
in case
we wanted to find the tan similarly uh
we have the next set for arc sine and
the arc cosines of
the certain of angles so to use to find
the arc sine for example we would use a
dot sine i mean sorry a sine
for arc cosine we would use this and for
r10 we would use this the next set would
be hyperbolic functions again hyperbolic
functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas uh again the details don't
have to be you don't have to know the
details you just should uh you should
know that if you wanted to say for
example find out the
hyperbolic sign of an a of an angle we
would use math dot
sine h
and we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos sh
tan it would be tan h and if we wanted
to find the inverse of
the hyperbolic inverse what we would do
is what we would do is use a so we would
use a tan h if we wanted to find the
hyperbolic inverse
of sine we would use a sine h and
similarly for cos it would be cos
a cos h in this video we will learn
about conditional statements uh and we
will learn about how do we create these
control structures
where we have these conditional
statements we will learn about the
keywords that we use in python to create
a conditional statement block the if
keyword the lf keyword and the else
keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in python
so let's get started so the basic
syntax if you will for a if statement in
python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this uh pictorial uh if if there's
an if statement there is a expression
there is this block of code which if you
can actually see is slightly indented to
the rest of the code uh and then we have
the rest of the rest of our code after
that so what we're looking at is this so
this is our if statement block um now
let's let's break this down so what is
this expression that we're speaking of
uh an expression in this context is a
boolean expression which evaluates to a
true or false statement so when we are
speaking about the if statement we have
an expression and if this expression
evaluates to true then we execute
everything below the if statement
otherwise we skip that portion as you
can see if the statement is true we
execute this statement or these
statement blocks
otherwise if it's false we move on to
the next the next statement block or the
beginning of a new statement so let's
look at an example to further understand
this let's take this if statement over
here as you can see in this if statement
i have this expression 50 greater than
30 so what python is going to do now is
it's going to check whether 50 is
greater than 30 and it's going to check
in a boolean context if this is true
then we can move on to the next portion
which is this but if it is false then we
will skip this so let's see what this
what happens over here so since we know
that 50 is indeed greater than 30 this
is a true expression we move on to this
block of code which is saying that print
50 is indeed a larger number than 30. so
let's see if this actually gets printed
so as you can see we get this the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at uh what happens if
i give a false expression now i'm
checking if 50 is lesser than 30 which
is a false statement so if it's a false
statement we do not move on to this
portion of our if statement block and we
we directly in fact we directly skip so
if i have to execute this you will see
nothing gets executed in fact my print
statement is just not executed because
we never entered this because our
expression over here was indeed false so
yeah this is how a basic if statement
block looks like in python and this is
how the uh how we move on to
how we check for the true the truth
truthfulness or the falseness of a
particular expression in the if
statement so moving on um let's move on
to the topic of indentation in um in
python so as you can see
this uh this if statement is an example
of a control structure so without moving
without defining a what a control
control structure is
in detail control structures consist of
these conditionals or loops or
iterations if you will
so all of these control structures
involve heavy indentation so what does
an indentation mean well what if i gave
you an example say i gave you some
variable called h and i wrote 20 over
here now if i give you an if statement
saying if age is greater than 10 now uh
it's very important to note that when
i'm defining an if statement i need this
colon otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this colon is important uh
anyways so now i'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10.
now what is this what happens if h is
greater than 10 now what if i want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do i tell
python that there is a piece of code or
a section of code that i want executed
only if this condition is met well this
is where indentation comes into play so
if i want say if i want this line
this person is an adult again this is
some random line where i'm assuming age
is pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so
if i have uh this variable age where i
write this number 20 which denotes the
age of some person and i'm doing a check
if age is greater than 10 actually let's
be specific here well the adult age for
most people is 18 in most countries so
let's see if age is greater than 18. now
if i'm doing this check
i want to print this statement only if
this person is a person's age is above
20 above 18. so
how do i tell python that i only want
this statement to be
executed only during this if this
condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play as you can
see exactly as you can see uh this part
this portion of the code is slightly
indented compared to the if statement so
when this condition is met then only do
we move on to this if this condition is
not met we move on to whatever the next
section of code will be like whatever
whatever
code that we have after this if
statement so let's see so this since
this condition is actually met as you
can see this print statement is actually
executed so this is the importance of
indentation now we will see uh in as we
move as we learn more about if
statements and else statements and lf
statements how indentation plays a key
role in defining what we want as an
output when a certain condition is met
all right so for now it's very important
to understand that uh this is how
indentation is used in python in other
languages we might use uh we probably
don't use indentation in fact popular
language the c language uh does not use
indentation at all but some languages
and python and probably the trademark
language for uh indentation and
programming so you might say that yeah
so different people have different
opinions on indentation the general
consensus is that indentation helps make
the code look very presentable and very
readable and this actually is one of the
facets of python programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
multiple conditions in our code or if in
our if statement block that we want to
see so let's create this um list or
let's actually just copy this example
that i have written over here as you can
see what i am doing in this piece of
code is i have a list x where i have
this integer 50 i have two strings cat
and apple now i want to check a bunch of
things so i want to check if 60 is an x
and i also want to check if the string
cat is an x and i want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
i want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have uh one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the l if which
is kind of a short form for else if uh
so we use the l if keyword so it so what
this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is the keyword
used in our block to tell python that if
none of our earlier expressions have
been true then do uh what is in the uh
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is uh only we only
reach this error as statement in case
all of the other earlier conditions have
not been met or have uh come to be false
and not true so let's look at uh this
particular example so we have a list of
50 cat and apple and i'm my first
expression that i'm checking is uh is 60
in x so this is how we check actually so
if 60 and x should be read as is 60 in
the list x so is this 16 elix list x
well actually no we don't have the
object 60 so this part is not executed
we move on to the next condition is the
string cat in x well actually it is
the string cat is indeed in x so we move
on to this statement block which is
within the condition that is met which
is print cat is in list x and you will
see that none of the other statement
blocks will be executed because we have
met our condition over here so if i
execute this as you can see that uh the
print statement cat is in list x is what
is actually executed and we do not uh
execute this obviously because it is
false and we do not even check or we do
not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition met
over here
so it's a one thing that is important to
note is that we can use as many elif
statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for
but it's very important that we only use
and if we are using that we only use one
else statement and only at the end of
our block okay so moving on now i'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that i have over here is where i've
stored the string cat in x now i have
three um i have three conditions that
i'm checking i'm checking is 50 greater
than 60 i am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and i'm checking i'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by 0. so
let's see what happens when i execute
this statement now typically if i wrote
1 divided by 0 python will throw me an
error because 1 cannot be divided by 0
that is an error error in a statement so
let's see what happens when i do this
actually as you can see i have a
statement being printed but i have no
error even though i gave a wrong i gave
an error statement in 1 divided by 0.
well now you might ask why is that so
well it's simply because i have actually
never reached this condition i have not
even
python not bothered looking at this
because if you actually see there is a
condition previous to this
over here which is met and which is true
so we move on to this block we execute
this block and we forget about the rest
of the code so we don't actually get to
this error statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that i have shown uh to show you
that once a condition is met in an if
statement block we do not look at any of
the further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally um i have one
one small topic that i would like to
share with you is the conditional
expressions or the python's ternary uh
operator now this is slightly different
to the if statement that we have talked
about up until now
in the sense that it is not a control
structure so what this actually is is
more of an operator that defines some
expression so let's see what i am trying
to say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the
syntax for what i'm trying to talk about
this ternary operator so let's look at
this example and let's see what i'm
trying to do over here so i have this
variable age all right and this age is
26 now x now just just read this
statement x is equal to adult if age is
greater than 18 else child now i could
have done an elaborate control structure
with an if statement then an indentation
within that if statement and then
i could have written else and then
another indentation and i would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that i have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable x and this
what value i'm assigning to x depends on
if this condition is true or false so
as you can see the condition says is age
18 uh greater than 18. so if this is
true then i assign this particular
string if it is false then i go to the
else statement and i assign this so
since age 26 is greater than 18 i should
assign the string adult to x and as you
can see if i execute this and check what
is an x you can see adult is indeed an x
so this is a very neat a very needable
readable and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's it's a
better looking way uh to perform simple
else uh some simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we we make a short
note on the path statement uh in python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is a
placeholder of sorts so what if i had an
if statement and i'm writing a piece of
code but i don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true um but
i don't know what to do if this
statement was true
how do i tell python well let's just
keep it a hold for now and i might
put something into this block later in
the future well i would use the pass
statement so if i had this uh say this
some condition again so i'm checking age
is greater than 18 but i don't know what
to do with this i would just simply use
this pass statement and uh this
basically does nothing uh it it's a way
to it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future i
might have i might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently i don't have
anything to place over here so i just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is
a way where you can use a pass statement
in
if and as statement or infinites control
structures in this video we will be uh i
will introduce you to the concept of
iterations in python and we will be
speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
uh
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
indefinite iterations in python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and
below that is something indented again
we encounter indentations just like in
fl statements a set of statements where
what happens here is following the while
keyword we have this expression where
this expression is evaluated in a
boolean context again we check if this
expression evaluates true or false and
if it is true we
execute all the statements or the
statement block that is indented below
this file statement now this is another
example of control structure much like
uh infinite statement blocks where we
use a lot of indentation so let's look
at a basic example now of while loop so
let's copy this example and let's see
what this does so i have a variable n
where i am assigning it a value 0. this
is called an initializing process and
it's very important to note that most
while loops consist of an expression
which contains a variable a control
variable uh which
is usually initialized prior to starting
the loop and then this control variable
is typically very modified somewhere
within the
main loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and i am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's
move into the loop now so the loop has
this wire keyword as you can see
followed by a
an expression n lesser than or equal to
five now what this is is an expression
which is going to check if it's true or
false is n lesser than or equal to five
and as long as this expression is true
we will continue doing whatever is
indented below this while statement and
what is below this while statement is a
print statement first of all which says
value of n is and it basically prints
the value of n in that particular
iteration and as you can see this uh
compound assignment where we add the
value of n uh by 1 and we assign it back
to n so what this is let's see what this
does actually let's execute this and see
what this does uh important to note the
value of n again is initialized at 0. so
this while loop will keep going on until
the value of n remains lesser than or
equal to 5. so as you can see i have the
execution of this
particular block of code or this while
loop where i get the
multiple different iterations of this
print statement that you can see here
the first iteration it says value of n
is 0 then it's the value of n is 1. what
i'm doing is i am writing i am assign i
am writing
the value of n multiple times
and each time the value of n is written
over here based on what iteration it is
so what is happening actually is
that initially the value of n is 0 and i
print the statement value of n is 0. now
i add
the value of what is in n by 1 so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we
come back or like once this whole co
block of code is executed we again come
back to this expression and we again
check if the statement is true so now
that the value of n is actually 1 if
this statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is 1. now again we add
the value of n by 1 and again we go back
here once this uh this block is executed
and we check if the statement is true
again and as you can see the value of n
when it's 2 is still
making sure that this expression is true
and this keeps happening until the value
of n is greater than 5. so once the
value of n becomes 6 this condition is
no longer met and finally we do not
execute the statement because this
expression evaluates to false and we do
not do this anymore and we finally leave
our while loop so let's check what the
value of n is just to confirm this as
you can see the value of n is indeed 6
and that is why we have left this while
loop over here so this is an example of
a basic while loop where we check for
this uh an expression if it evaluates to
true we evaluate everything within it
once this is done we go back and we
evaluate this expression again if it is
again true we again go back into
whatever is indented within it and we
keep doing this until the expression
gives us false and interestingly we
don't we don't necessarily have to
define these control variables always we
can actually use uh iterables and we
will learn about iterables actually in a
future video but we can use iterables
and an example of an iterable is
the list so let's look at this list
and let's look at this whole block all
right so i created this list a which
contains five objects one two three four
and five all integer objects and i have
another variable a x where i store the
integer one now i'm this while statement
now it might look confusing now it's it
says it says while a now what is a well
a is not
your typical expression where you're
making sure if some condition is being
met or not but this the way you read
this is while a exists so in the context
of a list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we do like we we
have this value x where we um we're
doing this this we're printing this is
iteration number and
we pass x so the first iteration
obviously pass x is equal to 1 and then
we add x by one and then the second
iteration should pass this iteration
number two and then so on and finally we
have another statement within this block
called the a called the pop statement
where we're popping the elements of a
now as if you would have seen the list
the video and list the pop statement
removes the right most value uh from a
list so if i do a dot pop initially it
will remove five from this list and i
will have the rest of them again if i do
pop it will remove four from this list
and then you will have the rest of these
so let's actually see we'll actually
check what's left in this list each time
we do this pop statement so that i'll
also print the list
a each uh during each iteration and
let's see what happens over here as you
can see what is happening out here is
while a or while a has elements we are
going to continue doing this while
statement whatever is within it so in
the first iteration obviously we have
all of it
and it is iteration number one and as
you can see the list contains everything
then i pop it then iteration number two
it again has elements but it has lost
its most rightmost element and this
keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
element or events the list has no
elements left be
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while loop and again
let's check what is in a a should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when i check what's in a it's an
empty list and that is why while a
returned near false and we did not print
any further so this is an example of
using a while statement using lists
and of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and
this is a broad topic what i mean by
this is that when when i'm saying nested
while loops i'm actually talking about
nested control structures so we can have
while loops within while loops not only
that we can have if and if statements
within while loops we can have while
loops within if and else statements and
we can have if and as statements within
fnl statements so if you think of all of
these loops uh and we will even speak
about for loops in the in the in in
another video for loops again are a type
of control structure so all of these are
control structures while loops are
control structures for loops are control
structures if and have statements or
control structures all of these are
control structures and nesting can
happen within them and it does not
matter
which is the like the parent of the nest
and then the child or the nest you can
have a while loop within an infinite
statement you can have for loops within
a while loop all of this is valid in
python and it's one of the one of the
great features of python that is very
flexible in this way so let's look at an
example where i have a while loop within
another while loop so i'm copying this
piece of code where i have this list one
two three four five and another list
first and second now my first while loop
i print i print what is popped from a so
i take a then i pop the zeroth index so
basically from the left hand side and i
print what is that all right and then i
have another while loop where i have
this list b and i'm doing the same thing
but this while loop is within the first
while loop and let's see what happens
out here so as you can see my first uh
my first iteration of this parent while
loop causes me to pop what is the first
element which is one then i do these
while loops and this is completely
executed and only then do i go back to
this first one and then i come back and
do all of this again then i go back to
this one and then i come back and do all
of this again and that's why you can see
this repetition so i have this first
iteration and then i do
the second while loop then i have the
second iteration and then i do the
second while loop and i keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next topic in this
section this video would be break and
continue statements now break in
continue statements are
ways to abruptly end iterations uh in in
a particular loop you can use break in
continue statements not only in while
loop but you can use it and also in for
loops so let's look at how we use it in
while loops and let's look at what we
mean by breaking continuous statements
first of all well the break statement
terminates the loop entirely so once the
break statement is found the the
complete while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continuous
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether uh the
expression or the uh the controlling
expression is again reevaluated and it
is checked whether
the loop will execute again or terminate
this pictorial that you can see here
actually emphasizes or it shows the
difference between break and continue so
i have this while loop and i have an
expression all right i have a bunch of
statements and i have a break command
over here and i have a continue command
over here so if i encounter the break
command it will not execute any of this
in fact it will not execute this while
statement at all and it will move on to
the next piece of code that we have but
a continuous statement if a continuous
statement is encountered in a while loop
will not completely break away but it
will not uh it will not execute the the
rest of the statements in that iteration
only these two but it will go back here
it will check this expression again and
again we will do this all over again so
this is this small uh difference between
the break and continue statements but
both are used to abruptly end an
iteration in a loop so let's look at an
example of how we use the break
statement so i will use this example
where i have again i have initialized
some controlling variable n to 0
my first loop will check whether n is
less than equal to five if this is true
then i will print this statement then i
will what i'm doing over here is i am
incrementing it by one now in my
previous my earlier example using a
similar uh using the similar example
i had no like this this part was not
there so what you got was i was printing
the value of n so it was printing as
like value of n is one i mean zero and
then one and then two and then three
four and five but over here i've
included a small i've nested in if
statement and within that i put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2.
so once n is 2 i move on to this and i
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once
so when i have executed this i don't get
the whole value of n is zero and then
one and then two three four five i o i
stop at one and that is because once n
is equal to two i actually do not
execute this uh while loop again i do
not go back and execute print value of n
is 2 now in fact i break from this whole
while loop and my while loop terminates
right then and there and that's why you
only get these two iterations value of n
is 0 and then value of n is 1. okay so
now i'm going to show you a neat example
of what happens or what is the
difference between a break and a
continuous statement okay so let's go
back to our initial example where we're
printing this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4
and so on but i've added one more
statement where i print hello at each
iteration so let's see what happens when
i do this as you can see it will print
hello after each of whatever i was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when i do
break well let's
go back to this if statement if
if we check this condition then we break
let's see what happens now as you can
see something interesting has happened
where we have this first iteration
completely being executed but the second
iteration kind of stops where there's no
hello and that is because we have broken
from this while loop before the second
iterations hello was printed let's see
the difference between a break and
continue now so now i have this
continuous statement instead of a break
let's see what happens here as you can
see it seems familiar to our first
example where we did not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that i want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue statement so as you can see the
first iteration has value of n is 0 and
then hello the value of n is 1 but there
is no hello and this is because and this
is because once this condition is
actually met we do not move on to this
statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again where we print hello but except
for that one step where this if
statement was met and we did continue
and this following statement was not
executed and that happens only for one
iteration and that is when n is equal to
equal to two and as you can see that is
what happens over here in one of the
iterations we may say hello and that is
the difference of the continue statement
between uh there is a difference of the
continuous statement with the break
statement this video will be an
extension into that topic where we will
be looking at three examples where we
are using while loops along with other
stuff like say if and if statements so
our first example will be where we
calculate the factorial of a number in
this example
as you can see here we are first going
to ask the user to enter a particular
number for us now this number is
supposed to be an integer once we have
this integer we store it to a variable
called number now we have this you can
say this
variable called fac which does 1 and you
we will see how we are using it later
now we know that the factorial of 0 is
1. that's how it's just defined so we
have an if statement checking whether
our entered number is 0 and if it is 0
we say that the result is 1 or the
factorial is 1. however if we enter a
number that is greater than 0 we must
calculate the factorial for this number
and that is what we are going to do in
this else statement block over here now
in this else statement block we have a
while loop in this while loop the
condition is checking
while number is greater than or equal to
one so as long as this condition is true
everything within that while loop will
be executed so as long as number is
greater than equal to one we are going
to execute these two lines now what do
these two lines do let us see so the
first line takes the variable fac where
we had the number one stored and we are
going to store fac times number into it
number being the number that we have
inputted so in case for example we still
we entered eight then what this will do
this line will do is one into eight and
it will store that back into fac now
once that is done we move on to the next
line where we are decrementing the
number variable by one so if we have
stored 8 or we have entered 8 into our
input it will become 7. now as we know 7
is still greater than or equal to 1 so
this condition is still being met and
then we do this process again where we
are going to multiply fac this time fac
stores the value 8 and we multiply times
the new number which is 7 now so we do 8
into 7 and then again we decrement this
also once we do 8 into 7 we store it
back into fac and we keep doing this
where we keep multiplying 8 times 7 and
then we decrement the number variable
by 1 and then we check this condition
again so what ends up happening is we
are going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6
into 5 into 4 into 3 into two into one
and once we are at one again when we do
this decrement operation the number
variable will store the value zero and
then this condition will no longer be
met so number will be zero and this
condition will be false and we can move
out of this while loop then finally we
store the result into a variable called
result which stores the result of 8 into
7 into 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2
into 1. this is of course if we did
enter eight when we were asked to give
an input so let's see this
um in real time once we execute this so
i'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say i enter my number eight as i was
speaking about eight all right now that
i have entered eight as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
eight is four zero three two zero which
is correct and you can check this for
yourself where it will show you um eight
times seven or eight factorial is
basically this this number okay so now
in our next example we will be looking
at how we can generate fibonacci numbers
for this example we will be using bunch
of if and else if statements along with
a while loop so let's look at this piece
of code where we are actually doing this
so as you can see the first part of the
code is basically an input statement
asking us how many fibonacci numbers we
would like to generate and then the user
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an int into a variable count
now in this
if statement the first
if statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
fib next if our
entered integer is 1 we just store the
value 1 in this array called fib
if our entered number is 2 we store 1
and 1 in the array fib all of these are
different sets of fibonacci sequences
this obviously an empty and an empty
array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is two we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now
the actual calculations happen when we
say we want a fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the fib
variable with the first two fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we are going to keep
executing this statement block as long
as this condition is met or this
condition is true and what this
condition is is it's checking this
variable i which we have initialized as
1 over here and we are going to check
whether that is lesser than count minus
1 count being the number that we have
been asked to input if the statement is
true and as long as the statement is
true we will be executing the statement
block which is basically us appending
this expression into the
array fib now what this expression is is
basically it's going to keep adding each
subsequent numbers and we're going to
store each subsequent numbers back into
the
array fib so in this case if you see the
what the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first position of
the array fill and it will add it to the
value at the zeroth position of the
array fib and both of these values since
they are one and one when we add them we
get two and we append that to fib so now
our fib will look like one comma one
comma two then we increment this by one
and what we do is we uh do the same
process again so in the next step what
would be what we would do is we would do
two plus one so we would get three now
this would keep going on until this
condition is met or basically until uh
the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many fibonacci numbers i
would like to generate and i will say i
want the first let's say six fibonacci
numbers so i execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then two which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is three plus five so if we wanted
more numbers we would just enter over
here like say if we wanted the first ten
numbers it would give us
the first ten numbers in the sequence as
you can see here now in our next example
what we are going to do is we are going
to write a program which takes two
digits that represent the dimensions of
an array for example if we want a 3 by 3
array we will enter 3 comma 3 and we are
going to generate a two dimensional
array in which each of the elements of
the array are basically the row times
the column position of that particular
element and what i mean by this is say
we have a position i comma j on the
array the value of the
element at that position would be i
times j so for example if i'm looking at
something at the third row and the fifth
column or say the third row and the
third column for example the value of
the element would be three times three
and if i'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column i am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using code
so if you look to the right over here i
have a piece of code where i'm going to
in where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store these uh
these uh
dimensions in the
inputs
in a variable called input string so
obviously when we enter say five comma
five that will be stored as an in in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want
five say we enter five comma five we
want five as a separate integer and the
other five as another separate integer
and that is what we do in this
particular statement where we're going
to split up our input string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the zeroth position of
dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now
we are going to store the number of rows
as row number and that is the zeroth
position of this array and we're going
to store the number of columns as the
first position of dimensions or whatever
we've mentioned in the input so now we
uh we have this um our results array
called multi-list which is basically
what what our final array is going to
look like and we're going to store into
multi-list and
in this example we will be using for
loops to
do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi-list
saying that um we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initially
once we have initialized this array all
multi-list will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a five by five
array it will have basically a five by
five array with all elements as zero and
that's what this line does once we have
uh done this we are going to move on to
the for loop portion where we are
actually going to create our
array that we want so as you can see we
are our first for loop is going to say
for row in range row number so obviously
uh range will generate a
an iterator which can be iterated over
and since it says range row number and
say our the number of rows that we
entered were five what it's going to do
is it's going to create an iterator
containing the value 0 1 2 3 and 4. so
for row and range it will basically
basically row will take the value 0 1 2
3 and 4. and a similar thing is going to
happen in this nested for loop which is
within this where we're going to again
uh create a an iterator using this range
function and for the column number once
we have this we're going to do the
simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for loops we're going to first go by
each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example
now i'm going to say i want a three by
let's say a two by four matrix so let's
see what the results will be when i give
this as uh so what i'm saying is i want
two rows and four columns now as you can
see here it might not be very clear to
you right now but what you can see here
is this is the first row and this is the
second row and each row contains four
columns so these are the this is the my
final array that i get so what you can
see here is this is the zeroth position
and the uh or you can say this is the
first row first column first row second
column and uh since python is zero based
so this is actually the zeroth row and
this is the first row so as you can see
uh this this value basically zero times
one this value is zero times two zero
times three zero times four and over
here it is one times zero one times one
one times two one times three so
similarly if i did for example a five by
five matrix what you will get is five
rows now five rows and five columns and
for example like this particular value
is uh
one two three or zero one two three so
zero one two three and the first column
so this is three times one um if i took
this value this is like the fourth row
for example fourth row times the um zero
one two three third column so this would
be four times three which is twelve so
and uh each value of this has been
generated in the similar process so this
is an example of how we can use for
loops um for a particular exercise that
i have shown you right now in this video
we will be covering the topic of
definite iterations uh using for loops
in python so starting off we know that
there are two types of iterations in
programming definite and indefinite we
have already covered indefinite
iterations in the form of while loops
definite iterations on the other hand
are done using the keyword for
and the basic syntax or the standard
syntax for a basic for loop in python is
as you can see over here we have this
four keyword we have some variable we
have the in keyword and we have this
iterable and
we of course define this control
structure with the colon and then
indented we have this statement block so
once this for loop has started we
execute all of these statements within
the statement block as part of the for
loop iteration so yeah let's uh now
let's to understand like how for loops
work uh exactly let's uh look at the
concept or meaning behind what we call
iterables and iterators so so think of
it in a stepwise manner all right so we
in python we have different objects that
can be used
as iterables and an iterable is
basically some object that it's it's a
collection of other objects so you know
think of your lists uh think of
dictionaries and sets so all of these
are essentially collections of objects
so once we have these collection of
objects
we can create an iterator out of it
how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if i passed this
list a if i pass this list a through the
iter function and i store it in some
variable iter underscore a
and i see what is iter underscore a it
is actually a list iterator at some
random memory location which we don't
really care about similarly if i gave a
tuple and i did the same thing i will
create a tuple iterator and uh in the
left if you can see over here i've done
the exact same uh functions with sets
and dictionaries as well so i'm creating
iterators out of these
iterables so as to speak
now what is an iterator well an iterator
is
an object that
yields
values successively so
if my list contained five values or five
objects an iterator of this list will
yield these values uh one after the
other and that is kind of how or that is
the basis for which we do
we create loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this
using another function that we call the
next function so the next function keeps
moving from object to object within an
iterator so since i've created this list
iterator let's just do it once again so
as you can see i've created this listed
iterator item underscore a now with this
item underscore a what i'm going to do
is i'm going to use this next function
what next function does is starting from
the leftmost object within this iterator
i will keep yielding or i keep producing
the values so let's let's just see what
happens when i do next either when i do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when i do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if i did it again it gives me third now
if i kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now i get fourth now i get
fifth now natural question is now that
i've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if i perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens i get a
an error or and this error is the stop
iteration function error which basically
is telling me
look you have uh exhausted all of the
objects that were initially present in
this list a and you cannot you cannot
keep doing the next next function
anymore you cannot go keep going further
so yeah so this is what the next
function does when it comes to the
concept of iterators all right so now
we've learned two things what is an
iterator and what is the how do we
create an iterator out of different
collections of objects like a list or a
tuple and we've also learned how to use
the next function now let's
move or let's come back to our for loop
that we
started off this video with so our for
loop again let's consider our for loop
over here
as you can see some for loop with object
second one two three four and five all
right this is a list now i'm going to do
for x in a print x and let's try to see
what happens when we do this okay as you
can see when i have executed this it
gives me one two three four and five so
i have first of all let's look at this
for loop i in this for loop i define a
new variable x and then i say for x in a
print x and what's happening well in
each iteration i am printing whatever
the value of x is
at present so in the first iteration it
is the first object one in the second
iteration it is the second object two
then three four five and then finally uh
on its own like this for loop knows that
okay now once i have exhausted all of
the objects within my iterator i can
stop doing this for loop and i can move
on with the rest of the code all right
so think of it like a three-step process
a for loop in python the first step is
it calls an iter function to obtain an
iterator for whatever we pass over here
this iterable second step it calls the
next function repeatedly in each
iteration all right to keep getting the
next item from the iterator so it gets
one then it calls next then it gets two
then it calls next and it gets three and
then four and then five and so on and
then finally the third step is the
termination step is when after we do the
final next where we get this
error as you can see the stop iteration
error or exception finally this tells
the for loop function or the for loop
that um okay we have reached the end of
our definite iteration or the end of our
definite for loop and this is where we
must terminate our loop and then
continue with the rest of the code all
right so this is how a for loop works in
python now it's very important to note
that whatever we have discussed when it
came to while loops such as nesting of
while loops and nesting of other control
structures is also applicable in the
case of for loops so if i had a for loop
within another for loop that is
perfectly fine if i had a vial within a
for loop that is perfectly fine so all
of these are valid statement blocks that
we can do
and again for loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of
indentation when it comes to writing our
statement blocks within a for loop okay
so now i'm going to speak about in
specific i'm going to speak about the
this uh something called the range
function that is uh quite
you could say it's used definitely it's
used in other areas of programming but
it's widely used in python uh i mean
i mean the for loop in python now
what i mean by this is that um
range this range function is very
important for the for loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at um one of
the examples of using the range function
so what does the range function do is if
i give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from zero to five so it will
contain the object zero one two three
four and five and we can use this as an
iterator so let's let's look at this uh
i have range five uh let's store this in
x okay now let's do a type just to see
what happens when we do type x it should
give me the type of range as you can see
and this is a type of an iterator in
python now let's see what happens when i
do for i in x
print i okay let's see what happens as
you can see it prints the number 0 1 2 3
4. an important caveat when it comes to
the range function is when we say range
5 it creates an iterator from 0 to 5 but
it contains the objects 0 1 2 3 and 4
only it does not contain the object 5
itself okay this is something that is
very important too so uh once again i
created
i use this range function to create an
iterator from
iterator of five objects from zero to
four zero one two three and four uh i
use that in my for loop and uh that's
what that is what you are seeing here
now let's use this range function in the
context of something else for example
let's see so i had my earlier list a
right look at my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function
on top of the length of this list a and
this is uh like i can't show you an
example right now without any context
but this uh this form of using a for
loop is used is widely used in
python programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and ai i cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for loop
expression so you have four
let's say i
in
range len
a let's see what's going on here first i
create first i do length of a that gives
me 5 then i do range of 5 that creates
an iterator between 0 and 4 right when
you do range 5 it gives you an iterator
of 0 1 2 3 and 4 as we saw earlier and
this is what we're doing over here we
have created an iterator out of the
length of a list
now when i do print i it should give me
again 1 2 3 4 0 one two three four of
course so as you can see here it will
give me zero one two three four and this
is a very neat way of using the range
function on top of the length of a
particular collection of objects in this
case we're using the list a this is
something that you will use a lot so i i
would recommend that you get used to
this form of creating a for loop as well
using the range function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statement as you have in
the case of while loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
break in continue statements and
follow-ups uh finally i would like to
show you something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or as an
iterable when it comes to for loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so i created this
dictionary a alright so i have
dictionary a
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pass it through the iterator function as
you can see and now i'm going to just
for the sake of showing you it will show
i'll show you that it is actually an
iterator of type of a specific dict key
iterator type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary i
have the key first that has the value
one i have the key second that has the
value two i have the key third that has
a value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now
a good question would be when i do
iteration or when i do a for loop on top
of this a well what is it going to pick
up is it going to pick up first uh is it
going to pick up the keys like these or
is it going to pick up the values or is
it going to go one by one key and then
value and then key in the subsequent
value
uh let's see what actually happens let's
do four i in
uh iter underscore a written i let's see
what what is the iterations happening
upon using this so as you can see we're
using the keys
so by default when we do this when we
perform when we create an iterator out
of a dictionary we use only the keys as
our uh
iterator elements or at iterator values
but of course like if you wanted to use
values all you would have to do is pass
a dot values over here and if you
remember from a dictionary video this uh
a dot values gives us a a list of or it
by it gives us the essentially a list of
the values in our dictionary so when we
pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is it underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location so it's not the dict key as we
saw earlier it's a dict value iterator
so now that we have this dict by
dictionary value iterator now let's
print what are our iterator elements and
as you can see now we are printing
values and not um the keys so this is
how to these this is basically two
different ways of iterating through a
dictionary one through keys and one
through values in this video we will be
doing a small exercise on if statements
now in the previous video you might have
already seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we're checking if a
variable x is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement else we
move to the statement block now our
variable x has the value 5. now since x
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something
where we are checking multiple
statements we use the l if statement in
such a case so
now in this block we are checking in one
of the one of the conditions we're
checking is if x is equal to 5 or if x
is greater than 5 and then finally if
both of these conditions are not met we
say else and we print whatever or we do
whatever is in this particular statement
block which is a simple print statement
so as you can see x is indeed good is
equal to 5 so this is the block that
will get executed as you can see here
now another example are nested if
statements so nested if else statements
are if else statements within if else
statements so let's look at an example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
where we're checking what is the price
is it lesser than 5 if it is we do this
block else we execute this block finally
if our initial
statement our initial condition is not
met we move on to this else block now
when i execute this what should happen
is i will enter this block because this
is true and finally i will enter this
block because this condition is also
true so i should have this printed i
will buy five dozens as you can see here
now let's move on to our main exercise
for this video so this was all just a
revision now we're going to use some or
all of these concepts in a sample
project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice
so in this exercise what we're going to
do is we're going to request the user to
enter a number between 1 and 20 and our
our code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter
now we use this in keyword to make sure
that whatever we have entered into the
input box is stored as a int data type
in the enter num variable
once we do that our first if statement
is going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
lesser than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered an invalid number now
once we have
say entered a valid number we move on to
this block this is in
if else if elif statement block now what
this block is checking is whether the
entered number is an even number or not
now as we know an even number is
divisible by 2 and leaves the remainder
0 when divided by 2. so this is what
this check is doing if this check is
true that means our number is even and
we get printed that our number is even
the other other check or the other
if statement is checking whether it's an
odd number and that means when we divide
by 2 we should get the remainder 1 as
you can see here and we get printed your
number is odd so let's execute this and
see what happens when we enter a number
now it's asking me to enter a number
let's say i enter 17.
now that i have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that i've
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if i entered something
else here let's say if i enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if i what happens when i enter an
invalid number let's say 25 now i enter
25 as you can see it says i have entered
an invalid number and in this case what
has happened is this condition itself is
not met and i have moved on to this
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when i enter 9 the
first check that happens of course is
this check whether it's a valid number
or not and since it is between 1 and 20
we move on to this block and in this
block is checking whether our number is
divisible by 2 or not and since it is
not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is odd as you
can see here in this video we are going
to learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we're handling large and different types
of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image files video files etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like xml
css html files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do on
by in python on files they are open read
write and close
there are certain other operations as
well like rename delete so some of the
most basic operation that we can do is
obviously creating and opening a file
and the syntax is as you can see here
where we store where we use the open
command and we give a file name and we
give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write only mode which is done by letter
w and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by r plus and we're going to see
them as we encounter them now the it's
important to note that what i just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do
for binary files we're going to do this
file handling then we would be using the
letter b in front of whatever we were
using in the case of text files so if we
were doing a read-only mode for opening
a binary file um we would be using rb
and if we were doing read and write mode
read or write only mode for a binary
file we would be using rb plus
so basically just adding the b in the
case of binary files let's look at a
basic example when we want to open a
particular file we are going to like in
this example i'm going to open some file
called
filehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and i'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if i wanted to do it
for the binary file since i'm using a
binary file i will use the letter b as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters we can use
the readline command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters is denoted by n over here
and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of
where i'm going to print something
called so i'm going to take this and i'm
going to do a print on top of this so i
have done first i've opened it and i've
stored it in my file and then i'm going
to do a
a method or a function called read and
i'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that i have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if i wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when i do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off in our from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how
python handles files so if i wanted to
again take the cursor back in such an
example i will have to open this again
and then i use this read command once
again to get back to where i started
from as you can see here now another
command that we can use is the read line
command so let's uh once again open this
over here and now we are going to use
the read line command
over here so what redline command is
going to do is going to each time we use
this command it's going to go one by one
and read each particular line from this
file so in first case it will take
artificial intelligence then data
science big data and so on so as you can
see if i execute this it first takes
artificial intelligence now if i did
this command again
it will say data science next time if i
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the read line
command now within the readline command
also we can enter uh characters and that
will tell us basically um that we want
these number of characters from the next
line so if i want the first six
characters of the next line i will say
six i will enter six here and it will
give me the first six characters of this
particular line which is the next line
that is to come as you can see here now
another way in which we can
print whatever is there in our file line
by line is by using a for loop so again
i'm going to open this file i'm going to
store it here now i'm going to use a for
loop saying that well for line in my
file and what this does is basically at
each each iteration it's going to take
each line and store it in this variable
that we end over here which is called
line itself and we're going to print
that at the end of the loop what we'll
have is all of the lines have been
printed one by one and another thing
that we can do right now is say we want
to read a particular line say i wanted
you to read the fifth line of my file i
can use this technique where
i just say okay i'm going to store 5 in
this variable called line number and i
have this
another variable called current line
which i'm going to initialize with one
and i'm going to any i'm gonna what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
do the same loop where i'm going to say
4 line in my line but i'm going to add a
condition saying that only if current
line when it's equal to line number am i
going to print the line and then i'm
going to break out of this whole thing
and at end of each
loop i'm going to say current line is
going to be incremented by 1 until
basically these two variables are equal
so when i do this i get my result which
is uh machine learning which is the
fifth line of um
my which is the fifth line of or
whatever file i had now we're going to
move on to the topic of um image file
handling so we we saw how we handled and
we we saw certain operations around
text files um and text files are
obviously something that we're going to
use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
uh such as images a lot and let's look
at certain examples and certain
use cases around image file handling so
my first step is going to be importing a
bunch of modules and packages now the
details of these modules and these
packages are not important as of right
now because they will be covered in a
future video
but just keep a note of some of these
packages such as um they say numpy and
image the image
package so once i've done this let's
move on to my example so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings uh i've attached
the uh this prefix r to say that this is
a read-only uh sort of a prefix so the
next topic that we're going to be
handling is image file handling now we
have already seen many examples
pertaining to text files so text files
are obviously something that we're going
to be using a lot but image file
handling is something very important as
well and we're going to see certain
operations that we can do around image
file handling so starting off i'm going
to import a bunch of um packages and
modules
what these packages exactly are and what
these modules exactly are are right now
not of that important i'm not not that
important to you right now but it's
something that will be covered in a
future or in future videos uh it's
important to just keep note of what
these are such as numpy and image so
once i've done that what i'm going to
store is i'm gonna store two particular
file locations into variables location
one and location two and i've prefixed
them with r just to say that these are
raw strings so once i've done that i'm
going to use the image
from the image package i'm going to say
open and i'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and i'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we have done this
we can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file
it attributes the it identifies the
source of an image and if the image is
not read from a file it is set to none
we can also see the size of the file
using the size attribute and we can see
the mode which basically defines the
number and names of the bands in the
image and also contains the pixel type
and depth certain common modes are like
l for luminescence rgb for true color
images and cmyk for prepress images so
let's look at them so when i
access this you can see my first file is
of jpeg of this size and an rgb format
image and my second image is another
jpeg slightly bigger image and again rgb
now we uh can also of course display
these images and to do that we can use
the plt um again plt is the is supposed
to stand for a matte plot lip dot pi
plot it's a particular for a particular
package
that again you don't need to know the
details of right now but this is how we
would
do this so
i'm going to use a bunch of
commands and methods such as figure and
subplot and then i am sure so once i
have done this as you can see both of my
images with this being im1 this being
im2 have been produced on the screen as
you can see i can also use display this
display function followed by the name of
the file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now
i can obviously
save a particular
image using the save function which is
as simple as doing this so i'm going to
save the image as i am underscore save
dot jpg over here now if i wanted to
crop an image i can do that as well so i
initially i stored the dimensions that i
want
cropped in the form of a tuple as you
can see here and i'm going to pass that
tuple to the crop function and i'm going
to apply that on top of im1 and i'm
going to store that to region once i've
done that as you can see so basically
what i've done is i've cropped this
image based on whatever passed here and
i've stored it into region and now if i
wanted to see what was actually in that
crop i can just
do the i am show function and i am going
to pass the particular cropped image
which is denoted by region as you can
see here and you can see my cropped
image is basically a certain a left
portion of this whole image has been
cropped out and i have produced it over
here now i can also use the copy
function using it's a simple basically
copy base you use the copy function and
it copies an image onto another variable
that you have assigned and when i use
the i am show function i'm going to show
you the copied image which is basically
the same now we can do the transpose
operation as well so let's see some of
the uh let's see what we've done here so
in this transpose opposite operation so
in this uh basically i've done a bunch
of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once i'm done with all
of these multiple operations i am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever i have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling
i have shown you two slightly more
comprehensive examples on
text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling in
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for audio files and even for
like stuff like pdf files and uh this is
like this is just only the beginning and
i'm sure you will encounter a lot of
different use cases different examples
as you continue learning
python programming this video is going
to be the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object-oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
its behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change breaking similarly if i gave you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and define certain
functions called methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form of a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own
unique set of information that is one
way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and then instance now for our
first example on classes i will be
taking you through a class where i've
defined based on the circle object so
this class is going to define basically
information about your general circle
such as its radius and its area so let's
go through it now obviously to define a
class we need a keyword well in the case
of classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here a bunch of def
keywords followed by so something that
you might not be familiar with and i
will try to get you through this so if
you see here you have a def keyword
followed by init and this init is
prefixed by a double underscore and it's
suffixed by a double underscore and you
can see the same thing for str and repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method these are of
course methods this is a method this is
a method this is a method this is a
method now any method that is prefixed
and suffixed by double underscores are
called dunder methods
these dunder methods are or can be
thought of like predefined or built in
methods for
any class that you define so these we
have like a three under methods over
here and we have one user defined method
that we will get to so this first method
that you see here is the init method or
the initialization method and this is
invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class circle and what we do here is
basically we pass um when we create this
instant circle uh we are what what
happens is that we are we get an option
to pass an a value for
a
w what is this
keyword or variable radius so if i pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um i will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the
radius that will be passed whenever we
create an instance for this uh class is
one um the str method is basically used
to return a descriptive string for the
the instance of um class um our api is
not something that you have to bother
with right now and uh now get area is
something that you should follow because
if you see here i have not used any
double underscores so this is a user
user defined method um user defined
methods are it's a method that we define
and these are like tasks that we define
on our own so in my user defined method
called get area i will be returning the
area of the circle based on the radius
that i passed to it now if you notice
here the before every
in every
method i have the self keyword before
any other attribute so
like this herself this herself even the
get area herself now what this means
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically um
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
i'm going to use get area function i am
going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on only the
current instance of
that particular class self is obviously
optional we don't really need it but
basically the first attribute of any
method is
is basically the is basically what the
mel is is the instance that
the method is invoked upon so if i say
self i'm telling
this particular function that okay all
the value that you're going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that particular
instance where you have been invoked
itself now don't worry if all this is
very confusing um this might be in the
beginning but just try to understand
that this is something that we do for
good practice and you will understand
when 20 yourself or when not to yourself
as you learn about object oriented
programming so if you see here my get
area function is supposed to return the
value radius times radius self dot
radius is basically telling um whatever
value i've passed for radius for that
particular instance you can read this as
radius times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi r squared which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where i am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line i have created
an instance of the class circle where i
have passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable c1 now the print
c1 function invokes the str self-defined
or predefined function now if you
remember str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we define on
our own in our example str will return
the uh the string saying this is a
circle with radius off and then it will
return the radius that we passed so in
this case it should say this is the
circle of radius 2.1 as you can see over
here so if i execute this you can notice
this line this is a circle with radius
2.1 and this is invoked by the print
function the print basically invokes the
dunder str function which does all of
this now in the next line we say print
c1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of the or what what gets
returned when we invoke the method get
area for this particular instance c1 so
obviously in this particular instance
our radius is 2.1 so the get area
function should do pi times 2.1 square
and the value is as you can see here is
some 13.85 so that is the area that we
got now if we want to print a particular
radius um we just say print c1 dot
radius so this will print the value of
what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name c1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say c1.getarea if you want
to find out what is there in the radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1.radius now before we
move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is um for example um
like for example if it's camel case well
each word that is part of this class has
its first letter capitalized variables
and method names are in lower class so
if my class was called circle we say
class circle with c being in capital now
moving on let's talk about how we
initialize or define instance variables
now instance variables are declared
within the init method if you remember
from the earlier example of circle init
is a dunder method it's followed and
it's preceded by double underscore as
you can see here now if you see in this
particular case i have again used the
self keyword and as i mentioned earlier
the self keyword is the first parameter
of all member methods um
and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
the init function basically initializes
each and every new instance of
whatever of our class so we can give
init any number of parameters but the
first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value
of for radius in our variable radius now
instance uh the i mean the init function
is not a constructor but it is an
initializer to create instance variables
the init function also will never return
a value and it is optional and can be
omitted if there are no instance
variables now let's move on to
class variables so now as we mentioned
earlier all the attributes that are
created inside the init function are
instance specific attributes and the
instance attributes are obviously
specific to a particular instance of the
class for example all dog objects now if
we have a class called dog then all dog
objects have a name and age but the
values for the name and age will vary
depending on which dog we are talking
talking about or basically which
instance of the dog are we talking about
now class attributes are attributes that
have the same value for all class
instances and we define a class
attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called circle and we have this
initializer again where we have a class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object which
stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance of
the class circle and unlike the
variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance okay now let's talk
about instantiating an object and let's
see what happens when we create two
different instances of the same class so
as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle and i'm
going to check its id well if you see
the id is something like this now if i
created another instance over here
called c2 and if i check its id well
it's something different now so if you
see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our
memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on
the introduction into oop let's talk
about class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are um
usually declared are actually declared
with the
at class method operator or decorator as
you can see here it accepts the class as
its first argument so in this case i am
going to say i'm going to define a class
called myclass i'm going to use this at
class method decorator to say that
whatever follows here is going to be a
class method and i've defined a class
method called hello that takes in a um
that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever i have
passed to it in the form of hello from
self.name now what this this is going to
do is basically it's going to give out a
string saying hello from uh name of the
whatever class we have and um whatever
we pass the attribute name so oh in this
my particular in this case i'm going to
invoke this method using the class name
itself i'm not going to use an instance
name because i have no instance in this
particular example and since this is a
class method it can be invoked using the
class name itself so i'm going to pass
rakesh and let's see what happens when
we do this as you can see the first
print will basically
give us the information of the class
itself it's saying that the class is
called myclass and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from the string name my class with
a
comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakish next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if i say class dot
class uh if i define a class myclass in
this example
and i'm going to define another function
called hello as you can see i have not
used any decorator like at a class
method so this is going to be an
instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so i create my
instance called my instance1 and it's an
instance of this class and then i'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this.operator and the instance
name and the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method which is
declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
i have defined a static method i've
defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here i've created my instance and
i'm gonna say dot hello it should
basically pre-print print hello world
that's all in this video we will
continue that discussion on op with
inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way i will show you an example where i'm
creating a cylinder class which is going
to be a subclass of the circle class
that you might have encountered in the
earlier video on op so what we're going
to do is create a cylinder class that is
a subclass of circle where we're going
to get the attributes radius and get
area from circle class and we're going
to add the attributes height and get
volume to the cylinder so right off the
start you can see we have our class
circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self.radius now we
also have a description string which
basically is a uh down to a method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to the cylinder class
you can see that i'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name but you can see that i have added a
parenthesis and within it i have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that i want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
define a subclass in the most basic way
you enter the name that you want and you
enter the name of the superclass that
you want the subclass to be if a
subclass of in parenthesis right after
the name now next if you move on to the
dunder initialization
the initialization is very familiar
familiar except now we have another
attribute for height which has a deeper
default value of one just like the
radius so this basically means that we
have an option of entering two different
attributes for our cylinder instances
now if you see here there's a line which
says super dot init now this is like um
this is a command which we use to invoke
the super classes initializer so anytime
we create an instance for cylinder we
also want an initialization for the
circle method as well as a part of our
cylinder instance next you can see that
um much like how we stored self uh i
mean the radius attribute in self.radius
uh we're also storing the height
attribute in self.height now even this
uh cylinder class has an str method to
return a particular string if we use
this print function and finally we get
on to a more a new method that we have
defined only for the cylinder class
called get volume now
if you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of
the cylinder that is being described in
the particular instance for which we
enter the height and the radius so if
you can see here
what we basically added extra is an a
height attribute and another method
called get volume and the other parts of
the circle superclass such as radius and
get area are also going to be a part of
cylinder even though you do not
explicitly see them anywhere here and we
will see how in uh in the form of an
example that's coming up so let me just
execute these classes now that that's
done i'm going to create an instance for
cylinder i'm going to store it in cy1
and i'm going to pass 1.1 for the radius
and 2.2 for the height and once that is
done let's just print um to invoke the
hdr method and as you can see the sdi
method basically tells us the
information that is a cylinder with
radius 1.1 and height 2.2 so now let's
print what is the value we get when we
use the get area method now it's
important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the superclass simply
by accessing any other method so if you
use the dot get area you can see that we
get a value for the area of the cylinder
so this basically this area is basically
the area of the circle face of the
cylinder uh the top or the bottom now
let's use now let's invoke uh the
subclass specific method which is the
get volume method in a similar manner as
you can see just by uh doing invoking
this method we get the volume as well
now um if we want to see what is the
radius and the height we can just do a
simple print statement followed by cy1
dot radius c1 dot height and it gives us
both of these values as you can see here
now over here what i'm going to do is
create another instance of cylinder but
i'm not going to pass anything for
radius or height so basically it's going
to take the default values for radius
and height which was one and one
respectively so once i print um
this is this statement is basically
going to print the str method or
whatever we stored in the str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once i execute this as you can see
here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what i'm going to show you is uh
now i'm going to go back and i am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the superclass of course and
i'm going to give it and since the
superclass has only one option
one attribute that we can enter which is
for the radius so i pass 3.3 and i'm
gonna print what what happens when i
just print uh this instance it's going
to basically give us whatever was uh a
part of the htr method after that i'm
going to print is instance this is
basically a check on whether c1 is an
instance of this class circle and x i'm
going to check if c1 is an instance of
its subclass cylinder now when i execute
this you can see that well this is what
we
this is the str method that gets printed
but if you see here um you can see that
it says c1 is indeed a an instance of
circle when it says true over here but
when we look at the next line is c1 in
instance of cylinder it says false and
this is obviously because um a
superclass object is never
an instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one base class and
one derived class from that base class
so this is a simple
single inheritance and in this example
you can see i have a class called
country where i have a method that i've
defined called show country which is
basically going to say print this is
india it's basically going to print this
every time we invoke this show country
method then we have a class called state
which derives
from the
superclass called country where we have
a method called show state which is
going to say print this state every time
so you can see i created an instance of
the class state and um through that
instance i can access the super class
and the uh subclass methods over here
next we have the multi-level uh sorry
multiple inheritance and this is when a
derived class contains more than one
base class so let's look at an example
to understand this so if you can see
here i have a class called student with
the two methods defined called method
one and method two in method one we can
pass uh two attributes sn s o or i think
is this this is supposed to be like uh
an id i guess like sn number and we have
s name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass um that are
probably descriptors for a student and
um in the next method you have basically
uh two print statements which says
student number and then they will print
the student number and uh it will also
print the student name next we have a
class called marks this is also um so
these these two classes are basically
what our super classes are going to be
and we're going to derive a third class
from these two so this second class is a
class called marks and we have two
methods again one method is called set
marks which has um the option of putting
in two attributes m1 and m2 both are
representative of the two marks and we
store them in self dot mark one self
talk mark two the second method is uh
put marks which is uh going to print the
marks um namely mark one and then it's
going to tell us how much marks are
there in the first subject for example
and another print statement doing the
same thing for
the second subject or mark two finally
we have a third class called a result
which derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis i've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result i have
two methods specific to this derived
class called calc wherein i'm going to
basically calculate the two the total
marks of um
uh the the total marks which is
basically the addition of mark one plus
mark two and i'm then i'm going to have
another method called put total which is
going to print me what is the total so
if you can see here i have created an
instance of this derived class called a
result and i'm storing it in r then i'm
going to access method one which is
obviously a method from the first
superclass called student um and i'm
going to store okay so that his uh name
is i guess lucky and he has 60 marks uh
secondly then i'm going to do our set
marks which is the method from the
second super class which is going to set
the marks uh respectively so you have
lucky student and his id is 60 and he
has got 50 and 60 marks respectively
in say the first two subjects and
finally i'm going to access the derived
class method called calc so this is
going to do the sum
finally i'm going to also do our method
2 which is
going to print our student number and
student name next we're going to have
put marks which is going to tell us the
um what are the individual marks for
mark 1 and mark 2 and then finally we're
going to print the total marks with the
put total so once i execute this you can
see here it says student number 60
student name lucky marks one is 50 as i
had written here marks 260 as i passed
here and then total is 110 which is
basically 50 plus 60. our next type of
inheritance is called multi-level
inheritance now multi-level inheritance
can be assumed as where you take a super
class let's call it a and you derive a
class b from that class a now what if we
derived a class c from b and we kept
doing this so until say a class e now
each of these steps is uh in its own an
inheritance but this whole relationship
can be described as a multi-level
inheritance so let's take an example
again so after this this time i've
defined a class called student where i
have defined two methods called set stud
and put stud or you can call it set
student and put student in my first
method i have options of adding two
attributes again this is the student
number this is the student name in my
second method i am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first
class called student this has two
methods called set marks where i'm going
to again get the option of adding two
integers for m1 and m2 which is going to
represent mark 1 and mark 2 and finally
i have put marks the method which is
going to print mark 1 and mark 2.
finally i have another class called
result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and uh
even as a part of this third class we
have its own
methods called calc and put total
calc will calculate the total as we had
seen earlier and put total will
basically print that total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class uh result and store it
in r um then we're going to do basically
we're going to set the student details
uh his uh student number and his name
we're going to give him his marks 50 and
60. we're going to calculate what are
the total we're going to say okay now
put the details of what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter i mean display his marks
mark 1 and mark 2 and finally we're
going to display the total marks so
let's execute this and if you see
it's basically the similar operation
that we did earlier but the only
difference is in the earlier example our
our third class result was derived from
marks and student together so this was
an example of multiple inheritance
whereas in this example the result class
derives from marks and marks itself
derives from students so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
finally we have um sorry not finally
penultimately we have
as our fourth example of inheritance
called a hierarchical inheritance apart
in my mispronounciation it's
hierarchical inheritance so in this case
a base class basically will contain more
than one derived class so let's see a
look at an example of what we mean here
so i have a class called one where i
have defined a method called display
where what i'm going to do is i'm going
to store self.x is equal to 1000 and
self.y is equal to 2000. then what i'm
going to do is i'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and i'm going to say
after that i'm going to print another
statement saying value of x is a self.x
which is going to be 1000. uh then i'm
going to have another print statement
saying value of y is self.y which is
going to be 2000. finally i mean next i
have another class called 2 this this is
going to derive from class 1 as you can
see here and in this class 2 i have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what i'm going to do is
i'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then i'm going to actually print the
result of x plus y which is 1000 plus 2
000. finally i have another class called
3 and this is also deriving from 1. so
if you notice we have one parent class
called one and from this one parent
class we're going to derive two
different subclasses called two and
three so this is an example of
hierarchical inheritance now in this
class three what i've done is i've
defined a multiplication method what i'm
going to do is print first of all i'm
going to print this when i invoke this
method that this is the method in class
3 finally i'm going to say i'm going to
print the result of x times y which is
1000 times 2000 so if you see i am going
to create an instance of two and i'm
going to create an instance of three and
i'm going to store them in t1 and t2 now
since uh t2 i mean t1 is an instance of
two so i can access its methods add and
i can access this methods display so i'm
going to use t1.display and even into
t2 i mean since it's a class
it's an instance of class 3 and this
also derives from class 1 i can also
access its method display but now i
cannot access add but i can access
multiply so if you see here i access add
through t1 instance since add is a part
of class 2 whereas multiply
is is a method in class 3 so i access it
in its respective instance which is d2
so if you see here now once i execute
this what you will get is basically um
the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from
class 1 which is the display method it
will display the values of x and y and
since i've done this twice from two
different instances it will basically
show a repetition over here finally i've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class 2 it is going to say as
much that this is a method in class 2
and then it's going to say x 5 is 3 000.
and now multiply is a method in the
third class so it's going to say this is
a method in class 3 and it's going to
tell me what is the multiplication
result finally we have what is called
hybrid inheritance and this is a
combination of multiple plus multi-level
inheritance that you saw earlier so
let's again understand this through this
example so we have a class called
student where we have a method called
set student
again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so
we have a method in class marks called
cell set marks where we can pass two
attributes for mark 1 and mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for marks 1 and marks
2. we have a class called practical
the spectacle is basically a another
super class if you see here since this
does not derive from anything it is
super class on its own and what it does
is it uh it has two methods get
practical um and we can
pass an attribute for p1 here and we
store that in self.p1 and then we have
an attribute for
put practical which will print us the
practical mark whatever we passed for
this attribute in p1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marx itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derives from marx
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to
do a total of the marks
in this case mach 1 plus mark 2 plus the
practical mark p1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student uh the student class um said
student method so we're going to set
student here we're going to say 60 is a
student id and name is ash then we have
set marks which is again the
the second level parent which is a
student class where we set the marks
finally we access this get practical now
if you notice get practical is part of
the practical uh super class so in this
we store the third subject or the the
practical marks hundred then we
calculate the total and we put uh first
the student details then we put the
individual marks then we put the
practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted
is shown over here in this video we will
continue our discussion on object
oriented programming with the topic of
polymorphism now the term polymorphism
in oop refers to the ability of an
object to adapt the code to the type of
data it is processing polymorphism is
one of the key concepts of python and it
is also a built-in feature of python an
example to get us started on
polymorphism would be how we use the
plus operator we use the plus operator
not only for arithmetic additions but we
also use the plus operator for stuff
like string concatenations or joining
two lists together this example where we
are able to use the plus operator for
different different operations is an
example of polymorphism to show you what
i mean i have basically done a simple
addition operation here where i'm adding
two variables number one and number two
when i do it on integers it basically
adds one plus two now when i use it on
two strings str1 and str2 which contains
python and programming two separate uh
strings and when i use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms
one string containing both of these
individual strings so this is basically
the plus operator showing polymorphism
and is one of the simplest occurrences
and yet most common occurrences of
polymorphism in python another example
of polymorphism would be through the
lens function the lens function in
python is something that we use a lot
and over multiple data types depending
on the data type that we use the length
function for we get a different value or
a different
sort of information from the length
function now if you see here from this
diagram when we use the length function
on a string it gives us the length of
the string when we use the length
function on a list it gives us the
number of items whereas if we use the
length function on a dictionary it gives
us the number of keys so this is well
another example of how we have
polymorphism in a function now what we
are going to do is look at the different
techniques through which we can enable
polymorphisms in our code our first
example that we are going to look at is
through method overloading now method
overloading in its traditional sense
where we can have a method with the same
name uh more than one method with the
same name in the same class is
not exactly possible in python so if we
have multiple methods with the same name
in a class in python which may differ in
uh in types and number of arguments are
not allowed and not supported in python
in fact if we did something like this
where we created a method with
different uh with different say types
and number and arguments but having the
same name um in the same class then what
python will do is it will only recognize
the the last defined method and uh it
will
not recognize any of the earlier methods
with the same name but we can simulate
polymorphism through method over
overloading by using default arguments
in a method now for example what i'm
going to show you here is an example
where i have a method called sum now by
default
it has three attributes that you can
pass through this method a does not have
a default value b does not have a
default value but if you notice c has a
default value 0. so this is a simple
example where i'm going to show you that
the sum method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case we're going to simply add
two digits uh i mean two numbers and in
another case we're going to use the sum
method to add three different numbers so
we have this class overload demo within
it a method sum and i have three
attributes a and b are
have
are supposed to be given by the user
since they don't have a since they do
not have any default values whereas c
has a default value of zero so if you
see here in my first case i have uh i
first of all created a an instance
called over an instance called od for
the class overload demo and uh i have uh
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
store the value of the sum of 7 and 8 in
the variable sum now if you see here i
have not passed a third argument so what
this method is going to do is is going
to take the value of c as 0 by default
so it's basically going to do uh seven
plus eight and it's going to give us the
sum for seven plus eight and in the next
instance i'm going to give three
arguments seven eight and nine so now c
will be replaced by nine instead of zero
and then i'm going to get the sum of
seven eight and nine so in this this is
not a very use
not a very commonly used thing but it's
basically a method just to show you that
we can actually simulate method
overloading in python by using default
arguments so i've basically shown you
how the same how the same method sum has
been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but
you'll basically notice that by having
this third attribute c i have a default
value of zero i have induced some form
of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already
in one of its superclasses now if there
is a method in a superclass the method
having the same name and same number of
arguments in a child class
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chat class will be executed and executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called
is called based on the object type which
is an example of polymorphism so let's
look at an example to understand this so
we have a class called person and we
have defined uh what we're going to
define the initializer is two attributes
which we have to pass called name and
age and we're going to store them in
self.name and self.h now we have a
user-defined method called display data
where we are going to print if this
display data has been called through the
parent called person um if it's going to
be called through the parent class
object then we're going to print
in parent class display method and then
we're going to print the name and age
that we have entered now we have another
uh class called employee which is going
to be a derived class 1 person so it's
going to um so it's also going to have a
an initializer and this constructor will
basically um what what this initializer
will have is it'll have an uh
constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the
superclass but we're also going to store
another attribute called id in self dot
employee id and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same named method from
person but now if you see in display
data i have every i have all the same
almost the same information i'm going to
print the name i'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
i'm going to say if i'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then i'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically i'm invoking this method from
the child class object and i'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
i'm printing before i'm also going to
print the employee id so if you see here
i have created an object called person
which is
an object of the class person with the
information of name john and age 40. and
then i'm going to display this now next
i'm going to create an object called emp
which is the child class employee object
which is going to uh now have the same
information of john for the name and age
40 but now is going to have an employee
id and then i'm going to store this
in amp and i'm going to display the data
for this child class object and we will
see the difference in how the display
data is differing from the earlier
earlier case so when i execute this you
see the in the first case it says in
parent class display data method so this
display data has been called through the
parent class object and i'm only going
to show the information of name and age
whereas when i invoke this method from
the employee class object it's going to
say it's going to specifically say that
it's a in child class display method
then i'm going to say the name is and
also the employee id over here so this
is the difference between how display
data has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding now our
next example of polymorphism
is going to be through operator
overloading an operator overloading is
the ability to overload the operator to
provide extra functionality in
additional to its real or core operation
and operator overloading is also an
example of polymorphism as the same
operator can perform different actions
the earlier example of where we use the
plus operator for different operations
is an example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when is
operator overloading required well um
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what i'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where i'm
going to store two attributes x and y in
sub dot x and y and septa instead of x
and self.y now i'm going to create one
object called p1 where i'm going to
create point uh one and two so you can
think of this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another point
called uh x coordinate three x one four
i'm going to call that p two now i want
to print p one plus p two all right now
if i try to execute this you will notice
an error it says unsupported operand
types for plus point and point this
basically means that plus does not know
what to do when it's given an object of
this type it has no idea what to do
whereas what we wanted to do is add the
the the x coordinate from this point and
the x coordinate from this point so we
wanted to do 1 plus three and we also
wanted to do this y coordinate plus this
y coordinate or two plus four and then
we want to print basically like
something like four comma six or the
addition of the two points
or the the vector addition of these two
points so this is what we
want this plus operator to do but the
python does not have any inbuilt feature
for the plus operator and we are going
to have to basically do some operator
overloading to create a polymorphism on
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internally
internally invoking the add method so uh
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for the
operators are part of big a bigger class
of methods known as magic methods and
these magic methods are automatically
invoked whenever its corresponding
operators are used so we want to change
um the or the operation for um the plus
operator in this example we are going to
have to use the the add method in this
case and since it's a magic method uh
magic methods are also
are basically what we saw earlier in the
in the form of dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore
a prefix and suffix to it so similarly
to how we defined an init of an init
method or an hdr method we are going to
also invoke the add method using the
same double underscore before and after
its name so now let's see how we're
going to do this so if you see this
class i have now my class point and i
have the same uh initializer where i'm
going to store x and y now i am going to
define on uh these this add magic method
i am going to override the the normal
functionality of plus and i'm going to
give it a very specific function where
i'm going to say um for two two
different objects you're going to add
its uh the first part the first part or
its so-called x-coordinate with the
other x coordinate and it the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when i pass one and two and three and
four it should return me four and six as
you can see here i have basically done
what i wanted to do by operator
overloading i have changed or i have
overloaded this add this plus operator
using this add magic method and i have
created a new functionality for this add
function for these two points one and
two three and four now i'm able to add
one comma two three comma four in the
way i want it to so now that you saw how
we did operator overloading i'm just
going to show you um a list of uh
similar magic methods for different
operators that we are familiar with so
the plus operator already we've seen has
the add method then we have the minus
operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh
dunder's in python so this is how we
would do operator overloading in python
for whatever operator we want uh
similarly we can do this for like
comparison operators and for unary
operators as well so look at this
example now where i'm going to overload
the multiplication or the asterisk
operator so i've again defined a point i
mean a class called point i'm going to
define an initializer but i'm going to
store some attribute x and self.x now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
overload the multiplication operator
where i'm going to basically allow the
uh this asterisk operator to multiply
two objects uh from like for example
twelve and five usually i can just do a
normal 12 times five but in this case my
object is slightly different my 12 is
being passed through an object of a
class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when i want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we define
or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do
using the attributes of these classes in
its respective
class instances so it's able to say okay
so i want this attribute from this
particular instance p1 12 and i'm going
to multiply it with the attribute 5 from
instance p2 whenever i say p1 times p2
or p1 astrix p2 so when i executed it
will give me 12 times 5. similarly i can
also do this for the greater than
operator over here so i have a class
called person where i'm going to define
an initializer where i'm going to pass
name and salary and store them in
self.name server.salary the
gt method is basically the greater than
method magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload the
greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator i'm
able to basically say object one greater
than object two and i'm basically able
to check through this and
if object one is greater than object two
it will basically tell us if it is true
or false or uh basically whatever like
we want to know so basically the print
statement will check for uh object one
dot name and it will say earns more than
object two dot name if in case object
one is indeed greater than object two so
when i execute this you can see here uh
my first information says john has is
earning forty five hundred some units
natasha is earning six thousand of some
units so it will say uh john earns more
than natasha well it's false because
object one is not greater than object
two so uh since forty five hundred is
not actually greater than six thousand
and this is the check that i'm doing by
overloading the gt operator over here
where i'm so where i'm returning the
boolean value of
what is greater self.salary or other dot
salary self being the first
object in any comparison so in the if
i'm basically any comparison if i'm
doing say if i'm doing five greater than
five greater than six so what the gt
will do is this will be the self object
and this will be the other object so
this is what i'm doing over here i'm
checking self.salary with other dot
salary in in the form of these objects
and it's basically the same same way
that we we are able to do five plus five
through these class instance objects
that you saw earlier or 12 times five
that you saw earlier so this is
all examples of operator overloading in
python in this video we will be taking a
brief introduction into what is a
function so a function in python is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task or tasks now
functions help break our program into
smaller and modular pieces of code and
it's very good and very
convenient to use functions to make
our code organized and manageable
especially as our overall program grows
larger it also helps us to avoid
repetition and makes the code reusable
so let's look at the basic way of
defining a function so this is the basic
function that i'm calling fun
underscored name all right
now the rest of the function or whatever
the task is going to be performed by
this function will be my written over
here within indent of course as a
standard when it comes to python so i'm
going to define this one
something in triple uh double quotes so
don't worry about what this is right now
this is
a doc string don't worry about what this
means and i'll explain it to you just in
a short bit all right
now now the rest of the statement the
rest of it uh will obviously be what
this function will do let's include a
simple print statement
all right let's uh it's done here let's
call this
so of course once you define the
statement function to call the function
you just have to use its name like this
this is how you call a function so as
you can see when i call this function it
should print the statement hello now
let's go let's uh look at some of the uh
like what happened over here so we've
used the keyword def to define a
function we give it a unique name which
makes it uh which with which we uh
uniquely identify this function um and
also once we've done this
we um we can give it uh we can give this
function a particular header uh it's
called a dot string so what this
docsting is basically something that we
include in triple quotes over here just
after the def keyword and
this is like a brief we can use this to
give a brief uh info give brief
information into whatever function is
doing so we can say this is uh this
function performs addition this performs
um
subtraction or whatever like some basic
information as to what our function does
so we can use a dog string for that um
of course this is an optional thing this
does not have to be we don't have to
include this as well all right but for
the sake of this let's just keep it here
after that of course rest of the
function
will contain whatever tasks we want to
do with it and that will be indented
finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is
at any point you find the return keyword
in a function you immediately leave the
function you go back to where this
function was called okay so
now let's see um now there's also one
more important uh component of defining
a function and that's parameter now if
you noticed over here within these
parentheses i did not include anything
this is like an empty path this is
opening and closing what if i said a if
i included some a and b over here so
what this means is whenever i call this
function i need to pass two parameters a
and b these can be like strings or
numbers or whatever
but now it becomes almost mandatory that
i pass these two things for my function
to
to work so let's define a function where
i'm going to add a and b so instead of
this print statement let's do this i
create a variable c and in that i'm
storing a plus b all right and then i
return c so you can use a return and you
can you you can return certain like
variables along with the return
statement so i'm saying not only return
from this function but also give an
output or return an output called c
which is the addition of a and b now how
do we use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this i'm going
to add better i'm going to include
parameters so i'm saying
pass 2 and 3 to function name where 2
will take the place of a and 3 will take
the place of b all right what will
happen now is addition will take place
and we will get return the result so
let's see what happens now as you can
see two plus three and i got the data
the addition of two plus three and it
returned me five so yeah this was like a
basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so
of course uh we can if you want to know
like what a what the
doc string of a particular function does
or or says uh you can use this uh
particular you can use this like um
statement so let's say
so uh it's very important to like just
keep a note in your uh while you're
going through this so while you're
learning that uh whenever we use some
sort of a function which has double uh
underscore right this is like a built-in
a built-in command provided by python um
within the python library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so i want to check
what is the dog string and this is how i
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is basically what i
wrote over here i can change this to
this
like this does
addition for example all right now this
will say this does addition when i
execute this line so this is the way to
check what is a dog string anyways so
now that you have seen a basic
basic function or two basic functions
that i defined for you and how we use
them what a parameter is let's look at
another concept that we call scope and
lifetime of variables so scope of
variable is the portion of the program
where the variable is recognized all
right now a parameter and a variable
that are
defined inside a function are not
visible from outside the function this
is a very key thing
so if we define something within the
function we can only use it within this
function and we cannot
like we cannot use it once the function
has already been executed so as to speak
um
these variables and these parameters uh
have what we call as local scope since
they are only
recognized within a particular function
now the lifetime of a variable is the
period throughout which the variable
exists in the memory itself and it's
very important to note that lifetime of
variables that are defined inside a
function
are as long as the function executes
once we return from a function
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so
when we use a function um it will not
remember the values of a variable from a
a previous iteration of a function call
so let's uh try to understand this
example or this concept using certain
examples so
out here i have defined a function where
i'm going to create a variable my
underscore var my variable and i am
going to store the value 10 in this and
then i'm going to print so whenever i
call this function i will always create
this variable i will store 10 and i will
print the value of this all right now
what i'm going to do is i'm not only
going to create this myvar inside this
function i'm also going to create a
variable outside so you see there now
you might be confused as to okay how is
the behavior going to be because outside
the function i have created my var with
a value 20 but inside the function i
will always define my virus 10 okay now
i'm going to print so my first what i'm
going to first do is i'm going to
execute this function that i created
initially where i store the value of 10
in my bar and then i'm going to pray and
print the value of my wire that was
present outside the function let's see
what happens you can see two different
things happening so when i execute this
function it prints the value inside the
function as 10 but when i print the next
line which says
okay now get the value of my var
it actually prints a value of 20 and
this is a very key concept because
what's happening here is when i
initially call my function within this
function it creates a variable called
myvar and it prints the value as 10 and
the moment my function has been executed
it destroys this variable and
the variable which contain the value 10
is of course now destroyed and all we
have is the my wire that contains 20
from the outside and when we print that
we get its respective value as 20. so
you can also think of it like this the
my wire that is present inside this
function is different to the mywire that
we create outside so the scope of the
mywire within this function is local
only to this function and once the
function is executed that variable is
destroyed all right now let's look at a
another case or the other side of this
case where
say we're dealing with variables that
have a global scope how do we deal with
them so let's create a variable called
mywear all right and i say i store 100
in this all right now if i define a
function i've stored my word let's say i
define a function define underscore say
again same name where what i'm going to
do in this is i am going to print the
value of whatever is there in my where
okay so let's do print um
value of variable is value stored in
variable
is
okay that's uh
my where so let's see what happens when
we do this let's call this function
underscore name see what happens here so
as you can see the value i stored a
value of 100 in y where and i've called
it inside the function and this is
because since i've defined it outside i
can use it inside as well now what if i
try to change the value of um this
variable inside the function though so
let's see
if i did this and now if i try to print
let's see do is this allowed no it's not
allowed in fact i get an error it says
local variable mywear reference before
assignment
and without going too much into detail
what it's saying is that the variable
inside over here is still local to this
function and i have not defined this
myware as a global variable so i cannot
make changes to it within this function
right now and uh to change that i can
use the global keyword what if i did
global over here so if i did global
and now if i said okay global mywear and
i declare this variable as a global
variable now if i do this now if i do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when i'm trying to do this
you see i get the value of 101 this is
exactly what i wanted and that is
because i've defined my variable to be a
global variable within this function so
i can in fact make changes to it within
this function so this is how we use the
global keyword and global variable also
just to make a quick note um there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions uh these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user-defined
function that is the ones which we
define ourselves and the third type is
called anonymous functions they're also
known as lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say um
if i define the function where
underscore sorry fun underscore name and
i'm saying a comma b red but what if um
the user has not um like save i i want a
default value of a and b each time when
i uh use this function so in the case
where if say i don't pass a value for a
and b like this will always be used so i
can just say a is equal to 2 by default
and b is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function i will say c is
equal to a plus b and then return c
so
i do this and if i say fun underscore
name and in case i don't pass any
arguments here let's see what happens by
default i get the answer 5 because by
default a is 2 and b is 3 but this is
not fixed and i can always change this
by passing my own values here 5 and 6
and in this case i should get 11 as you
can see here now the next type is
required arguments and when we are
defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically um it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if i try
to pass like this i won't get a oops
yeah i won't get a default value then
that's because um
that's because well there is no default
value and it needs an a and b so i have
to pass it a three and say four now it
should give me seven as you can see the
next type of argument that we'll be
talking about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what i'm doing in this
particular example is i'm defining a
function called my sum where i'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
i'm doing something out here and what
this does is
it will take the values of a particular
like collection of objects and that's
called my integers and each value i'm
going to keep adding it to each other
and i'm going to result a particular sum
i'm just going to resolve the sum of
whatever is there so
in this case what happens is i'm
creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then i'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me six now the problem in
this case is that each time when i'm
going to perform this function i have to
create a separate list where i'm going
to store these objects but what if i
didn't i do not know like what exactly
i'm going to pass here what if i don't
know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case i can use a
variable uh variable uh key variable
number of arguments so it's like a
variable keyword argument so what we use
here is um
a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so i say define
my under underscore name and i use an
asterisk now i give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever task we want so let's
just uh since i've already created one
here let's see how i'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see i'm doing
i'm creating a particular
variable argument function over here and
i'm doing the same task i'm just going
to keep performing edit
i'm going to add whatever i pass over
here but now when i'm calling this
function i don't need to create a
separate list as i did over here i'm
just passing all the numbers that i want
to in the form of like it's pretty much
like a tuple so i'm just passing these
numbers here and what this function is
going to do is it's going to create an
iterable out of this and then we're
going to iterate over it as you can see
that's happening over here and i can
keep
i don't need i i can just keep like so
since i've done it for one two three and
seven the summation should be 13 in this
case i can add another number here just
explicitly just like this and you can
see the value will change and that's
because this is a variable uh this is a
variable argument
method of
perform creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh
argument so let's look at what is the
keyword argument now so i have defined a
function here called the concatenate
function and let's see what i'm going to
do with this so in this i have passed a
keyword argument i've said that okay
this is going to be a keyword argument
function and what i'm going to do in
this is i'm going to create a blank
string and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to add
or i'm going to concatenate certain
strings that i'm going to pass to this
function so i
in this example i have passed python and
is and cool and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what i'm going to
do in this function is i'm going to join
them together um and i'm going to create
one whole string out of it let's see
what's the result python is cool so this
is so of course like uh if i had to add
some something else like python is say
cool and say i just wanted to say
hello and say one more string i can add
i can add it just like this i don't have
to like define a fixed number of
arguments i can pass any number of
arguments i want and this works exactly
the same as variable and
only differences instead of positional
arguments we're using keyword arguments
over here hello bye like this doesn't
really make sense but just to show you
as you can see so this is how we use
keyword arguments in this video we will
be learning about exceptions exceptions
uh errors that are raised during the
execution of a program when an
error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled uh which
avoids our program from crashing python
has many built-in exceptions uh however
we can create many uh user-defined
errors or exceptions as well to catch
whatever errors we're looking for in our
program so when an error occurs python
interpreter raises an
exception and stops the current process
and it passes it to a calling process
until the exception is handled and if
it's not handled the program will crash
some of the
built-in exceptions are like i o errors
in the case when a file cannot be opened
or import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar
so many
exceptions that are built in python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
um let's look at the difference between
an exception and a syntax error so for
that i will be using an example where i
will be dividing something by the number
zero of course this is not possible so
let's see how python handles this
particular problem well it raises
something that it raises what we call a
zero division error and this is an
exception that is built in in python
whenever we try to divide something by
zero now let's look at the difference
between this exception and a syntax
error so this is the same statement
except i'm going to add this extra
bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if i try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error and it says the unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma
that basically makes the line unreadable
to the interpreter in the first place so
the the interpreter doesn't even get to
the point where it needs to figure out
uh that there's something being divided
by zero it doesn't even get to that
point because it finds this extra
bracket and it's uh cannot execute this
line at all so that is like the
difference between an uh an exception
and a syntax error all right now for our
first case of how we raise or how we
handle exceptions let's look at
the keyword rays so for this example
what i will be doing is i'm going to
take this variable x all right and i'm
going to store a value 10 and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to check for a
condition if x is greater than 5 then
i'm going to raise this exception using
the raised keyword like this and in case
this condition is met if x is actually
greater than 5 i want this particular
message to play out in my
x section so let's see what happens when
i execute this as you can see the
exception is raised because x is indeed
greater than 5 its value is 10 and the
mirror message says so that x should not
exceed 5 the value of x was 10. so this
is an example of how we can raise an
exception and as you can see when a
condition was met the program comes to a
halt and an exception was raised now
let's look at another type of handling
exception where we use the assert
statement so when we use the raise
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking
whether the system that we are working
on is actually linux or windows 32 so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
editor will obviously be an assertion uh
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement now if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systole platform contains win32
and not linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for windows system we won't have
any error when you execute this as you
can see so this is the example where we
use the assert statement
another way of handling exceptions is by
using the try and accept block so this
is probably one of the most common ways
of handling exceptions in python
where we
use a try keyword and an accept keyword
now within the try keyword as you can
see here we have a chunk of code which
we're going to check and if everything
is fine in the try keyword then this is
perfect so we don't need to move on to
what we call the accept part of the try
and accept block but if say there was an
error in the try block then we move on
to the accept block where we're going to
run the part of the code in the case we
find an error in the try block so first
we check the other part of the code that
is under the try block and if if there
is an error we move on to the accept
block and we run that part of the code
over there and where we and in the
except block where we that is where we
handle our whatever error that might get
thrown our way in the try block okay
let's look at an example at how to uh
use this technique so i have a basic
function out here all right it's
defining a function called linux
interaction what this is uh basically
doing is that when i call this function
i want to do an assert check i'm going
to check if linux is the system i'm
working on and if it is not then i want
this error to be thrown okay and
so yeah let's see what happens in the
case and if if this search statement is
actually passed then we will move on to
this statement so you could look at it
like this if whenever i mean when i call
this function it will first check for
this assert statement in case something
wrong happens and we get an assert error
then we do not move on to this line so
we only get this printed but if this
assert statement passes then we move on
to this line and we get print doing
something okay so let's see now i'm
going to call this function out here
let's see what happens here as you can
see i get an assertion error because
obviously this is a window system and
not a linux system and i get this
message okay now let's see what happens
when we use it in a try and accept block
all right so now i have a try block over
here in which i am going to try the same
this function linux underscore
interaction if in case i find an error i
immediately jump from the dry block into
the accept block now you see the slight
difference in how we handle this like
what happens so as you can see when we
use the function explicitly we directly
went to what we call an assertion error
but when we use a try and accept block
we will not use the assertion error
because we are leaving the try block
immediately and we are going to go into
the accept block where the only thing we
are doing is printing the statement as
you can see we are not on linux found
some error okay now what if we wanted to
catch the error within uh this function
itself which was the assertion error and
we can do that explicit layer like this
so now what i'm doing is i'm going to
try all right and it's going to catch an
error in this slide so now in the accept
block i'm going to say the assertion
error that we found in this function in
the try block we're going to use that in
our accept block so as you can see we're
going to print that assertion error
it'll basically print this statement
function can only run in linux systems
as you can see here function can only
run on linux systems function can only
run on linux systems and the next part
of the thing was the linux interaction
function was not executed okay so this
is
a very this is like um this is a key
there's a key uh something very
important happening here when we use
this assert statement the whole program
is actually getting executed right uh
but when we're using the try and accept
block we are immediately jumping on like
the moment we catch an error we are
immediately jumping onto the accept
statement and uh however and all the
handling of the exception is done in the
accept block and not in the try block
anymore so we do uh think of it like
this that the try block is only to check
if a particular piece of code is
like does it have any errors or not and
in case it does then every uh like all
the handling that we do is uh in the
accept block of this particular
statement now let's look at another
example in this example i'm going to try
opening a particular file now this file
does not exist so i will be i will get a
file not found error and this is a
built-in exception and i'm going to
catch that and i'm going to print that
error over here in the accept block all
right so as you can see file not found
and whatever like error i have i printed
over here all right so this is another
like this is uh a file not found error
that we're going to we that we we caught
in our try block and we're handling it
in the excel block now let's use let's
combine both of the examples where we
use this linux interaction and we also
try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
try block so as you can see in my try
block i'm not only doing this linux
interaction i'm also trying to
open a particular file that does not
exist obviously so now you might think
will i get two exceptions well let's see
what happens when we try to uh execute
this so uh it's important to note that
in our accept we have an accept for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding
the assertion error that that is part of
this linux interaction function so so
since both of these
are erroneous statements or they will
throw exceptions so now the question is
will we get both of these except blocks
or when we get both of these exceptions
but we get only one of them that we get
the first one so let's see what happens
so as you can see my error statement is
is very much like the assertion error
that i had that we had done as part of
this linux underscore interaction
function function can only run on linux
systems the linux function was not
executed as you can see
that is the one that has been caught and
for some reason the file not found error
has not been caught and this is because
this is a very important feature of the
try block the moment we find the first
error in our try block we immediately
leave and we do not execute any of the
further statements and we jump into the
exceptions and we handle it using the
accept blocks so the moment an error was
found in this function we did not
execute this part of the statement and
we directly jumped into the respective
exception that was the assertion error
exception so this is a key takeaway so
some of the some of the other key
takeaways when it comes to exceptions is
a try clause is executed up until the
point where the first exception is
encountered and in the accept clause or
the exception handler we determine how
the program responds to this exception
we can have multiple exceptions and we
can differentiate how the program
responds to each of these and it's also
very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bear accept
clause now finally before we conclude
this topic of exceptions let's look at
the else and the finally clause so the
else clause is used when we want to
execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we have the linux interaction
function i'm going to define a win under
underscore interaction and this is going
to check whether our system is windows
or not in case it is not then we get
this error message all right and in case
it is a windows of
intel it is a windows system we print
this in the case of when we call this
function so let's again use our try and
accept statement only in this case we
will be using an extra else clause so we
first try this function in case there's
an error we catch it as an assertion
error and we print that error but if
there is no exception then we move on to
the else statement and we print this so
as you can see our
we have actually moved on to the else
statement and we print this line
executing the else clause and that is
because we have found no exceptions over
here so again it's key to remember that
the else clause is used whenever you
want to execute a particular statement
in the case where we do not find any
exceptions in the try block the final
clause is used when we want to execute
something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens i mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so i have this block where
i'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that i'm doing is i'm going to
check for this linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linux system or
not this is i'm doing the try block now
if i catch an error that i want to be i
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that uh
there is no error then i will move on to
the else statement and i will try
this particular block of my statement
which is again that uh where i'm trying
to read a particular file that does not
exist and it's very uh it's very
important
that you note that within the else block
i have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this i'm first
trying this if i have an error then i do
this and i don't
execute this but if i don't have an
error then i execute this whole
statement which contains its own try and
accept block all right but regardless of
whether i get an error here or not
i will always execute this portion of my
statement or under the finally clause
let's execute this as you can see of
course the error is raised in this try
stride block so we move on to the
exception and that is what is printed
over here and after the exception is
done we move on to the finally we of
course skip this else block because the
exception was actually raised so after
that is done we move on to the final
block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
python i hope you learned something from
this and
of course this is just the beginning
exceptions are something that you will
be that you would probably encounter a
lot especially when you're beginning and
it's something that you will
learn to extensively work with and that
will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
covering the topic of iterators now an
iterator in python is an object that
contains a countable number of values or
it's a larger object that contains a
countable number of sub-objects an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon and what that means is we
can traverse from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks using each of
the
sub objects or values within this larger
collection called iterator now
when we're looking at it technically an
iterator is an object which implements
the iterator protocol in python which
consists of the methods eter and the
method next so to begin with let's look
at a simple iterator we're going to see
the example of a list where we're going
to traverse through
the objects of a list using the for loop
so we have objects one two three four
and i'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here
another example of an iterable in python
is
the dictionary so let's say i have a
dictionary where i have two values two
key value pairs uh key x which contains
the value one and key y which
corresponds to the value two now when
i'm going to do a for loop through this
by default i will be traversing through
the keys x and y as you can see over
here and of course uh the other types of
weight rebels in python are like sets
and tuples as well all right now let's
look at um what this iterating protocol
is in python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects that
contain sub objects and when we use the
eater function it uh creates an iterator
out of it so we can one by one we can
traverse through
each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally uh
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub-objects we encountered the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh
iterated upon so and as an example i
will create a list where i will store
the values uh some simple values
integers one two three four one three
four five okay um i'm going to create an
iterator out of this where i will use
the iter function and i'm going to say
this is let's say this is called my
my editor okay
and
i'm going to use iter function as i had
mentioned and i'm going to pass my list
in this
now if you see what is my eter
it should say it should be a list
iterator at a particular memory location
now let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see now when i look at
the next it should be three then i
should get four and now i should get
five as i use the next successively now
since i've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time i use this next function i should
get a stop
stop iteration exception that is raised
as you can see here so this is the basic
iteration protocol in python now you
might have
already gone through the for loop video
and in that i have spoken in quite a bit
of detail as to how a for loop performs
this um this iterator protocol and how
it creates an iterative iterable object
out of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it
breaks out of the for loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now
let's do a basic comparison of what is a
a basic comparison between a generator
and an iterator in python so in
generator
we use a function we use like we define
it using the def keyword and we define
it under one function to create a
generator whereas in the case of
iterators we use two separate functions
the iter function and the next function
the generator makes use of the yield
keyword whereas the python iterator does
not in generators we save the states of
the local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any trouble like a list
to iterate upon
we may use any number of yield
statements in generators and we do not
use yield statements initiators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in python
now a module in python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot by extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my module of programming is the
process of breaking a large
a large event or task into smaller and
more manageable sub tasks and we call
these subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now so first of all there is
simplicity uh because instead of
focusing on a big big problem a big task
we can break down the problem into
smaller smaller portions of modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains um there is usability
usability uh in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
um there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in python that promote code
module modularization
you might have already come across
a gordon intro into functions in this
video we will be going through modules
in another video we will also cover the
topic of packages to import a module we
use the import keyword and in this
example what i'm going to show you is a
simple function or a simple operation of
importing the os module
this is short for operating system and
as the name suggests we can perform
system tasks through the functions and
methods that are part of this os module
so simply executing the statement will
import this module onto our program for
us to use now if we wanted to see all
the functions that are present in a
module what we have to do is use the dir
function so if we print the dir os
function it will print us basically a
directory of all the functions that are
present in the os module as you can see
here
like all of these are basically uh names
to different functions that are part of
the os module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the get cwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
directory that we are working upon right
now so if i execute this it will tell me
what is the directory that i am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir slash 10. if
we wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if i were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently
there in the directory that i am
currently working upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is basically creating a python script
with whatever functions and tasks that
we want and methods that we want inside
uh whatever module and saving it with a
dot py extension um so in in my example
what i'm going to do is i have already
created a script in notepad and i've
stored it with a dot py extension that
contains these four functions add
subtract
product and division um i have basically
copied i basically use this code and
i've stored it in a dot py script and
i'm going to be using this as my uh as
a test module for this particular
example now how do we import a module
now once that i have created a script uh
in my example it will be called my calc
dot py uh and we've stated stored it in
our directory to import the module all
we have to do is use the import
statement so if i had to import my calc
all i have to do is say import my
underscore calc and now my calc has been
imported um so we can use the import
statement or if we want to import
something particular from my calc we can
do from my calc import
now whatever like for example if we
wanted the ad uh the add function we can
basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything uh we can also use from my
calc import and we can say asterix to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and i will show you how right now so
what i'm going to do is in my example
i'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this is this is the original
folder or the original module but i'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that i can easily use it in my code and
i don't have to type out my underscore
card every time so now i'm going to
import this as calc so anytime i have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside this script or this module i will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now i have two
variables a and b and i'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what i'm
going to do is basically four operations
i'm going to print the addition of a and
b then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation i am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that i have already imported my
characters calc all i'm going to do now
is invoke these functions using the dot
operator that we're already familiar
with so i'm going to say calc dot add
and then i'm going to pass these two
arguments or these two variables to say
that i want to add these two and
similarly i'm going to do it for
subtraction
multiplication and division as you can
see these are the results of my tasks
now if i had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt or
dunder methods that are already a part
of any uh python script by default such
as built-ins so if i execute this just
to show you what happens when i use the
dir function it will basically give me
all the functions that are part of this
python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division fraud and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
in more detail into what happens when we
do a module search um let's let's
actually look at what happens so what
happens is when for example we execute
the statement import mycalc as calc as
we did over here so the first the steps
that actually take place are the
interpreter executes the above statement
and it searches for this python script
in a list of directories assembled from
these following sources that you see
here so it takes the directory from
which the input script was run or the
current directory if the interpreter is
being run interactively which is the
case right now uh secondly it will list
all the directories contained in the
python path environment that you set up
that you can setup or you can change
later on as well and this format for
python path is os dependent of course
but it should mimic the path environment
variable that we see in
windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search path that is accessible in the
python variable system.path
this is basically obtained from a module
named sys so if i imported this this and
i did sys.path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if i am doing uh
import my kayak or import os it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that i am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as
you could say directories or
paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed a very large application
in python that contains many different
modules and we have so many different
modules that have similar names and
functionalities and they're all kept in
like or dumped in the same location that
it becomes very difficult to track these
modules what if there was a way to
organize and access these in a much
simpler and more organized manner well
packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module name space using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to
let's look at certain examples to
understand what we mean so i have a
directory called pkg this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod one dot py and mod two dot p
by and what we're going to store in mod
1 and mod 2 dot py are the follows so
i'm going to define a function called
foo and i'm going to print uh this
particular statement mod 1 and then i'm
going to basically say foo
and then i'm going to say in class 4 i'm
going to have an empty pass command
similarly i'm going to define a function
called bar in mod 2 dot py where i'm
going to print this statement so
basically mod 1 dot py has a simple
function where i'm going to print this
statement and mod 2 dot py has a simple
function then i'm going to print this
statement
and i'm going to store them in mod 1 and
mod 2. py respectively and these two
modules i'm going to store in the
directory pkg in my local folder now
i've already done this so we can already
get
to working with this now if i wanted to
access these particular modules from the
pkg folder i can simply use the import
command and use the dot notation so i
can say pkg.mod1 so this will inward in
this will
import the mod1 module from pkg folder
similarly i can do the same thing for
the mod 2
module from the pkg folder in the same
line so now that it's been imported just
simply execute this and this imports
whatever you needed now if we wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod1 or py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly i can invoke the
function
that was part of the mod 2 module
by extending the dot notation to it in
the same way now another way that i can
invoke
i can import a package is by directly
importing the package itself by using
import pkg and
not accessing any of the specific
modules within it now let's see what
happens when we do this so just for this
example what i'm going to do is i'm
going to restart the kernel so that the
pkg modules that were already imported
get cleaned away so we see what happens
when we execute this on its own now if
you see i haven't imported this now
let's see if i can access
my mod 1 and mod 2. if you see here it's
throwing me an error and this is because
using simply using the import command on
a particular package only imports um you
could say the package namespace but it
does not actually import any of the
modules and files that were part of this
package so if i wanted mod1
from this package i would have to
actually say import pkg.mod1 directly um
and i cannot simply say import pkg and
python will not import everything that
is part of a package on its own i have
to specify it myself
specifically now i'm going to create and
i'm gonna i mean i'm going to show you
another type of importing from a package
using the star operator so i have this
package pkg once again now i'm going to
store um three i mean four different
modules within this package mod111 dot
py mod 222 dot py and i've already done
this so you don't need to bother about
um
seeing me doing it right now because
i've already created these files and
what i've done is within mod111 dot py
i've defined
i've written this statement and i've
stored it in the python script similarly
i've created another python script
script called mod 222 dot py and i have
basically written this in the code and
i've simply done this for mod 333 dot py
and i've done another for mod 4 dot py
now once i have done this i've stored
these python scripts into my uh into my
package or pkg
package so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create i'm going to execute
this command if you see this from pkg
dot mod 333 import start so once i
execute this now i'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if i change
this and if if i imported mod 111 and if
i did the same thing you will see foo
has now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all uh
functions that were part of these
different modules where i am importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is sync from pkg.mod111
so it's saying that um okay look into
this directory or this package and find
this module and in this module import
everything that exists inside it up
until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application
um and these modules can be accessed
using the familiar dot notation that we
have used in other examples such as
methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions
so let's look at a simple generator
first of all so out here i have defined
a generator called my generator where
i'm doing uh like the three uh like
three
functions or three tasks that i'm doing
uh first one is when i'm printing the
first item and i'm yielding a value 10
then i'm printing second item yielding
20 then i'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword um
every time we use the next keyword we
will keep getting what is next in this
function
so let's store
the generator in my gen
so now
we
have stored the iterator in this
function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first
um task is performed or the first
iteration is performed where we get this
the first yield command is done all
right let's see what happens when we do
next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20.
let's do it for the next let's do it
once more since there is one more task
there's one more iterable inside you can
see this now a valid question is what
will happen if we do next gen again
since
there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in
exception um that happens when we
have
like reached the last
object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so
now a key difference between a generator
and a function is that when we execute a
function the moment we hit the return
statement in a function or when we
execute a function like whatever
variables that were stored inside are
lost and they are destroyed unless they
were defined as global
and the function is completely done
executing and we leave the function
completely whereas when it comes to a
generator
when we hit the yield function we don't
actually completely leave this function
so the first time the yield is found we
get 10
but
the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next iterable so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in python
so to understand a what the difference
between the yield
command and the return command us let's
take the same function
all right
and let's put a return over here
after this particular
the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to
my
generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first deal will be standard first
item 10
the next one is again is going to say
second item and then 20 but now if you
notice there was a return i put over
here
so
technically when i did the second next
it's not only yielded 20 but it's also
executed this return function or this
return statement so let's see what
happens if i do next again
as you see i have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than i did
before and that's because i have used
the return function and our in determine
statement and what that's done is that
um
if we've completely left this function
so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between
yield and return
now in the next example i'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for loop or for a for
loop so let's take this whatever over
here and i have defined a function
called get sequence up to x and
what this will do is basically
it will keep printing the
printing numbers up until whatever we
have entered in place of x over here so
if i said
say sequence is equal to
let's uh
copy this
all right
and say i want um i want sequentially i
want every number up until 10 but not
including 10 of course because python
starts with zero right
so let's do this
and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if i
did this again
it should give me 1
2 and i can keep going
until
i will stop at the value 9
as you can see here
so 8
9
now i should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator
is um
in the case of fibonacci numbers so
let's use it
let's
see how we can generate a fibonacci
series using um generator so i've
defined a fibonacci function called
fibonacci where i'm passing max so max
is basically the max value that i want
um
yeah like up until where i want the
sequence right so
uh this is basically the code which will
uh give return me the subsequent values
of my fibonacci sequence
so
let's uh pass this to fib and see i want
all the fibonacci numbers until 10
so and i will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero
then when we
do this again we get one
then we do zero plus one it should be
one
next number should be one plus one which
is two then we should have two plus one
three
and then 3 plus 2 5 then 3 plus 5 should
be 8. now 8 plus 5 is 13 and since 13 is
greater than what we passed for our max
value here now when we try this
we should get the stop iteration error
as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like
creating a new list
using a much shorter and cleaner syntax
compared to what you might traditionally
be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes creating these
new this much simpler much easier for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list
which will contain fruits that contain
the letter a in their name so we already
have a list of fruits over here as you
can see
it has apple it has banana cherry kiwi
and mango now we want to create a new
list which has only the fruits that have
the letter a inside them so apple would
be one of them banana would be one of
them and mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few
extra lines
but yeah it does it does do what we want
to do now what if there was a way of
doing the same thing by just writing one
simple line of code and that exists as
you can see here
so i take the same
list
now
this is where you need to follow so now
my new list is equal to so i'm creating
a list over here as you can see now
within this list you have this line this
is what we call a list comprehension so
as you can see it says each fruit for
each fruit in fruits if now it's
checking for the letter or the character
a
inside
each fruit and what this each fruit is
that we're checking each
object in this list one by one so first
in the first iteration each fruit will
contain the string apple then in the
next iteration it will contain banana
and in each
uh each iteration we are going to check
if it contains the character a and if it
does then we store that each fruit in
the new list
as you can see here
so if i execute this line you see
my my result is the same i have my
whatever i wanted and this was a much
cleaner way of writing
or creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what i'm going to do
is i am going to iterate through a
string so i have a string it can be
anything in this case i am using a
string called human
all right so i have a string called
human right now i want to store each
character of this string into a
list that we call h underscore letters
so if i use the for loop this is how we
would do it if i execute this as you can
see the list contains h and then u m a
and then n now what if i wanted to do
the same thing but uh by using list
comprehension
so what i would do is
let's create
a list over here h underscore letters
and um
so as we know list com so a list
comprehension will uh it's it's a so you
just basically need one line in this
case it will just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when i check what's in
edge letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see i have
the output as what i needed so this is a
much cleaner way let's go through some
more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we have already
seen uh
one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
went through where we we did a sort of a
loop through a string we can also use
this comprehensions in conditionals so
let's uh look at an example where we use
the
this comprehension with an if statement
so what if i wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would so this is
an example that i'll be using
so in my list i want to store the first
10 even numbers so this would be a way
to do it
so i have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is x is going to take the
value of one two three four and so on
until ninety eight that actually take it
from zero one two three four until 19.
so when we do range 20 we're creating an
iterate in iterable
where uh we're going to
loop through our iterate through the
value of 0 to 19.
so
if i if i do this
and this what this statement does is
basically it checks if it's divisible by
2.
so
if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number
and if this condition is met if this
condition is met that means we store
the x into our number list so let's see
what happens when we execute this
it should contain
0 2 4 6 until 18 so this is the first
and even numbers as you can see
so this is an 8 way of using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if i i'm checking um
each
okay so i'm going to create another list
and in this list i'm going to basically
see if
each of my
num numbers are the even or odd the
first let's say 10 natural numbers
so let's write this statement down
so i want it to be even
in case
the i that i'm checking i being every
number between so like say the first 10
natural numbers as i said
let's check if um
if it is divisible by two
well if it is divisible by two of course
it's going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we check for i in say the first
let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this let me check
oh we check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is a an example
where we used the
list comprehension with if else
statements
so another neat thing that we can do
with the
list comprehensions is that we can use
it along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double x where we define
this double x uh this double function to
take an input to take an argument x and
what we return is the square of the
argument so
let's use this in uh in our lifts list
comprehension so what we do over here is
that we are we're checking what we're
doing is for every x um between range 10
so we're taking the value 0 1 2 3 until
9 and we're passing it to this function
double x
and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list
x let's just call this list
it's called y so now let's see what's in
y when we check
uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and so on so
wait this let's check again does this
square no this is actually two times so
let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see 0 1 4 9
for the first
10 numbers 10 natural numbers now what
i've shown you is obviously list
comprehension
but we can also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as uh list comprehensions
the only difference is the
set comprehension will make sure that
there are no duplicates inside the set
so you can't have like duplicate items
which you can in the case of list
comprehensions so let's uh let's say
let's take a look at an example so here
in this example what we're doing is
we're going to check so we have this
string that we're storing in the
variable text and the string is
uh something like life finds away so
whatever this is
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
uh
iterate through this
string
character by character and we're going
to check if
uh there are we're going to check for
vowels essentially so
uh we're going to see if the character a
e i o or u is present in the string and
if it is we will pass it into our set
now if you if you look you'll find there
are multiple eyes right
and there are multiple a's as well so
if we did this through a list
comprehension each time that we
found find a vowel it would be added to
our list but since this is a set and
sets do not allow duplicates so you will
only have one copy or one particular
object for each of the vowels
so
of course now
set combination is defined using curly
braces so let's keep that in mind so now
if i check what's in this i will see a e
i and u even though there are multiple
a's or multiple e's or i's and u's since
this is a set we don't have duplicate
copies of any copies of any of these
so this was just a small example for
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and we
call the discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing that we
have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this
so let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except
in this case we will define the key and
that separates it from a set
comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
i'm checking
i'm going through the a list of numbers
from 0 to 9 right so what the range 10
function does and
what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create a key which is going
to be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be a square as you can see
here
i'm doing i times i
or just to
make a little more clearer
as you can see i'm doing i squared over
here for every value from 0 to 9 so what
i should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is zero and the value of
that key should be zero as well because
zero uh square is zero then for one it
will be one and then for two four and
then three nine four sixteen so let's
see what happens as you can see here
this is the
the result that i wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to
list comprehensions um so it's obviously
an elegant way to define and create
lists based on
existing lists
it's more compact and faster than normal
functions and loops but we should also
keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated
list comprehensions because
the idea of a list comprehension is to
be user friendly and also it's important
to note that every list comprehension
can be written in the form of a loop but
every loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example
if you see this example here you can see
a symbol called the carrot followed by p
and then five periods
then an n and a dollar sign and what
this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with p ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now
this is a regex pattern that is looking
for a five character string that starts
with a ends with s and has three
characters in between now if we had to
match this with this tree with these
strings as in as
our test strings the first one would not
match because it's a three letter string
and we're looking for a five character
string the second one would match
because it's a five character string
that ends with an s starts with an a and
has three characters in between this
will not match because whatever pattern
would do is it would find the first s
and it would find that the string itself
starts with an a and it would say okay
there are only two characters between
this first test and this a and it would
assume that this is actually just a four
character string to actually
identify two consecutive s's we would
have to do something special and what we
would have to do is what we will see
later on
so again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a
is perfectly fine when we're searching
for this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python can be
imported using this statement import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do uh pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify
different sequence of characters in our
strings let's try to understand
a bit more in depth about regular
expressions now so what you're seeing
here is one variable called pattern
which stores
something that looks like a regex
and another variable that stores our
test string called abyss
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method of this
module re and we're going to check
whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this regex is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what i just showed
you a five character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if i execute
this and this is what it does
now if i change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here
now let's try to understand what exactly
do we mean by uh when we use these
different certain these special symbols
like for example this carrot or this
dollar symbol um these are by the way
known as meta characters and now we're
going to look into all the uh or most of
the different meta characters that are
used in red x
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's a list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square bracket
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match
some combination of a b and c it can be
one a two a's three b's four c's we are
not looking at a specific pattern we
just want to know if a b and c exists in
any form in our string so if we used it
on a the string a simply we would find
one match because the letter a is found
here ac would match twice because we
have a and c
present here in this string hey jude we
will have no matches because a b and c
none of them are found here and in this
weird string we will have actually one
two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use r e dot match to
do
to actually search for this and to see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string um i'm going to test this
i'm going to match whether my pattern
that um
any of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when i
use re.match for this so the the format
uh the syntax is simply the regex
pattern and then comma whatever test
string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like i can see an a
over here i can see a c over here
re.match actually gives us the result
none
now
if i
try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least 1998 what
i'm saying here is all film titanic was
released in 1998. now let's see if the r
match
works or not
as you can see it actually does your
return when i execute this it returns us
an object called ie.match object with a
span01 the span01 is basically telling
us that we have found a match between
the zeroth and the first character which
is basically this character a which is
what it has found and it's saying that
the match is indeed the character a
uh from amongst these options
so what this is basically telling us and
uh what this means actually is that the
re.match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space
in in our bigger string it will not
search for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
it will return us the first instance
where it finds a match now let's see
this is a test string now and we're
searching again for
our uh we're searching for a b and c any
any of these um in our test string but
we're going to use re.search and not
match so now if you see it returns us
when i execute this it returns us a
match object again but this time it's
saying the span of nine and ten now the
spine panel nine and ten actually exists
over here this is the ninth character
and a itself is the tenth character over
here so what this basically is telling
us that the tenth character is where we
found a match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a or b or c in
this whole string and this is basically
how re.search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance or wherever
we find now what if we wanted to find
out all the instances wherever a b and c
were found and not just the first
instance well in that case we would be
using the method find all over here so
when we use find all it will actually
return us each and every case where it
found a b or c and uh you might not it
won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like um so if i
execute this you can see it gives us a a
list with a c a and a and what this
basically means is it was looking for
the characters a or b or c and it found
a first and hence this for the first
item in the list and then it found a c
and then it found two is successfully so
this is exact this is actually how find
all works where it will actually find
all the instances of our regex pattern
now that you've seen how the square
brackets work and how the re dot search
and re dot uh match and re dot find all
methods work now we're going to go
through all the other meta characters
that we saw above so the period now
period matches any single character
except the new line new line is
basically slash n or a break now if you
look at this picture what it's going to
do is um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have um two characters like sets
of two characters in our string so this
is a single character string and
obviously a single character string is
not a double character string and this
expression this double dot is basically
uh asking us do we have two characters
present in our string
so if i had to match it with this a it
will obviously be a no match because a
is one character if we checked it with
ac it is a match because a and c are two
characters a c and d will also give us
only one match because it will find a c
and then it will leave d as a single
character but when we check a c d and e
or this string in particular it will
find two matches because it will
consider a and c as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches so
below is basically what we're doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd dot search for each of these
different examples
so if i if you see when i use find all
on acde and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me a c and d e as you can
see here and similarly for something
like this it will return me again uh
whatever like two character patterns it
finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the carrick
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the
one is checking if a
is the beginning of a string and the
other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because
only the character a and it will match
here as well because this string starts
with a but it will not match here
because this string starts with b now if
i look at this
particular expression
you can see that
this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because it does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
a because it's not followed by a b
so out here is basically us using the
ie.search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples
so this is going to check basically if
so this expression will check if the
string ends with a so this uh this
string is basically the character a so
it will match this also ends with a so
it will match and this particular string
does not end with a so it will not match
and we are going to do that using the re
dot search over here so as you can see
it finds a match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns us a none another example
is
of the meta characters is star so this
is the symbol for star and this what the
star basically is used is for checking
if there are zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it so now if
you see here
what this will check for is
um is there any form of
m and a
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that
the n has to follow the a in this case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen so if i checked it with m
and n this is actually a match because
n is followed by zero occurrences of m
and a which is if it might seem a little
weird but it is technically the truth
because
uh the the star symbol checks for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for if n
occurs it must occur after an a
or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine m a uh m
triple a n is also fine because n
follows an a and there's an m here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have m and a and we have
an n you see the n is immediately
followed by an i
is n follows an i immediately or the n
is preceded by an i immediately and this
is a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must
uh precede an a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the re dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the re dot search
as you can see here finally we have the
next meta character which is the plus
symbol yes so the plus symbol matches
one or more occurrences of the pattern
left to it now this is very similar to
what we saw earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences instead of
zero or more occurrences that we were
looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now
we need what is there to the left of the
plus sign at zero no occurrence of it
will not be allowed or will not cause a
match
so let's see now what we're going to do
here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign so now what
we're going to say is okay we need m and
a at least one occurrence followed by an
n the all of these conditions have to be
met so again if you took the first
example m and n this time it will be a
no match because there is no occurrence
of an a over here for preceding the n so
it's a no match m a and n is a match
because well this is this is perfectly
fine m triple a and n is also perfectly
fine but if you look at m a i and n much
like earlier the n
is uh preceded by an i and not an a so
there is no match and again women is
perfectly fine and we basically execute
the same thing through the search
function in this piece of code the next
meta character is the question mark the
question mark symbol matches 0 or 1
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
so
let's see what this does so now
we saw the star
the star which was zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it we saw the plus which is one or
more occurrences of the pattern to the
left of it now we will see the question
mark which is zero or one only zero or
only one and not zero or more of one or
more which was the previous cases only
zero and one or one occurrences of the
pattern to the left of it again we're
going to see the same expression except
we're going to replace the meta
character with the question mark so now
let's see what what happens when we
match so if you see here m and n is a
match because there is zero occurrence
of a and one occurrence of m preceding n
so this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
eight currents of a and m and then it's
followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a
which is followed by an n we're only
looking for zero or one
this again main will be a no match for
the same reasons that we have already
gone through and women will be a match
again for the same reasons
and we do the same things using the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do is we're going to see if there are
so uh that is the typical syntax for the
braces is n uh brace followed by some
integer n comma integer m and then close
braces so what this means is we're
looking for at least n
and at most m repetitions of the pattern
left of the braces let's see through an
example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least two
and at most three occurrences of this
the character a in our test strings so
let's see what happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a and even this part of the string
only contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three
this part will contain one match the
second the second example because the
second part of the string actually
contains
two is for one
two uh repetitions of ace consecutively
but this uh in the end and in the third
example you can see both the strings
actually contain matches so we get two
matches because as you can see here
there's two a's here followed by three
a's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now so
what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is these
first three is and is going to see okay
so there are three occurrences of a and
i already have a match it's not going to
consider this fourth a and the search it
will just look at the first three and
they say okay there are
three a's and my my match is fine so
again there are two matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more uh
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is
0-9 now a dash symbol is valid in python
using regex because what this basically
tells it is that it's looking for either
0 1 2 3 4 so on until 9 basically any of
the digits you're looking for any of the
digits from 0 to 9
and we are going to check if at least
two and at most four occurrences of
digits if they are there or not in our
particular code so let's see what are
the matches that happens when we use it
on test strings so if you use it on this
string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh three occurrences of
digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and whatever this is you will see this
will not find a match here this
obviously will not because these are
characters but if you look at over at
this part it will find matches in terms
of the first four and then seven and
three the next two
one and two again there are no matches
because there's only single occurrences
of digits we're looking for it at at
least two and at most four so if i use a
find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
determine 1 2 and 3 as you can see here
but now if you look at this test string
it's going to return me 12 it's going to
return me 3 4 5 and 6. it's going to
return me 3 4 1 and 2 but not 7 because
we're looking for at least 2 and then
it's going to return me four five six
and seven followed by eight and eight as
you can see in this list over here
now if we use curly braces with only one
digit it's basically telling the search
engine that uh we want exactly so many
repetitions of the preceding uh whatever
kind of expression that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically saying that we
want uh x
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again which
will not match in this case because
there are only two dashes and it will
match in this case because there are
exactly three dashes and it will again
not not match in this case because there
are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b so a should be followed
by b
and uh basically this pattern has to
keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here uh we will
have a match because we at least find an
a even though there is no b
but this is to consider a match because
we did find an a at least over here
we'll have three matches because we have
a followed by a b followed by an a again
so if we did a regex expression for this
we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that i want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what i want is some form
of a following b following c
some sort of alternation between a b and
c so this part as you can see here is
kept in a parenthesis because i want
this whole condition to basically occur
before i find in x and z so let's look
at what happens here
in the first case we don't have a match
because uh this basically this
parenthesis condition is not being met
the x and z is preceded by a space or
basically the a and b is preceded is
followed by a space so if this space
didn't occur we would actually find a
match as you can see in the next example
here you can see a and b occur basically
this
initial condition is met followed by x
and z so there is a one match so it's
fine for us now if you look at this uh
slightly more a trickier one what you
can see is we have two matches in this
case first in a followed by x and z and
then we have
c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things we're looking for
some form of alternation of these things
followed by an x and z and we can get
that over here we get b followed by an x
and z so you'll get two matches in this
case now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works let's look at grouping
constructs so grouping constructs break
up a regex in python into sub
expressions or groups and this serves
two purposes one is a grouping part
which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity and
any additional metacharacters apply to
the entire group as a unit and then
there's the capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group you can retrieve
captured matches later through several
different mechanisms so let's look at
basically what we mean by this example
over here so if you see this this
expression has a plus sign so we're
looking for uh as you know a plus looks
for one or more occurrence so this will
basically check for one or more
occurrence of the character r only
because there's no parentheses as in
this example so this plus is
next to an r and it's going to check for
basically
whether one or more occurrence of r
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put b a and r in a parent
thesis followed by plus it will actually
check for the entire string ba r and it
will check one or more occurrences of
ba-r together so if you look at these
two examples when we use this uh on
these examples you can see that these
are fine like these matches are fine but
if i used this
parent thesis then these would be the
acceptable matches and like ba triple r
would not be a match if i use
parenthesis
as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work
so let's look at some other examples so
what this will do is f o o has to be
optionally followed by
b a r and b a r must exist together and
this is because we have a question mark
here this question mark symbol tells us
that it should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing
is followed by a plus so we're looking
for this whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it cow is simply just cow
we're looking for this pattern and this
is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of c or w
because of the existence of the question
mark for uh preceded by the parenthesis
in this video we are going to continue
our discussion on regular expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
expressions let's continue our
discussion with special sequences now in
an earlier video on strings you might
have encountered what is an escape
sequence and how we use the backslash
character to generate these escape
sequences and an escape sequence is
basically if you remember
something that we use to either
give certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital a which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string
so out here if you can see we are
checking if the word
d is present in these two strings so we
would get a match in the first case over
here because this starts with the word d
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it for the same thing using the
find all function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find d in the beginning of the string in
the second case we get as empties list
because this string does not start with
the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash b
small b now this is used to match if
specified characters at the beginning or
the end of a word so when you use
backslash small b
and then you follow it up with whatever
you're looking for it would look for the
that particular those particular
characters or that pattern if it exists
in the beginning of a word in a string
so if you look at the first example it
starts with f double o and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double o so it will also
match
however in this string which is very
similar to the second one we don't have
a space between a and f and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double o but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here
now similarly if we wanted to check if
something exists in the back of a string
at the end of a string we type what we
want to search for first and then we
follow it with a backslash small b and
then if you see here it will match in
this first case it will match in the
second case because this part of the
string ends with f double o but it will
not match in this case because well we
remove the space so now this whole thing
becomes a
the string that we're looking for and it
does not end with fw anymore and this is
basically us just checking in through
the find all function now the next scale
the next special sequence that we will
be looking at is the slash capital b
which is basically the opposite of what
we just saw this matches only if the
specified characters are not at the
beginning or the end of a word so if you
see here this is checking if f double o
is not at the beginning of these strings
so in this case there will be a no match
in this case also it'll be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with a particular
string we would type that whatever
pattern we're looking for followed by a
backslash capital b
and then we can use the find all
function to generate us lists wherever
we find such objects
find such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small d and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you seen you must have seen earlier
so if we did a square bracket 0-9 and if
we did a search or a find all or a match
it would look for any of the digits
between 0 and 9. so a similar thing can
be done using a special sequence
backslash small d so as you can see
there will be three matches in this case
because one two and three digits exist
whereas in this case
for the word python there will be no
matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital d and this is just
basically the opposite it matches for
any non-decimal digits it's also
equivalent to typing a caret inside uh
square brackets with 0-9 which if you
remember from the previous video is
basically asking us to check for
anything that is not uh the digit zero
to nine
so
this is basically we're going to check
in these two strings if there is no
digits and no non-decimal digits so if
you see here we will find three matches
a b and the
double double inverted commas
and in the second string we will find no
matches because this is fully just
digits
next we have backslash small s now this
matches where a string contains any
white space character so this is equal
to doing a uh check for all of these so
this is like backslash small t is a
check for tab space backslash small n is
a check for break line and then
backslash r black slash f backslash b
are their own uh checks for
different sorts of white space
characters that you can see by just
looking it up honestly but yeah so if
you simply do a backslash s it would
actually be the equivalent of searching
for any of these uh white space white
space characters that we generate
so if you see here
when we do a backslash s on this string
you can see that there is one space over
here so it will match it will give us
one match because there is one white
space which is just the normal space
here and in the second example there is
no match because there is no white space
here
similarly slash capital s now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash t slash n slash r
slash f slash v in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital s now we're
looking at uh a space b so over here if
you see it will match for all the non
spaces so it's going to match for a and
b so we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty string is
basically a white space character on its
own so this would be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're going to look at is the
backslash small w uh this matches any
alphanumeric character which is the
equivalent of doing a to z in small and
then capital a to z and zero to nine for
and also an underscore check in square
brackets um it's also it's important to
note that the underscore is considered
an alpha minimic character hence why we
include it over here but yeah this is
the backslash w uh small w which
basically checks for any alphanumeric
character and matches it in a string so
if you see in this first case
it will find three matches at one two
and also at the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters whereas
in this string none of these are
alphanumeric characters so we will get
no match again much like the other
examples there is a capital there's a
backslash capital w which will check for
any non-alphanumeric character and it's
the equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have this string where
we have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this
percentage symbol is a non-alphanumeric
character so we will get one match over
here but in this case in the string
python we will get no matches because
they are all alphanumeric characters
which is doing the same thing here with
a bunch of different examples using the
find all function now the backslash
capital z matches if the specified
characters are at the end of a string
now don't confuse this with uh backslash
small b because the backslash small b
checks for a string and it checks each
and every word in the string
individually and checks if so if any of
the words ends with a particular thing
or or starts with a particular thing but
it checks each word individually but in
this case the backslash capital z will
check the string only and not each word
so if you see the difference here in
when you use capital backslash capital z
um it will match in this first example
but it won't match for the next two but
if you used a
backslash small b over here it would
actually match not only the first
example here but it will also match in
the second example because it would
check this word individually and it will
find out that yeah there is a match here
as well so it would actually match in
the second example as well in this video
we will be covering the topic of
closures now before we understand what a
closure is we have to understand what is
a nested function and non-local
variables
now a function which is inside another
function is known as a nested function
nested functions are able to access
variables of the enclosing scope so if i
define this function called outer
function where i pass some argument
called text and i store that in a
variable called text again and if i
create a function within this call in a
function and i want to print whatever
this variable is in text
when i execute this
it will be able to access this variable
because it's within the enclosing scope
so if i set outer function hey this gets
stored in the variable text and then the
inner function will print that variable
which is basically the string here
as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here in a
function is treated as a nested function
which uses text this this variable text
as the non-local variable now a closure
is a function object that remembers
values in enclosing scopes even if they
are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally
but are defined in enclosing scope with
the value or reference to which the name
was bound when the closure is created a
closure which is which unlike a plane
function allows the function to access
those captured variables through the
closures copies of their values or
references even when the function is
invoked outside the scope so let's look
at an example to emphasize on what what
was just said
so again i've created i've defined this
function outer function where i'm doing
the same thing now i've defined the same
inner function where i'm going to print
the same thing now it's very important
that when i return over here what i'm
going to return is inner function but
it's not going to be a function call
this is important to
create our closure so we return in our
function but with without um using the
call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure um where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now i'm going to store this
outer function in an object called my in
a variable called my function now when i
call this my function um you can see
there there'll be two things that are
happening here so once i've defined this
and i've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then i'm
storing it to this
but because i've done return inner
function without parent thesis i have
created a closure basically and this
closure allows the inner function to
remember the values that were stored in
text at any point
and at every point even after the
execution of this one time so when i
execute this again for the second time
over here it will remember the value
that was stored in the variable text
which is hey which was which was given
over here
that's why you see when i execute it for
the second time over here the first time
being in this line when i'm storing it
in my function when i execute in the
second time again it would give me the
result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
function error function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we defined
called add x and y which will return x
plus y and the subtract function which
will subtract x and y
so
now we're going to execute these once
we're going to execute the add over here
and add logger and we're going to
execute the
subtract function and we're going to
store it in sublogger so technically we
have already executed these two
functions but now
uh since i have created an x an
enclosure basically uh if you see here
this is the enclosure that i have
created now what happens is
when i
access this function from outside its
initial scope which is basically over
here this was the initial scope when i
access it outside you will see that it
is it still has access to these
variables x and y so if you see here i i
first of all i've allowed this uh this
the enclosing function to accept uh
arguments of any numbers so
uh i can pass xy i can pass xyz also but
if you see here i won't i only have uh
thing for x and y so
when i want to access any value of x and
y even after the execution of this code
initially
i have access to these variables x and y
and that is because i've created a
closure out of
that so if you see if i do add logger
three and three over here i'm able to
get the result six if i do add number
four and five i'm able to get the result
nine similarly for subtraction logger
ten and five i will get five here and
twenty and ten i'll get ten here and
i can keep doing this i can keep saying
add logger in fact if i say four and
seven so if i executed this
and now i'm going to say let's say for
example add logger
if i set four and seven here
so this still has access to my variables
x and y because i've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if i
did sub logger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15 so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again i have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of lambda
functions now a lambda function in
python is an anonymous function without
a name
we usually use lambda functions whenever
we want to create a a function type
object for for a short period of time a
lambda function is defined using the
lambda keyword like a
normal function defined using the def
keyword we define a lambda function
using the lambda keyword also the lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
lambda function like
a sort of a a temporary function object
that you create whenever you want to
perform a particular task or object but
you don't want to give it a name or you
don't want to define a full a full-blown
function and give it a name letter
so over here i'm going to give you an
example of a lambda function let's say
that this lambda function takes in
let's call it x
and
so you define the function let's call it
x let's call it a lambda function using
this keyword
now we won't say two parameters right
we're saying say a and b or two
arguments a and b so we're gonna pass
two arguments a and b whenever we call
use this function and we're gonna
perform some sort of an expression now
let's uh write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
just use the colon now over here we have
our expression so let's call it a plus b
so now we've created a lambda function
called x
where we will pass two arguments and the
result will be the expression a plus b a
plus a and b being the arguments we pass
so now let's print
the result
of
um let's say we pass one and three so
now we should get the result four right
because a plus b is equal to 4 so we
passed a as 1 bs3 now let's execute this
as you can see the result is 4.
similarly you can pass any number of
arguments so we want to call some
function x
may say lambda function
we say a
b and c this time and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do
when we check the result let's say we're
doing the product of two 4 and 6
so this should be 48
and
when you execute this you get 48 as you
can see here so these are two simple
examples of a lambda function
now i could have done this
in a different way where i could have
defined some function x and over here i
defined that it takes in three
parameters and then you can define um
some say return the function basically
returns you a product b product c but
many a times you don't need to define a
full function called x you don't you
don't want to
assign some function with this name you
just want to create a temporary or
a short time anonymous function with
some name just to perform a simple
expression and in that case we can use
lambda functions uh that's an example by
the way you can use lambda functions in
multiple places so let's uh move on now
now for the
sake of this video what i'm going to do
is i'm going to show you how the sorted
function works and we're going to learn
how the lambda function uses this sorted
function how they work together so this
will give you a clearer understanding of
how we use the lambda function in our
code so to start off a sorted function
returns a sorted list from the items in
an interval so you can have a bunch of
for example numbers and the sorted
function by default will give you
will return you the list of numbers in
an ascending order of course you can
also
using a parameter called reverse you can
you can you can return a list of numbers
in the descending order um you can also
do this for strings i mean characters so
if you give it a bunch of characters say
a e f g in the in the alphabet it will
give you if you use the sorted function
it will give you the characters it will
return it in an ascending or descending
order depending on the parameter you
give so basically this uh the sorted
function the syntax is you use the
keyword sorted then you pass the
iterable which is basically some some
list or some
uh tuple then you give it a key so this
key sometimes we don't need to give by
default if the iterable is does not
contain um multiple uh multiple items
per object for like if it's not a tuple
of multiple objects um if it's not a
list of tuples for example you don't
need to give it a key if it's a simple
list of numbers you don't necessarily
need to give a key if you want to sort
it but yeah a key is basically the
parameter which we use to tell the
sorted function that we want to sort
based on something which is going to be
the key in this case
finally the third parameter is reverse
which basically just tells us that if we
want to sort in the default ascending
order or if we say reverse true then we
will sort in the descending order now
let's look at some examples so i have
this list over here
and
i'm going to print this list
so uh this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e a u o i and this is not in the
ascending order of the
the alphabet right like we we know it as
a e i o u if i print the sorted form of
this list it should give me a e i o a
list with a e i o in the ascending order
sorry yeah
so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um i gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if i use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these
individual characters like p y d h o and
n
but in the order that we want it to be
in
which is the ascending order of course
so
if i print this you can see it returns
me the list with each character in the
order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before h that's because this is in upper
case so what this does is first it uh
sorts all the uppercase characters
since there's only one so it just places
it in the first
object of this list and then it sorts
all the lowercase characters that you
see here so yeah moving on now now what
if we wanted to say sort this in
descending order so we have this list
and now we want to sort this in a
descending order so in that case we have
to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true so once we do this now when we
execute this you can see we have the
return as the same list but in the
opposite order so that's how the reverse
parameter works now let's uh try to
understand how we use the key function
or the key parameter in the sorted
function
now of course if you if we want to sort
something based on some key that we want
to define
we use the key parameter so let's take
an example now
so in this example what we have done is
i've defined this function
called take second so what this does is
it it simply it takes the second element
of a list of tuples so what is this list
of tuples well this random you can see
this random this is a list of tuples so
this is one tuple this is the next tuple
and what i'm going to do is in this
example i'm going to create a key out of
every second element in
each tuple so i'm going to create a key
out of 20
40 10 and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order i will sort this whole
list so my what my result should be is
that since the smallest of the uh every
second object in these tuples is 10 so
this will be my first object in the my
sorted list then it should be the one
with 13 because this is the next highest
number so then this will be the next
object similarly this will be the next
object then this will be the whole next
object so you see i'm using every second
element of the tuple as my key and for
that to create a key basically um i'm
creating this function which will
basically return every um it will
iterate through all of these and return
uh each of these second elements
so um let's actually uh let's actually
do this now so what i have here is
i am going to create a sorted list which
is going to use a sorted function on
this iterable which is a bunch which is
a list of tuples it's called random now
my key is going to be take second so
this sorted function is actually very
dynamic in the sense um i don't i don't
exactly have to create a list directly
each of these objects present in the
tuples i just have to define if i can
even pass a function in the parameter
for key and it will apply this function
on the interval that we pass over here
which is random namely and it will use
this function to generate keys
generate a key out of each second
element and based on that it will do the
sorted it will perform the sorted
function so now
if i check
what's my
sorted list
you will see
that as i had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we've
used a key to do the sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this
we have this um some some list
where a bunch of names a bunch of tuples
you can see right tuples with three
objects each within it each first one is
always a string denoting someone's name
some student's name um the second is the
marks out of hundred and the third is
their age so
what we have here is what we want to do
is we want to sort this these tuples
in the order of first marks and in case
the marks are clashing or they are the
same basically
we will sort by the age so
what we want to do is we want to first
sort by these marks as you can see here
but in case they clash for example like
say this 75 and 75 they're the same
marks in that case we want to sort it by
the age which is 12 and 20 which is
different so in this case we're going to
use two keys one for the first key will
be given the highest priority and then
if there is a clash then we use the
second key so how do we do this
now let's define some function like
how we define this take second function
here this will be our function that we
will pass to the key this function
basically what it does is it gives us
who has the highest marks now since we
are creating and since the key works in
an ascending order so
the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
we get returned right so what we're
going to do is we're going to return the
error which is basically the difference
between
100 which is the total marks and the
marks that student gets
so this is how we obtain a ascending
order in our list which is what we which
which basically is what we want because
we want um the highest marks to be first
so we do hundred minus item one item one
is basically the first object or
whatever iterable we pass in this case
it would be the the first objects of
each tuple which is the marks secondly
we found age age is the item two which
is
yeah each second object of each tuple
now
what we return in this function is uh
like this is going to be our key now a
list of errors and the list of age error
being the marks error the difference
between 100 and the marks you obtained
so now what it's going to do is it's
going to take the marks as the first key
and the age as the second key when we
pass this to a sorting function
so uh if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print
if you see
we get
let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second then the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same mark 75 so
now what we want to do is the guy who at
the younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we passed two keys
error and the age so when the clash in
error key happened we went to the age
key and then we did ascending order on
that and then finally the rest of the
objects that you can see here so now
that we have seen how the sorted
function works now let's look at how the
lambda function works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so it now some of you might have figured
out where this lambda function will be
used right so
whenever we were using the key in the
sorted function we had to define a
function and then we would pass that
function as the key so as some of you
may have figured this out
what we're going to do using the lambda
function is we're going to skip that
process of defining a function with a
new name and all that and we're going to
pass a lambda function or going to use a
lambda function
as the key so let's see how we do it
so initially what we've done is we've
created this list this list is a list of
dictionaries that you can see so this
first object is a dictionary second
object to the dictionary each dictionary
contains two keys um the name and the
age and the values are something like
nandini the
values for age is like 20 20 and 19. so
we have three dictionaries in a list
so what we're going to do
is we want to print what we what we want
to do with this we want to print
the these objects or these dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20.
so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied
on this list so this is our iterable now
if you see here in the key the key
parameter we don't we don't predefine a
function and pass it over here instead
we use the lambda and this lambda
function is defined in such a way so we
say lambda
it will take one argument i
and then it will return basically the
age
index for some i and this i is we're
going to presume an i to be some sort of
an iterable which has an index called
age and which is uh which is the case in
our case right we have a bunch of
dictionaries where there is a key in
each of these dictionaries called age so
we're going to use that and now you're
going to ask like what is i well when we
use the lambda function in the sorted
function this i will basically be each
object that we get when we iterate upon
this list so if we're going to iterate
first on this so it's going to take this
dictionary and it's going to search for
the age then it's going to take this
it's going to search for the age then
it's going to take this and it's going
to search for the age and each of the
time it will pull out what is the value
for each of these age keywords or these
age indexes or h keys and out of these
objects so 20 20 and 19 or these values
we're going to create a key with which
we're going to sort each object in this
whole list okay so this is how the
lambda function will work here so let's
do it so as you can see
our sorted list now contains this object
first because a 19 is smallest h and
then this and this now you might see
that there are two 20s so how do we
control which one comes first well by
default it will um
it will just uh give us the result in
the way we passed it in the original
list so since nandini came before
manjeet in the result also nandini will
come before manjit but what if we wanted
to sort it even more what if we want to
sort it in such a way that first we go
by age and the second key will tell us
that if there is a clash in ages we have
to go alphabetically by the name so in
this case we will create a second key
and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the lambda will again take one parameter
which is i which is going to be each
itera which which is going to be each
object in this iterable list and we're
going to take two keys so the first key
will be the h key
and the second key will be the name so
it will first sort on age and then on
name so now if you see
the result should be that manjit will
come before nandini even though the ages
are 20 because m comes before n in the
alphabet
as you can see this is the result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
to be more clear
now if i execute this basically this
whole
whatever result we get will be backwards
now
oh wait i did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we
execute this you will see nandhani comes
first manjit comes second and then
nikhil comes third because we've done
the reverse uh we use the reverse
keyword as true reverse parameter is
true in this video we will be covering
the topics of map filter and reduce
functions in python
now python provides several functions
that enable functional approach to
programming and since functional
programming is all about expressions
some of these expression oriented
functions of python are lambda functions
list comprehensions map filter
map filter and reduce now we've already
covered the topic of lambda and list
comprehensions
now let's cover the topics of map filter
and reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence
a function is basically
some defined some user defined function
or any function
a sequence is basically an iterable
object like a list or a tuple for
example or a bunch of lists and tuples
as well so let's look at an example so
one of the most common operations that
we do with something like a list is
doing an operation on each of the
elements in the list and then outputting
a new list with
the the values as uh whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list
so we do what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
you want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this
uh for example
over here
you can see when we print squared
we should get the list of uh whatever
square values we have uh for the
original list but this is uh slightly a
bit tedious and what if we had a method
that or a
what if we had a a technique where we
could
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of
applying whatever operations we want to
do on each element of a sequence so this
is where the map function comes in use
so let's look at
how we use the map function over here
so if you look at this i've defined a
square function so the square function
basically returns takes an argument x
and it returns the square of it and i
have a map function which takes the
square
function as one of the arguments and the
i the list or an iterable as the second
argument so this map function creates a
map object if you see here so let's just
do it one by one so i'm creating my list
and i'm going to create my function
called square
and i'm going to
send this to the map function so i'm
sending this
the first argument as the function that
i want to do and the second argument as
the list that i want to apply it on now
let's list out all the items that are in
this map object
so if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here i found a very neat way of
passing a function and then iterable
and using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable
so as you've seen we basically passed in
a user defined function and we applied
it to each item in the list then the map
calls the square function on each list
item and collects all the return values
into a new list and because map expects
a function to be passed in it also
happens to be one of the places where
lambda functions are
appearing a lot so let's look at the
an example where we do the same
operation using a lambda function so if
you see here i have a lambda function
where
i'm passing it as the function argument
and what this lambda function takes is
some variable x or some argument x it
does its square and it returns that x
and this x is basically going to come
from each element that is present in
this list called items and when we list
down these you will see it basically
does the same thing for us it creates a
list with squared items
now we can also pass instead of passing
uh an interval itself we can actually
pass a sequence of functions and use the
lambda function to perform
a sequence of functions on particular
items so let's look at a new example a
slightly different one so we're going to
use a numpy module for this don't worry
we're just using it to use the square
root function that is present in the
numpy power module
we will be learning about number in a
later section so we're going to import
this first and now i'm going to define
three functions for square cube and
square root
so once i've defined these basically
they're returning the square the cube
root uh the cube and the square root of
some integer x
and now i'm going to create a list of
these functions that you've just seen um
and we're going to
use a for loop and we're going to
iterate through a range from 0 to 4.
so and we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we want to
apply
some some function we want to apply some
function x and we want to return that
using this lambda function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called fu ncs or funcs and in
fu ncs we have a bunch of functions
called square cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to
r and r will take the value 0 to 4 and
now let's see when we print this what
values we get
so if you see here we get a list of
square root squares cubes and square
roots for integer 0
1
two
three and four so this is another way of
um using the map function and lambda
functions together to apply multiple
different operations to a bunch of
intervals
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically
what it does is it creates the upper
case of some string that we passed to it
right so that's what we've done here in
this function called two upper case so
before let's define this function now we
have a print function basically which is
going to print each object in a
particular um it's going to print each
element of a particular object and it's
going to at the end of it and the end of
printing we're going to give a small
space for printing a new line basically
so let's create this also this print
iterator object now what we're going to
do is we're going to pass a string with
the letters a b and c to this function
and we're going to map and we're going
to apply the upper case function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable
where it's a sequence of one character
strings so this whole string is
basically a sequence of one character
string a one character string b and c
so we're going to so
we can pass a string as a as an iterable
to the map function because it will
apply the operations on each of these
characters so let's see what happens
when we do the upper case function uh we
apply the upper case function using the
map
using mapping to the string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with a capital a capital b and capital c
as we had expected
because we have applied the list
function to the map object
now
in the next step what we're going to do
is we're going to do a very similar
thing we're just going to instead of
simply mapping and creating a list out
of it we're going to store the map
object in a variable called map iterator
we're going to print
what type of object it is and then we're
going to print out each of the elements
using the print iterator function that
we defined here so let's do this now if
you see the class the type of object is
of class map and the objects elements
inside the object are a b and c
moving on let's uh let's look at now an
example where we're going to pass
multiple arguments um so instead of one
iterable we're going to pass multiple
iterables now and we're going to apply
some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created two uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here um yeah so if you see here i have a
list and a tuple and i'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that i have defined a lambda
function as the operation that i'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments x and y and it returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get x and y from so the x it gets
from this uh
this sequence which is a list and it
takes y from this sequence which is a
tuple so what it's going to do is going
to take x as 1 and then y is 5 in the
first step and it's going to return the
product s5 and then the next step is
going to take 2 as x and then y as 6 and
it's going to return the product of that
and we're going to get 12 and so on
we're going to get 21 and then 32
when we read and this is these values
are going to be stored in the map
iterator which is a map type object and
when we use the print iterator function
it's basically going to print out
whatever results we got
through this mapping so let's execute
this and as you can see this is the
result we got 5 12 21 and 32 which is
what we wanted so the next part the next
function that we're going to discuss is
the filter function now now a fritter
function is basically again it takes two
two arguments a function and a sequence
and a function
basically tests if each element of a
sequence is true or not now a sequence
the sequence
um so this filter function will
basically take two arguments so one is
the function and this function is
basically going to test if each element
of a sequence is true or not and is
going to take another argument called
sequence and this argument sequence is
the list or the tuple or basically any
sequence and or iterable that needs to
be filtered and it can be
as i mentioned it can be sets list
tuples or containers of more iterators
and what this function will return is an
iterator that is already filtered um so
let's look at an example now so we have
this list r which you've generated which
is basically numbers from minus 5 to 4.
so if i
create this list here you can see it
will create a list of minus 5 to 4. now
if i wanted to extract only the values
that are lesser than 0 well i can use a
for loop and use a if condition to check
this right so if i did this over here
you can see it gives me it returns me
some list called result which contains
only the values
lesser than 0 which is basically checked
through this condition what if there was
a uh
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or
we're going to create the condition and
we're going to
pass this to a particular function and
then apply that particular operation on
every object of some sequence well just
like mapping we have a filter function
to do this and in this example what
we're going to use is the lambda
function which takes an argument x and
it checks for some condition x less than
zero and where it's going to get the x
from is some sequence r um which which
in our case is the numbers from minus
five to four and the filter will
basically create a filter object type
which contains uh only the objects from
r that meet this condition that is x is
less than zero and when we use the list
operation on top of it you will see it
creates it results in a list with the
values that have met my condition so for
a second example what we're going to do
is we're going to create
a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first of all
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that um
one of uh the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters and if it doesn't it returns
false so this is our condition that
we've created once we create this
condition uh this function that checks
this
we can pass this function and the
sequence into the filter function and
then we can list out whatever we get so
you can see our filtered list contains
only a and o which is basically the only
vowels that are present in our original
list finally we have the reduce function
this reduced function is basically a
func tools it's in the functo's module
of python 3.0 and what the reduce
function does is it applies a function
of two arguments cumulatively to the
elements of an interval and it
optionally it starts with an initial
argument and it returns a single result
so let's first import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some lists called numbers right
what if we wanted to take care to get
the sum of each element in this list
well we can iterate over it and store it
in some variable called total in each
step right
this is what we would typically
typically do and in this step what you
can see is the loop basically iterates
over every valuable in numbers and
accumulates them in total the final
result is the sum of all the values
which is the value of 10 over here in
this example the variable total is what
we call an accumulator and we can apply
the reduce function to do the same
task so how do we do it let's first of
all create a function called my add
where we're going to take two variables
uh two arguments and we're gonna return
the sum of it okay so let's define this
function and
now we have we have a list called
numbers right which contains one two
three and four now let's do reduce my ad
to numbers
now when i do this when i use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically
each and every element
uh in a sequence so it will take one and
two then add them together and then it
will create basically what it will do is
it'll take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it'll take
three and then the next element which is
three again so it will create the sum
which is 6 and then it will take 6 and
then it will take the value 4 and it
will give us the result 10. so this is
how the reduced function would work so
this is how it will give us the result
of 10.
as you can see here i've simply used i
passed this function where i've defined
that i want two
arguments to be passed to a function and
then the return should be basically the
sum and then i passed a whole list of
like four numbers and i've used the
reduce function to basically do this
process for four numbers in a
step-by-step manner by taking two at a
time subsequently and my result is as
you can see is correct as you can see
here
so let's use the lambda function now to
do the same topic just do the same task
so what i'm doing now is i'm going to
define a lambda function and that's the
function i'm going to pass to this
reduce so when i pass this lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments x and y and it's going to
return the sum of that
as x plus y now where it's going to get
x and y from is in a very in a very neat
manner so it will take first the first
two elements one and two it will then do
the sum and we get three then it will
take that same three and then take the
next object which is three again and
then give us six then it will take six
and then the next element which is 4 and
then give us 10 and then the reduce
function will output the the single
result which is 10 to us as you can see
here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to uh what i'm going to do is also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program
that we have to write where we compute
the frequency of words that exist in
some input okay uh the program should
output after sorting the key alpha
numerically now this input can be any
it's basically a block of text right so
in our example we have um for example if
this was our input right uh what we want
to see is an output which is basically
saying that uh the word python has
appeared say well in this example it's
appeared five times and then the word
read has appeared one time and so on and
so forth like for each of these words we
want to see um how many times have they
appeared in this particular block of
text so
let's look at
a particular example now where we have
done this
so let's um let's see here
so first of all i'm going to create a
dictionary so why am i creating a
dictionary is because i'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in
a block of text as the value to that key
so
i'm going to use a sample
string which is basically this long
string that you can see here which is
stored in line so this large chunk of
text is what we're going to be analyzing
so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here
is
we want to
um check word by word first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is before i encountered it for
the first time then we need to store a
new key in our dictionary called
frequent table or frequency table and if
it has already if there is a key already
with that
particular name then we just want to
increment the count or the value by one
so let's see how we do this over here
so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string
using the split function what this will
do is it will split up the string at
every white space so it will take this
as one part and take this part as
another part it will create an iterable
with each word as the um each iterable
object in that container so
it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key
then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count of
uh the value of that key by one but if
it does not exist then we're going to
actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value
initialize its value to one
so when we execute this
now
if we
want to once you've done this we can
sort it by the count of the words so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a another tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
lambda function out here
to
sort the dictionary in terms of its
values so what we're going to do is
we're going to take the key the key
being the lambda item item
with index one index one is basically
the value um so a a particular uh key
has a value so the word python appears
so many times the word
say scientist appears so many times so
we're going to check which words have
the highest number of occurrences and
we're going to sort it in a descending
order so that that is basically what the
reverse is equal to true does so when
we're going to sort this when we're
going to use the sorted function when we
say reverse true uh it tells the sorting
function to sort this dictionary this
dictionary frequency table
in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our
sorted tuple so
that's what we do in this line and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result
of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears five times and so on and so
forth so we've created a sorted tuple
where the first object of the tuple
we've created a list of sorted tuples
where the first object of the tube each
tuple is the unique word the second one
is the number of times it has appeared
in this particular example or this
particular string so yeah this was the
first basic project that we have tackled
in this you might have seen some
examples of how we do list operations
and how we use the lambda function in
sorting the
dictionary by the values of the key in
this video we will continue with what we
started in terms of our
project number one what we're going to
do is um we're going to tackle another
slightly complicated um
[Music]
a question or a situation um we're going
to try to arrive at a solution so in
this what we have is some sort of a
robot a moving robot which moves on a
cartesian plane a two coordinate plane
um is going to move in terms of up down
left and right okay and each each time
it moves up or down or left or right it
takes a certain number of steps in that
direction um integral steps of course so
what we need to do is uh from a starting
position whatever its starting position
is which we are going to take as 0 comma
0 in this example
we're going to make it move to a
particular location with the commands up
down left and right followed by certain
steps
and we're going to
ask what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the distance between
these two points
and we're going to calculate different
types of distances so you might be
introduced to new concepts um your
distance concepts in this video as well
so
what we're going to be using for
distance calculation is the minkowski
distance and that is we're going to take
so this minkowski distance between two
variables is basically the absolute
difference between these two uh
variables of these two points and
we take it to the power of something so
if we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms of the
quadratic main cause distance with
basically p2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to two we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance and
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
cartesian geometry when you are asked to
find the distance between two points on
a plane um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the
absolute distances between each point no
roots no powers nothing basically p is
equal to one and we call that the
manhattan distance so we're going to
take p is equal to one two and three in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points uh based on
these
measures
so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the euclidean distance
basically the
estimate of the value between these two
points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of if we
go up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another point so yeah let's move on to
the problem in this particular example
we're going to start from the starting
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up 5
down 3 left 3 and right 2. so first of
all what we want to do is we initialize
the starting position as 0 and 0 and we
also just for the sake of this example
we initialize the end position as 0 and
0.
so what we're going to do first of all
is
let's execute this much now we have this
list list of tuples um it's we're going
to call this actions and this is the
actions that we're performing
so
this the each tuple contains an action
and the number of steps in that
direction so it contains four actions
up by five steps down by three steps
left by three steps right by two steps
so now we're going to iterate over this
each tuple and we're going to get the
direction first of all in this line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is
stored in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so
what happens is if you go up
by a particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the uh the y axis so we're going to
change end position and the first index
which is basically this part of the
end position
coordinate point so we're going to say
if it's moving by up then we're going to
uh update
by adding uh
the y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction was down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if you're moving left
it's a negative uh it's a decrement and
if you're moving right it's an increment
so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right otherwise we we
just skip that particular action so this
is what the this particular loop will do
it will update our final position
so once we've done this uh if we if i
execute this
what will get stored in the end position
is basically my end position so
now that i have my starting position and
my end position
um just to show you what the end
position will look like right now
let's
just do this so if you see here after
i've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0
it is 0 0 so now we're going to find the
distance between 0 and 0 and minus 1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the uh
the difference between the
what do you say um the end position x
coordinate and the end position y
coordinate times
or to the power of a root and uh we're
basically going to do this operation
that
you saw here we're going to do this
and um
we're going to use this root variable to
specify to like p is equal to one two or
three like what p value we want to take
for this minkowski distance so once
we've done this what this function will
do is basically store
uh this much and it will wait for us to
uh it will basically wait for us to give
us a root so when we give root one it
will create these it will check the
distance between the end and starting
points um with the p value of one if we
give it two it will calculate euclidean
distance with p value two similarly for
three and we can calculate for any roots
so we're going to calculate for 1 2 and
3 roots
and we're going to see what values we
get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 i print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 is
something root 3 something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the um
the cubic minkowski distance with
basically the with root 3 is 1.91 so you
see these three different uh distance
measures for the same distance between
two points so in this video you
basically so in this basically by doing
this activity you might must have you
will learn
how to
basically how to iterate through loops
um and perform these distance
calculations which you'll find pretty
handy in
many activities related to data science
and machine learning in this video we
will be continuing tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of a
project called project 3 where we're
going to be using regular expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered or do they match
certain criterias or not so let's look
into our particular question we have a
website that requires users to input
username and password to register now we
have to write a program to check the
validity of passwords input by the users
now the criterias that the passwords
have to follow are that there's at least
one letter between a and z and one
number between zero and nine uh the
third criteria is that uh there's at
least one letter between capital a and
capital z so this first and third point
basically is saying that there should be
one lowercase letter and there should be
one uppercase letter now there should be
at least one character from dollar sign
hash or the at symbol um it should have
a minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12.
so when we whatever passwords that we
enter into our
example they must be comma separated so
if we're going to have an input uh
they're going to ask us for an input
where we're going to have to input the
different passwords in a comma separated
way so let's look let's look at uh how
do we tackle this so for my example i'm
going to use these uh examples in terms
of these are my password examples if
you're going to check if these are valid
passwords or not so let's copy this
first of all and now let's import the re
this import rd is basically the regular
expression module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords as you can see here
so i will just ctrl v so since this is
comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these
by the comma and it will store them in a
list so it will take this as one
password this has another password this
has another password and this has
another password once i press enter
now if i want to check what's in list i
mean what's in items
what i can do is
just check over here what's in items
it's a list of whatever password i had
entered
each object is separately treated now in
this list
now i'm going to create a an empty list
called value first of all once i've done
that i'm going to move on to the next
step
so once i've created my list called
value what i'm going to do is now i'm
going to search and i'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have
initially
so
if you see here what i'm going to do is
first iterate by each item in this to
check for each password now my first
check will be a basic check
for the length of the password if it's
lesser than 6 or greater than 12 then
our basically our password is illegal so
we can't be using this and we will just
continue and we won't check for anything
else but if it is within 6 and 12 the
length 6 and 12 then we can
continue with our check so we can do
we'll do an statement for pass which
basically moves on to this
next block
now once you've done this
what we will do is
this this first statement what this is
going to do is it's going to do an re
dot search and re-dot search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of um
a letter occurring between
a and z so this ire.search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does is basically the square in the
square brackets we're looking for
anything between
a and z in terms of small letters so if
this condition is not met then again we
continue and we leave this a particular
search because one of our criterias is
not met
all right but if it is met then this if
not statement will not uh like we won't
enter this block and we can move on to
the next check
so
now now we move to lf not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for uh a negative
case so anytime one of these cases have
been met it basically means that our
password has been invalid because these
conditions are not being met so we're
trying to eliminate all conditions all
of these conditions so that we get a
valid password so again we move on to
the next statement which is basically
going to do the search for numbers once
again if we find a case a password
without any numbers
we continue and we don't
check this password no more because we
already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for these particular
symbols the dollar the hash and the at
one of these three symbols uh we're
going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
that's an illegal password and we're not
going to continue checking for those
cases
so
so this is basically all our cases lower
case letters
numbers capital letters these one of
these three symbols and the existence of
a white space so once we've done all
these checks if none of these have been
passed we move on to this else statement
where we just pass and what we can do is
we append the value p to the
the list called value
so basically what happens is um just to
go through it again
if this condition is not met and this
condition is not met this is not met
this is not met this is not met and if
this is
also not met then we're fine so
basically as long as we have small
letters as long as we have a number as
long as we have a capital letter as long
as we have one of these three symbols
and as long as we don't have
any uh white space characters we can
append e to this otherwise it will
continue and it will break out of this
for loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks um anytime this condition is met
uh this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this uh
whole for loop and we don't append p to
the value but uh if we actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh p to value now finally what we
are going to do is we are going to print
out all the valid passwords so just by a
quick look you can see here this is a
valid password right so let's execute
this and let's see uh
what we get if you see here we only get
one valid password and let's look at why
um some of these did not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign
in this case we have two white spaces
one over here and one over here so this
is an illegal password similarly in this
case also we have an illegal password
because it begins with a space
in this case it's the same thing we
begin with a space and also it does not
have any of those symbols that we were
looking for the dollar or the hash or
the ad so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to value however this does get
appended to value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password welcome to
web scraping with python my name is
richard kirschner with the simplylearn
team certainly there are many reasons to
be able to go online and scrape
different websites they range everything
from pulling out different links uh to
pulling data off of websites as a data
scientist you might need to get some
information off a website that doesn't
have a direct api to pull that
information and in python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk python and
you talk web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crummy.com
software slash beautiful soup you can
actually read a little bit about it
currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for it you can always
do what i do which is go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want ide i'm going to use jupiter lab
which is built on jupiter notebook
through anaconda so when i open up my
anaconda navigator you'll see that i
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pycharm
or something like that we don't need to
do this and jupiter lab is jupiter
notebook with added tabs and some added
features it's basically in beta testing
so it's got a few little glitches when
you're saving things and moving between
projects but for the most part it's a
great upgrade to the jupiter notebook
and you can use them together so you
don't have to i mean it's built on
jupiter notebooks anything you do in
jupiter notebook you can open up in
jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead in this
case i'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and i'm going to open up a terminal
window we have to install some packages
in here to work with now there's a lot
of choices on this i because of the
simplicity we'll be using conda install
now you can use pip install for the same
thing and we're going to install our
beautiful soup four and you have to type
out the whole thing beautiful soup for
you can use a pip install if you're
using a different environment and i am
using python version 3.6
although according to beautiful soup
they also work on 3 7 all the way from 2
7 through all of 3x now according to the
beautiful soup website the beautiful
soup 4 works on anything you can install
on anything from python 2 7 all the way
through any of the python 3 versions
this just happens to be python 36
because i do there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on 3.7 yet and
we'll go ahead and run this install on
here and let it go through its
environmental setup and of course with
conda it goes in there and finds all the
dependencies pip doesn't do as much as
far as finding dependencies but you know
exactly what's on there with pip so if
you're doing a huge distribution you
probably want to use your pip install so
you can track what's going on there with
the
conda i like to just let it take over
since this isn't a major distributed
package going out another quick note
between pip and conda is that if you
start on a project in one of these
environments and you're using pip in
there stick with pip if you're using
conda stick with conda they track the
packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply
install pandas and let's just install a
couple more packages in this case let's
get our install our map plot library
because we're going to plot at the end
since we're going to be collecting data
and for this project that will be all
the packages we'll need so we can go and
close out of our installer whatever
setup you have and we'll go back to home
and we'll just launch our jupyter lab
and that will open up in our browser
window now if you're coming from jupiter
notebooks and first time in lab we can
go ahead and just create our first
notebook python3 you can also do it
under a file launcher and you'll see new
notebook it automatically opens up and
we just click right on there it'll pop
open on the left and i'll right click
this and we'll rename this we'll rename
it just beautiful and it is a i n b file
on there so that should look familiar
because that's the jupiter notebook file
this is a new one now i have more tabs
in the past i usually hid this on the
other computer all my notes for the
lesson today but this is my notes going
down and we'll go ahead and just start
going through this and see what it looks
like to do a data poll from front to end
and see how that works as a data
scientist pulling that information in
from the website and the first thing i
want to do is i want to go ahead and
close this side window that way it looks
get the nice full screen and we can also
up the size a little bit one of the
wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that control plus
thing the packages we talked about is
pandas so we imported our pandas if you
haven't already that's our data frame if
you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas it's
such a powerful tool this basically
turns your data into a spreadsheet data
frame our numpy is our number array
so it kind of works with pandas very
closely as far as manipulating data in
arrays map plot we want to go ahead and
bring that in our plt so that we can
plot the data at the end and this line
right here it says matplot library
inline is for the jupiter notebook
specifically it tells it to print that
on this page a lot of the newer versions
don't actually require to have that line
they'll still print it on the page but
you should still include that if you're
in the jupiter lab setup and then we
have our url library.request we're going
to import url open for opening up the
website and then we have our bs4 that's
your beautiful soup for we're going to
import beautiful soup and then our last
one is our re that is for manipulating
our regular expressions so we get to
that part of importing our data we have
to do a lot of reformatting so it's
something we can use and the re is one
of those tools we'll go ahead and run
this and just bring all that in so this
is all imported all these packages are
now into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data which have a nice
website to pull from and let's go ahead
and we'll use the hovertiming.com
results for the
2018 martin luther king race and if we
take this you can actually just take
this where did we get this from well you
can go in here and find the website
you're going to scrape from and you'll
see right here it says you just copy
that link right in there that http um
and this is the website that we're
looking at you can see right here all
the information that we're looking at
let's say we wanted to run some
statistics on this it sure would be nice
to be able to pull it off of here and if
they don't have a direct api that means
we need to pull it from their website
some of these will have a download
although if you've ever done we have a
download click and maybe you're paging
through a hundred websites uh in one
case i was pulling all the different
united states bills that are passed to
track who voted on them for a project
and you can imagine that there's you
know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on and it goes
through the senate goes back to the
congress so i opened up a website pull
all the links off of there that match
the certain criteria and we'll look at
that in just a minute how we go through
the html and then i had to reformat them
or i could hand download each one one at
a time which would just be a nightmare
so it's nice to automate it in this case
we're going to be pulling up this chart
we want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website and so we go
back into our jupyter notebook i've got
my url just our name for it and it's
just a string that's all this is nothing
fancy there you'll notice that on the
slashes we now have forward forward
slash you can do a single forward and
http is a double forward this is just
how you have to switch it to match setup
in there and then it's going to go ahead
and use the html equals url open url and
that's from our url library request so
it's opening a link to that website or
at least pointing to it and if we run
this this just sets it up so this is all
set up and then once we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be and if
you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported from the
bs4 and this is the package that we're
working with and so we're going to do
our beautiful soup on here and on this
we need to go ahead and send it our html
so it knows what it's opening and then
the second part is we have to tell it
how the format is coming in and the most
common one for your html polls is an
lxml setup and so almost all of them
you'll end up using the lxml there's a
few other options and because this is so
common in the newer versions a lot of
times they just leave it out just
because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions
they actually default it to the xml
setup in the html we'll just leave it
out and call it html so it's just gonna
pull from this url and when we run that
on here we've now created an object soup
that has pulled the website into it so
soup contains the information along with
information on that website and what's
going on so let's just go over what we
did real quick before we start digging
into the actual soup before we start
scooping out stuff we imported our
different
modules that we're going to use with our
package specifically the beautiful soup
we did install the beautiful soup if you
remember correctly you have to call it
beautiful soup 4 specifically so it
knows what you're bringing in and this
line right here is very key from bs4
because that's how it installs the
module we're importing our beautiful
soup and then we found our url in this
case we're going to go pull information
from the martin luther king dream run
and then we set our html to our url open
url and you can see right here we
imported that so here's our url.request
import url open so we're requesting a
connection and once we send that
connection into the beautiful soup it
creates an object called soup and then
this one of course we chose soup just
because it goes with beautiful soup i
guess we could have chosen beautiful and
now we can start extracting information
from our website because we pulled it
down onto our computer under soup now we
can start by looking at the title of the
website
soup.title and if we print title dot
text you'll see this a lot in beautiful
suit because title contains all kinds of
information and if we want just the text
from that title you add the dot text on
the end and you can see right here we
have our 2018 mlk dream run 5k race
results if you look at the tab that's
the actual title up here uh 2018 mlk
dream run 5k race that's what the title
is on the website and then you might be
curious what's in title what's the whole
title that it's storing up there well
let's go ahead and print it out here's
print title and print title.txt and we
run that you can see it has the html
tags title on it and then the forward
slash title to end it and so we're
really just pulling off this piece of
the html code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
html and earlier i mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page well that would be fun uh we
could do soup dot and we'll do find
underscore all put this in bracket and
then quotation marks we're going to put
a a is the
key find and you'll start seeing a div
and all the different options you have
for finding these entities in a website
and then let's go ahead and just print
our links and you can see here that it
now shows all the different links in
here that are marked by eggs we did a
find all a and then we can also because
this is a little bit hard to pull off
the h reference so we can also add in
our find all fine-tune that in this case
the h reference equals true we'll
actually filter that out and then
finally we might do a four link in links
and we can simply do something like this
for each link we want to actually find
the h reference because we know there's
an h reference in it and if i run this
you can see it just comes through and
prints them out one at a time some of
these are really useful so you might be
looking for something that has https in
it and you know that's a link running to
something else or you might be looking
for the mail to tags you know that's all
the mail addresses but either way you
can easily find all the links in your
html document that you're paging through
and of course
any packages that have evolved over time
you can also do
get h reference which should do the same
thing as our other format and you can
see it certainly does we get the same
printout up here in this particular case
we really want to get the data off the
page uh so let's go ahead and do that
let's see what that looks like and in
data let's call it all rows there we go
equals and then we have our soup dot
find underscore all there's our brackets
and then if we're looking for each row
in a database you'll remember your html
code we're looking for the tag tr so we
want to find all tr and we can take this
and let's go ahead and just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're going to guess that
we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so uh from beginning to five
and you can see here's our first five
rows on here i sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers finisher is 191
and just out of curiosity which if
that's zero what's row one
okay so we're starting to see titles
going across here so if we come up here
and we do rows we did what up to ten
let's just take a look and see what 10
does again and just take a look at that
information that comes across place
bib name gender age city state chip chip
pace gender and so on so it comes all
the way down here we kind of have an
ending right here and then we have one
and then we actually it looks like we
start to have information so we have our
1 or 1 1191 max randolph that must be
the name male 29 and so on and start
seeing how the information starts
getting displayed going down so the next
thing we want to do with this i'll go
back up here and just edit the space
we're in so it starts to make a little
bit more sense keep it all together and
so we want to do for each row in all
rows we're looking at what information
are we looking at well we have our th up
here that's a header our td down here
which looks like the individual
information and we really are looking
for
the actual data so we're looking for td
tags in the rows and we can do that
because when you remember when it stores
the row it also stores the tags
underneath that so all rows have all the
different tags in it and you can see
right here as you print each one of
those out and so we look at each row we
can create another variable we'll call
it row list and we'll set this equal to
in this case row because we've already
pulled all the rows out of soup so now
we want to find for each row and in
there we want to find our td and if we
go ahead and just print i'm going to do
it if you notice i changed the indent so
i'm just going to print row list what
this does is the last value to go into
row list our last row is going to print
now and of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're typing so row dot find underscore
all td and if we print the last row you
can see i have all the data coming
across here we have our 191 our 1216
zuma ochoa i hope i said that right
female i believe that's age 40 and so on
and then we can take our row list and
there's a lot of things we can do with
the row list what we'll do for let's do
object or let's just do cell in row list
and so we're going to look at each cell
because this is if you look at this they
have commas separated between the
different objects and then we're going
to go ahead and print
cell dot text let's just take a look and
see what that looks like and we can see
here for each row we get 191 there's our
191 there's our 12 16 12 16 our
individual who's in the race and so
forth all the way down for those
different settings and let's go ahead
and create a new variable up here uh
we'll call this all let's just call it
data we'll keep it simple uh so here's
our data and then we have our row we
take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this
data row we'll set this empty to an
empty row and we're going to take our
cells tab this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is i want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so i'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once i create each row
i want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were lurking with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the date on the page and
we get uh finishers 199 male 78 female
113 one and so on and if you look at
this this is the headers on the file we
have finishers uh male females just like
some general statistics on the first one
and then we have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have one 1191 max randolph mill 29
washington dc runtime one of 78 and so
on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that number of different ways
to do that one of them is just to do
we're going to set we do data 2 on we
should get rid of everything but we want
to keep randolph so make sure randolph
is in there oh we lost randolph let's
try one on there we go there's max
randolph on there uh so we can just
simply do redo our data on here and we
can do data probably want to do it in
all rows from one on but i'm just going
to do my data equals data one on down
here and there's reasons to split it
this way in data science sometimes you
don't want to touch the original data in
case you need it in case we do need the
first row so we'll put it down here and
maybe we'll just call this titles titles
equals data of zero and so we could do
something here where we print we'll
print up our titles and we'll print our
data in this case instead of one on
let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
is expecting a little bit more up there
and we have our last couple people and
they look like the data on these looks
just fine on here turns out this is just
some generic statistics up here so we'll
get rid of titles completely it doesn't
really do us any good but we know that
data comes in here and we can look at
our data and look at the very end of the
data too the minus two to the end and we
can see it pulls the data in pretty good
we don't have anything too funky in here
we're looking at it looks pretty clean
now you got to be a little careful
because at some point we might have to
come back here and clean up the data if
we get an error for running a data
analysis we might find out there's some
unusual characters or something is
missed in the data itself and you also
notice that everything is a string so
when we're bringing it in we might have
to do some conversions to test it out
and convert them to whatever kind of
data format we're working with so at
this time we want to go ahead and bring
in our pandas um and let's go ahead and
call this
df for data frame we'll set it equal to
and if you remember correctly we
imported pandas as pd and that's
standard you'll see that in most code
examples where they call the import
pandas as pd um and it is capital d
capital f for data frame and we're just
going to bring in our data that's what
we called it on here and let's uh take
this and we'll print now when you're
working with data frames you're usually
talking large amounts of data and so you
almost never want to print the whole
data frame out we're going to go ahead
and do that anyway just so we can see
what that looks like and you can see in
here brings in our data frame coming in
here we just have a mess of information
this is our data let's go ahead and
print df and see what that looks like in
the data frame and this is nice because
it organizes it into a very easy to read
table and we have they set the label 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 and so on and then we have
each row we have mel
78
going across when we get all the way
down here we'll see max randall about
number three and the first thing this
does is this flags me that i brought in
a bunch of information up here that we
really didn't want uh it's from three on
that we want and we can clean this up in
one of two ways we can try to clean it
up under the data or we can clean it up
under the data frame depending on what
it is we're trying to do and so to fix
this
i want to go ahead and just change it up
here in the actual data pull in we don't
need that information so i'll rerun it
reload our data from 4 on and then when
i run this we see we have max randolph
is right at the top of the list like he
should be and we have all the data going
down now with the data frame remember i
said we don't usually print the whole
data frame we'll go ahead and do df.head
and this prints the first five rows and
you can see that we have 13 columns
here's max randall all the way to theo
kinman and i usually also print df
tail and the reason i like to do these
particular two setups i'm gonna change
it just to two rows because you can do
that you can put as many rows as you
want is this good to look at the first
part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in uh something's messed up and
you can also see that we have 190 rows
in here and it comes in with our zuma
lisha and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the setup on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you could look at individual
cells maybe find a marker in that cell
that's something specific like remove
all colons or semicolons or something in
there or brackets there's a lot of
options in there but you'll find that
this one actually comes in pretty clean
on here all the way down and the next
thing we really want to do is we want to
look at the headers i don't know about
you but it doesn't make any sense to me
when i have column one i don't know what
1191 is or 1080 need name kaiser runner
i'm guessing that's column two is names
third one it looks like male or female
probably age but i don't want to guess i
want this to bring in my column so i
know exactly what i'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in jupyter lab in
this case jupiter notebook i can just
type out column headers if it's the last
variable i have listed it will
automatically print it so it's kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place i'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there i shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just a pin and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column.text and then if we come
down here and we print
our header list let's see what that
looks like if we did it right we should
get a nice list of all the different
column headings we want so we have place
bib name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool we can simply
do df columns equals our header from our
header list we simply said df column set
to df headers and then if i print
df.head we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
i want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object i usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if i put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different ide you'd want to go
ahead and use the print statement on
here and then one of the things you'd
want to also go through we'll create a
second one df2 equals df dot drop in a
now the axis is automatically equal to
0. so a lot of times you'll see
something like axes equal 0 comma how
equals any axis equals 0 is default that
means we're looking at going down the
rows you could look at the column going
across let's remove the how any this is
going to confuse you the axes is whether
you're going down the columns or if
you're looking at a row by row by row by
row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column and it would drop off
the n a in any column and how equals and
we want any i always confuse all in any
they both start with a all means that
all of them have to be non-value where
any means that any of them can be there
to drop it so this would drop any column
with a null value in it but we want 0
and it'll drop any value with a null
value and then because 0 is always the
default we'll just leave it out and then
it's curious as to what the shape is now
did we lose anything was there any null
values in our df2 that we dropped from
the df and we'll go ahead and run that
and we see 191 and 14. so we didn't
really drop anything but it's always
good to check there's other ways you can
also do are there let's see any n a's
you can detect n a's in here no values
infinite values that's another one you
got to watch out for we're working with
data that we're going to do something
with here in a minute so you got to be a
little careful also in the convergence
are you going to convert something where
people typed in weird characters to
describe the data a certain way so now
we've got to this point where we have
all our different columns we have our
different data and
at this point maybe you're asking or
maybe the shareholder the company is
asking hey can we look at the um based
on the
chip time here's our chip time can we
plot that versus gender how does gender
versus chip time compare and so we can
do that we can take that and the first
thing we look at is we say hey well chip
time came in as a string and that's
going to be an issue now there's a
number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this i notice that anytime
there's two colons in it that's probably
a time signature and let's convert all
the time signatures to date time filled
or whatever a lot of times you don't get
that you don't get that option and
that's always a question in bringing in
data whether you convert the data coming
in at the beginning or do you wait till
you have it open it up and then convert
it when you go to use it we're going to
go ahead and convert it after we got it
into our data frame so we have our df2
here we've dropped all of our n a's we
dropped our we have a shape in fact
let's do this since there's no
difference between df and df2 well we'll
just go ahead and use df2 so let's go
ahead and take our df2 and we want to
take those that specific field and
convert it into some kind of numerical
value we can use and let's add another
column a lot of times this is something
you want to do is where you want to go
ahead and keep all the original columns
and just add a new column in there and
this new column is going to be based on
the if remember correctly we had chip
time that's what we're going to look at
okay we want chip time versus gender if
we go into our pandas we find out we
have
pandas to delta and this is actually
time delta and then we just want to take
our df2 and we're going to use the chip
time column so this is going to say hey
let's look at let's convert everything
in df2 chip time into a time delta
format that's the data type we're going
to put it as let me go ahead and just
run this and if we go in here and we do
info df2 and we'll keep our we're going
to look at this particular column but we
want to keep it as a data frame so this
is a list of all the columns we want to
look at we'll just do dot info on here
and run that and we do an info on that
you can see is now a
time delta 64 nanoseconds well we really
don't want nanoseconds we actually
probably want to do it in minutes uh so
let's take a look at that and let's take
this whole thing tf2 let's just set the
df2 we have our df2 this is a column
we're working with here and we can use
the as type property in pandas and so we
can set this equal to df2 we'll take our
same uh column in here and we'll set it
as type time delta seconds so it's still
a delta time here so if i run this
you'll see that it still comes up as
where is it hopefully it turns it into a
float so we're now at a float 64 so it's
the number of seconds in that delta time
and then finally we want to go ahead and
turn that from seconds to say minutes
and you know there's 60 seconds and
minutes and so now we divide by 60 we
still have a float we have our info it
shows us it's a float and then we can go
ahead and just do a print df2 and let's
just keep it small we don't want to look
at all our data we just want to do the
head of it and we run this and you can
see right here where we go to be the
last one here's our chip time in minutes
and a lot of times just to make life
easy for viewing since we're only
looking at this particular element we
can do chip time in minutes and now we
just see that we take off we'll go ahead
and take off our info done with that and
we'll run this and you can see we have
our minutes 16.8 minutes 17.51 minutes
and so on it's a float number now keep
in mind this is 0.8 that's not a 16
minutes and 80 seconds that they can
always throw you if you're going through
so many numbers you forget it's
important to remember that and we're
also going to look at the other one
we're looking at is what gender you want
to look at gender to
chip time in minutes and so we can see
here under the head we get male male
male and a number of different setups
and let's switch this to tail real quick
and just look at the end of it and here
we have female female male female female
so we have two different genders and we
have our chip time in minutes and if you
remember we brought in our plt if you
haven't used the plot library the
matplot library you have a drawing place
you're putting stuff on so we have our
plt we're going to do a bar graph and we
just want to simply use our df2 gender
and df2
chip time in minutes so that's going to
plot the two bars and to make it pretty
we'll go ahead and give it the x label
gender the y label chip time minutes and
that simply is remember it always plots
x and plots y we have our gender our
chip time give it a nice title uh
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female uh and if we go ahead
and run this with the correct titles in
here and everything matches you'll get a
nice graph we can see here the
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
uh there's a number of studies that show
that women team tend to have as far as
doing cross-country there's a lot of
women who have a longer endurance than
men so it's not too surprising but we
can see here the average chip time
around 70 and for women over 100 minutes
and then another really cool thing we
can do is we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is we're going
to include uh np number the numpy number
and if we run that you'll see here comes
up and it says chip time in minutes a
count it gives you the average or the
mean standard deviation the minimum the
maximum all the different descriptive
information you're going to want from
your data set on there and just because
there's all kinds of fun ways let's do a
box plot to display your information we
can do a box plot where the column
equals chip time in minutes and let's go
ahead and run that keep mistaking my
chip time in minutes you can see it puts
out a nice box plot showing you the
information we have our different values
and floaters this is always interesting
this is a nice way of seeing where we
have these uh floaters one up here and
there's two up above and of course here
they're a nice spread on the box plot
and we can also uh modify this a little
bit and we can add in by equals gender
and then we'll give it a we'll just give
it a blank title i don't know why we're
giving a blank title uh we'll just add a
y plot y label on there for run time and
if we run this you can see here box plot
grouped by gender chip time in minutes
and now we have our female and male two
different areas and you can see how they
vary you have your two different your
outlier up here and you can also see how
there's such an overlap between the two
different values so if i was looking at
this i'd be like wow you know i really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that women's run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions i'd have to come up with
done here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus df2 of h there's our xy
coordinates but if you remember from df2
when we did the info let's go way back
up here we're looking at a data object
as far as our chip time on this and our
h now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the h and if we do
it right here we just plot it and it'll
actually let us plot it it shouldn't it
should give us an error but it does let
us plot it you'll see the ages come up a
mess over here because they're
converting it to weird float numbers and
all kinds of things so what we want to
do is we want to take our age and we'll
just call this h underscore i so we're
going to take our age and we're going to
create another column for df2 age
underscore i and the i is just going to
stand for integers our own choice of
values there is a number of ways to do
this but we're going to do pandas to
merrick is the best way in pandas and
the reason we're doing this is that
numeric creates a float value so right
off the bat we want all our stuff
converted it converts it to the least
common denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a
null so it goes from like a string to a
null versus just having some kind of
made up number that python somehow
created for the graph we have below and
then we want to add our df2h because
that's what we're converting to numeric
and then we want to coerce it and
there's a couple different options on
this like you can have it where it just
doesn't process it in pandas but coerce
means that if it gets a weird value that
is a null value now and since we're
dealing with errors this is what happens
when you get an error converting it we
want to coerce it there we go and put
the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so i'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
i've taken df2h which is a d type object
which in this case is mostly strings
with a couple blank ones in there and
we're going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert and usually that's
a blank screen like i said i've worked
with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes in a dash to mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can this might get you
in trouble because you might have null
values in a different column and so you
might lose uh data that way um at this
point we could also do like certain
parts of like drop just certain columns
with null values there's all kinds of
other options in here what we're just
going to do how we're going to just drop
any and we want to do it in line equals
true so that means it's going to
reassign it to
df2 so df2 now has a rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
i and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors when we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axes one is
your column by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rolls and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70. uh
so we have our chip time set and then
our age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show
for display and for the the um and you
can easily show that to your
shareholders or whatever group you're
working on it makes a really nice and
quick easy display in this session we
will discuss the top tips and tricks in
python that you can use to solve your
problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by guido van rozum
it has simple easy to use syntax
python can run on different platforms
such as windows linux and unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as c c plus
and java
companies use python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python trips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually short
snippets of python code with simple
illustrations to tell you
how you can perform a complex task
easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries
we'll also see how to effectively use
loops iterators and collections in
python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where i'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first i'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets i'll
declare a string suppose
india
and now
if i use the multiplication operator and
suppose i say 10
then i'll print a
so this will print india 10 times
if i hit shift enter it will run that
cell
you can see we have printed india 10
times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
so india and then we have
france
i'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10. so let me print my list again
if i hit shift enter you can see india
and france have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose i am printing 20 five times
i'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 20 five
times
but
if i pass an integer as my first operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if i use c
equal to
20 into five
and if i print c
it will give me the product of twenty
and five that is hundred
next
let's see how you can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
i'll declare my
list as list one is equal to
and inside this list i'll
pass in a few country names such as
india then we have
usa
let's say we have france
and then
germany
and finally we have
spain now if you want to reverse the
order of this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so i'll write
print
and i'll pass in my list that is list1
and i'll use
double colon
followed by -1
so this will read my list from the end
so if i hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed
our original list so now spain comes
first then germany france usn india
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time i'll use list 2 is
equal to
i'll pass in few integers say
200
300
and 400
now if i
print
my list
2
using colon colon minus 1
it will reverse
list 2.
you can see we have reversed our
original list 2 so now 400 comes first
then 300 200 100.
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer
suppose i have a list that has values
like 1 comma 2
3 and 4
then i'll print this list
after that
i'll use four variables
such as a comma b comma c comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me
go ahead and print
any order that i want for example i use
b comma a comma d comma c
and hit shift enter you can see we have
printed our list in the order that we
wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned
the value 1 from list to a
2 to b
3 to c and 4 to d
and we are printing in an order badc
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say i want
c first
then i want b
a
and then d
[Music]
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
python
so list comprehension is an effective
way to define and create new lists based
on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn
and add letters as items of a list
ideally you would use a for loop to do
this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for loop i'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to
i'll use
square brackets to assign my empty list
then
and declare a for loop suppose for i in
i'll pass in my string that is simply
learn
and
i'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print
the letters
if i hit
shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first i'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets i'll
write
i for
i in my string
simply learn
then i'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for loop to do
it
so let me show you how you can proceed
so
before to define a function so first
i'll import
the math module present in python
and then let's say i'm defining a
function called
square
and i'll pass in a parameter as a
then i'll write e is equal to
i'll use
the power function
so i'll first
give in my module name that is math and
use the power function that is pow
and i'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
i'll give him 2
and i'll
return my parameter that is a
if i hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function
now let me call that function
if i write
square of a
it has given me one by default
now suppose i want to find the square
of integer 5
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose i
declare an empty list called squares
i'll pass in my empty list
and then i'll use a for loop say for
example for
i
in range
i'll give 10 as my range
and then
i'll append my square value so i'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
dot
append
so i'll use squares dot append
and pass i
into i
and then
i'll just
call my
empty list squares
if i hit shift enter
you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of 5 whole numbers between 0
and 20 having an interval of 4
so i'll use
squares is equal to
i'll say x
double multiplication operator
into 2
for
x
in
say range
i'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
20
with an interval of 4
now i'll
print
squares
if i hit shift enter
you can see it has printed the square of
values so first the number is 0 so 0
square is 0 then the number was 4 so 4
square is 16
8 square is 64.
then 12 square is 144 and then 16 square
is 256.
moving ahead
in the next trick
i'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's say
i have a list
that has items
say
310
294 i am taking random integers
450
and say 243
and now
if i
use a print statement suppose
i'll write using the
enumerate function
then i'll use a for loop say for example
for
index
comma
element
in
enumerate
i'll pass in my
list that is list underscore items
after that
i'll use a print statement
i'll pass in
index
and then
i'll give
a list
and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
i'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if i hit shift enter you can see
we have printed the index position as
well as the item value so at index 0 we
have 310 at index 1 we have 294
similarly for index 2 and 3.
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert to
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function
with our list as parameters
so let me define our two lists say item
number and names
so i'll use
item number
and give him some random whole numbers
102
410
and let's say 321
and i'll use my second list
that is names
and let's say this list has
some string values like
phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
i'll
assign a variable say item
dictionary
is equal to i'll use the
dict function
and then
pass in zip
and i'll pass in my parameters item
number and
names
finally i'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so i'll
pass in my dictionary
and then i'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see
we have all the keys printed similarly
if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
i'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two lists
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore a
that will be equal to
davis
then let's say we have karen
then we have
john
we have frank next
and then let's see we have another
person say steve
and let me declare my list
b
so list underscore b
is equal to i'll take kerin
next we have davis
then suppose we have
jack
up next we have
george
and then say we have steve again
now to find the common elements i'll use
variable let's say common
and i'll again
use a list comprehension say a
for
a
in
list a
then use for
b
in
list
b
then i'll use an if clause so if a
equals to equals to b
then
i'll
print the common variable
by run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list a and b
so davis kerin and steve are present in
both list a and b
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list
such problems you would often come
across while doing data analytics
so the idea is very simple just need to
convert the items in a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose i have a list of
numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20
22
24
so 26
then we have
28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
and we have 22
and let's say we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so i'll say original list
equals to
and then i'll pass in my
list that is list numbers
after that
i'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so i'll first use the list function and
then inside of that i'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally
i'll
print my new list
so i'll type
list
after
removing
duplicates
that will be equal to
i'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if i run it
you can see our original list has all
the elements that has duplicate values
and the final list the output you can
see we have only the unique elements
printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
python 3.4 version and below
so let's see i have two dictionaries say
team a
i'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
i'll give my key as one and i'll take
davis
i'll give my second key
and see i have andrew in my team
and then let's say i have my
third key
and let's
see i have karen
similarly let me declare my
team b dictionary
i'll take
the next key as 4
and the next person would be
say john
and then
i'll use my fifth key
we have angela
and let's see i have my final member in
the team
the sixth member
who is suzanne
now
if you do it in python 2 or python 3.4
version and below i have to define a
function so let me say define
merge underscore teams which will be my
function name
and i'll pass in two parameters say
dict 1
and
dict
2
then i have dict 3
in dict 3
i'll use the
copy method so i'll
use date
1
dot
copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my
dict
3
dot
update
i'll
pass in my
dict 2
and then
see i'll
return
my dict
3 finally
i'll print it so i'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
team b
if i run it oops there is a mistake i
have made so
this should be
dict 2 actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our
dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
i have say a
is equal to
i'll pass in my dictionary
as
a
has value of 1
say b has a value of
2
let's say b also has a value of 1
and my second dictionary would have
key b again
and it has a value of 2
and key c
will have a value of 1.
if i write a dot
update
b
and if i print a
let me run it you can see we have merged
both the
dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use
let me show you
so i'll copy paste
my team a and team b again
and then
let's say i'll declare
another variable called final team
that will be equal to
i'll use curly braces and then say
i'll give 2 star and then team e
comma
2 stars again
and then
team
b
then i'll print my
final team if i run it you can see we
have merged both are t me and b and this
is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
i am using in this live session then
please mention your email ids in the
chat section will share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension you can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose i want to find the square of
numbers so i'll pass in my variable that
is square
and i'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x
comma x
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for x in
range
say 5 so i want the square of the first
five numbers
then let me just
call it
you can see
it has
printed
a dictionary that has the square of
numbers from 0 to 4 that is 5 numbers so
0 square is 0 1 square is 1 2 square is
4 3 square is 9 and 4 square is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function
all function in python returns true
if all the items in an iterable are true
otherwise it returns false
so i'll directly use my all function
so i'll say all
now let's see i'll use a variable a
percentage 2
if it's equal to equal to 0
and i'll say for a in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if i run it
it gives me true
because i have defined my range from 0
to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0
2
4 6 8 and so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if i change the third parameter in
my range function see i'll make it
3
and i run it it gives me false
up next we'll look at a common
programming question that you often get
to see in any interview or programming
test
that is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so
i'll declare two numbers see x and y
let's say we have xs 10 and y as 20
i'll use a print statement
say
before
swap
give a comma and i'll declare my
variables x comma y
now to swap two variables i can simply
use x comma y equal to
[Music]
y comma x
and then i'll again use a print
statement say
after swap
and i'll write x
equal to
say
x
and
y
will have the variable
y
if i run it
you see before swap x had 10 and 20
and after swap you can see we have
x as 20 and y as 10.
so we have swapped the values of the two
variables successfully
now moving on
the next trick i am going to show
is how you can concatenate a list
containing strings
so we'll use the join function for this
let's say i have a list
characters
and it has a list of strings
say p
comma
y
comma
t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list
elements i'll declare a variable called
word and
double quotation marks
and then i'll use the dot operator and
join function
i'll pass in my
list that is
character
then i'll
print my variable
bird
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list character so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
i'll declare a list called test and
suppose it has some random whole number
c 1 comma 2 comma 3
four
two comma two then we have three comma
one comma
four comma four comma four
i'll use
print
statement and pass in my max function
then i'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma
and then i'll use key is equal to
test dot count
so what it basically does is it will
first count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it
if i hit shift enter you can see it has
given me 4 which means
the item 4
has occurred the most number of times in
my list you can see we have 4 4 times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in python
these operators evaluate something based
on a condition being true or false
so i have my two variables a comma b
and it has
values
10 and 20 respectively
now if i
use a print statement say both a
and
b
are
equal
if
a equals to equals to b
else
a
is
greater than
b
if
a greater than
b
else
b
is
greater
than a
so first i am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to b then will print
both a and b are equal
else
if a is greater than b will print a is
greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print b is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output b is greater than a
because our b value is 20 and a is 10 so
b is greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers
for this you can use the cumsum function
first i have to import my numpy library
so i'll write
import
numpy as np
then
i'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
i'll use a list function
and then
pass in my cumsum function
and let's say i'll give a range of
10.
finally i'll print the result
if i run this
you can see we have
calculated the cumulative sum of the
numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so
the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1
the next element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3
and 3 plus 3 is 6
6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is 15 and so on
let's now understand how you can use
iter tools in python
iter tool is a module in python that
implements a number of iterator building
blocks
it provides several functions that work
on iterators to produce complex
iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the item tools i'll first
import it so i'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list say
football
underscore
clubs
let me take
a few club names see manchester
united
then we have
real madrid
i'm taking the top clubs from europe
the next club we have is say arsenal
followed by
chelsea
then we have
say liverpool
and finally we have
barcelona
then
i'll use my list function
and use another function that is present
inside the item tools
library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
i'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and i'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2
if i run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in this league
as i mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the item tool and its
functions
now to do this i'll use a
for loop so i'll use for
p
in
iter tools
dot
i'll use permutations function
so permutations
and then let's see i'll pass in my
list that has values one comma two comma
three and four
i'll print it
i'll use print
then i'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
for
x in
p
if i run it
you can see below we have all the
permutations listed
up next let me tell you how you can
print all the false values present in a
list
now to do this we can use the filter
false function present in the item tools
module
so i'll use list
and then
use my item tools
dot
filter false function
i'll pass in
bool as my
data type
let's say we have
a list containing none
then we have false
we have 1
comma 0 comma
10.
if i run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and 0.
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
technologies
also if you want to get the source file
that i am using in this live session
then please mention your email id in the
chat section our team will share the
source code with you over email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far
then please put your queries in the chat
section our team will answer it in the
chat
up next
let me show you the trick to perform
certain mathematical operations inside a
list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that i'll import my item tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then i'll import operator
we have
a list of tuples say a2 comma 5
then we have
10 comma 4
we have
another pair says 60 comma
3
now i'll use
list function
and inside of it i'll use my item tools
module
so i'll write iter tools dot
star map function
and
i'll use my operator
and
add
comma
i'll pass in my list that is a
now if i run it
we have the addition of the pairs of
tuples present in the list so first pair
is 2 comma 5 so the addition
is 7
then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3 is
63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list
and just copy paste this code and here
instead of add
i'll use
mul to multiply
if i run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180.
now
let us explore a bit about the
collections module in python
so the collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list tuple dictionaries and set
i'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first i need to import the ordered
date
function from the collections module
so i'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
i'll say d is equal to
ordered
predict
dot
i'll use the from keys
and let's see
i have my key as e b c d e
then i'll
use another function called move
to
end
and let's say i want to move my
key b to the end
then
i'll use inverted commas
and pass in my
join function
and inside that i'll say d dot
keys
if i run it
you can see we have shifted the key b to
the end
now if you want to move the key b to the
beginning
you can do something like this so let me
copy the last two lines of code from the
above cell
i'll paste it
now here i can give another
parameter that is last
and i'll say
false
if i run this
you can see we have the key b in the
beginning now
now the final trick i am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a lambda function in
python
so lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
lambda function
so first i'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and i'll assign a dictionary
i'll pass in
my sum
and then
use the lambda function
i'll pass in variables x comma y
and i'll add x plus y
similarly
i'll now
subtract
i'll use the lambda function again
pass in my variables x comma y
and i'll write x
minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so i have to call this first so i'll use
func
and using
square brackets i'll give my sum
and then pass in my value say 10 comma 3
this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13.
similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
i'll just write
subtract here instead of sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is 7.
i think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in python welcome to python
interview questions
certainly the questions we're going to
ask in here are very general with a few
specifics towards data science since
that's the main direction that python's
going in and you'd want to expand your
questions for your interview depending
on the domain that you're using the
python in specifically let's dive in and
get started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy dot
deep copy creates a deep copy shallow
copy creates a different object and
populates it with the references of the
child objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change to child one and
object one it will also make that change
in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the django
architecture so the django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so we look
at the architecture you can see here we
have a nice model drawn out where the
user initiates the django which
initiates the url which indicates the
view what they're going to view and you
have your model and your template so the
model of data whatever data model you're
pulling goes into the template and then
goes back up the pipeline to the user
and the important thing to note is
there's a template the front end of the
web page this is what they're going to
see there's a model the back end where
the data is stored so you can keep the
template and the looks and everything
looks the same but you can swap out the
underlying information that goes into
that template then you have your view
which interacts with the model and
template and maps it to the url and then
the django serves the page to the user
so your django grabs it and says okay
thank you for the url and here you go
user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list
so numpy's a module you import almost
always see numpy import numpy as np
numpy is written in c such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists i would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our jupiter notebook any ide
will work if you're going to do a set of
interview questions taking a quick look
at code is always important we have our
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import time here's our list list sub for
iron range of 100 and what we're doing
is we're going to time it so we're going
to create a list then we're going to
create a numpy zeros array and you can
see here look how quick you can create
this numpy zeros array here we are
appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer i believe it's either
float or integer on this i'd have to
actually do a type on it and then so if
we take in and we create a tl1 time
equals time and then we do for i in
range of 100 for j and range of 100 l of
i j equals l of i j plus 5. so we're
just doing a simple calculation on our
array and sub arrays this is an array of
rays and we'll do the same thing with
tl2 tl2 time dot time tl1 equal so here
we have our final time on that and then
we'll do this with an array array op and
this is what i really love a equals a
plus 10 and then you can just print it
right out so you can see right here with
a numpy array i'm doing the same thing
if i run this our time is significantly
different here we have 0.09 and 0.003 uh
so you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time i run it depending on what i have
running in the background so there we go
number five
what is pickling and unpickling amazes
me how many times i pickle and unpickle
something converting a python object
hierarchy to a bite stream is called
pickling pickling is also referred to as
serialization unpickling converting a
byte stream to a python object hierarchy
is also called unpickling unpickling is
also referred to as
deserialization so if you just created a
neural network model you can now save
that model to your hard drive pickle it
and then you can unpickle it to bring it
back into another software program or to
use at a later time how is memory
managed in python number six python has
a private heap space where it stores all
the objects the python memory manager
manages various aspects of this heap
like sharing caching segmentation and
allocation the user has no control over
the heap only the python interpreter has
the access you have a nice little
diagram here here's your program there's
your interpreter we have our heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in python pass by value or by
reference arguments are passed in python
by reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of 0 equals 3 l
equals 1 2 3 4 function l print l and
you're going to get three two three four
because we passed l in there so it's a
pointer here we have def function l l
equals three two three four l equals one
two three four function of l print l
because in this function i have assigned
instead of operating on a piece of l the
list i've consigned a whole new value to
that list or l it then at that point
will create a new object so if i make
changes to the object it's going to
change it in the outside the definition
if i use a variable and i cited a
completely new value like l equals 3 2 3
4 that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight how
would you generate random numbers in
python to generate random numbers in
python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between 0 and 1. the
random range function generates a random
number within a given range and you can
see here one is the lower end tens the
upper end and step two so it would be
one three five and so on as far as the
options in the random generation number
nine what does the double forward slash
operator do in python the forward slash
operator performs division and returns
the quotient in float for example 5 over
2 returns 2.5 to do a double forward
slash operator on the other hand returns
the quotient an integer for example 5
double slash returns 2. 5 divided by 2
and you drop the 0.5 number 10 what does
the is operator do the is operator
compares the id of the two objects and
you can see in here where list one
equals brackets round one two three list
one equals list two equals true and you
have the double equals in python of
course and you can do list one is list
two where list two equals one two three
is false list two is not the brackets
one two three it equals it but it's not
the brackets and if we do list three
equals list one then list one is list
three equals true number 11 what is the
purpose of pass statement the pass
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learn we've added two
spaces in it for i in variable so it
goes through each eye if i equals space
do nothing else print i and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
i does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area and
you can also do a function like this you
could do function
whatever your def function name brackets
colon pass so it goes into the function
and does nothing but it's a placeholder
number 12 how will you check all the
characters in a string are alphanumeric
python has an inbuilt method is all
number which returns true if all
characters in the string are
alphanumeric and so you can see here
abcd123
is all number output equals true and the
second line abcd the at symbol one two
three the pound symbol is all nume
output equals false so really you just
wanna know about is all new all
numerical alpha numerical number twelve
how will you check if all characters in
a string are alphanumeric so here we go
if you know is all number which returns
that the characters in the string are
alphanumeric one can also use regex
instead and so we have boolean re match
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase dash to z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the abcd123 and so we can
do an re.match and if it matches if all
these things if all the different
entities in that array matches the first
one we get an output true and if not an
output false number 13 how will you
merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in python there's lists tuples
and strings python across makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your tuple is the curved brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn s1 plus s2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function l strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here spacebase base
python dot l strip leading strip python
and you can also do strip which release
leading and ending of course there's
also the ending set number 15 how will
you replace all occurrences of a stub
string with a new string the replace
function can be used with strings for
replacing a substring with a given
string syntax string dot replace old
comma new comma count replace returns a
new string without modifying the
original string hey john how are you
john question mark replace john with
capital j-o-h-n one and then you can see
right here hey john how are you and
since we designated with the one just
says we're only going to replace one of
these 16. what is the difference between
dell and remove brackets on lists dell
for delete dell removes all elements of
a list within a given range syntax dell
list start to end remove remove brackets
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax list remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list one to three
it will delete the first in this case b
one two it doesn't do three remember
that one two so we'll delete b and c and
you end up with a d where if we do
remove b from the list and we have an
abbd it's only gonna remove the first b
number 17 how to display the contents of
text file in reverse order open the file
using the open function store the
contents of the file into a list reverse
the contents of the list run a for loop
to iterate through the list number 18
differential between append and extend
append adds an element to the end of the
list you can see right here we have a
list one two three four and we append
four we end up with an output one two
three four and extend adds an element
from an interval to the end of the list
and we have here list equals one two
three list dot extend four five six
output is one two three four five six so
if you wanna append an array to the end
of another array you wanna use the
extend number nineteen what's the output
of the below code justify your answer
this is a great interview question
because these are the kind of things
that come up when you're proofing code
def add to list value and list so we
have value in and a list dent or list
equals an empty in this case an empty
list list data pin value return list
list one equals add to list one list two
equals add to list one two three empty
bracket list three equals add to list a
and we want to print them list one
equals and you can see the formatting we
have our placeholder list one list two
and list three so when it prints list
one we get one comma a and what you want
to notice here is that list one and list
3 are equal why are they equal well when
we passed the information to the add to
list we passed value without passing the
list equals brackets without passing a
second value what this means is that
list as we have it if you don't have a
list it'll start off with empty list
which we append the one to the second
one list two we appended a value to an
empty list so it's only going to be one
two three it doesn't matter what the
list was before we've already assigned
an empty list and then list three here's
the tricky one we're adding a to the
list but because we didn't designate the
list list is a shared value in other
words it doesn't reset it and we end up
with list one equals list three one
comma a default this is created only
once during the function and not during
its call number twenty what is the
difference between a list and a tuple
lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where i have list equals one
two three square brackets denoted it's a
list list of two equals four and i
printed out i now have one two four if i
do the same thing with the tuple i get
an error because you can't change the
tuple one two three into one two four
you have to completely reassign tuple to
a new value what is docs string in
python docs strings are used in
providing documentation to various
python modules classes functions and
methods and so you can see here we have
def for a function add a b and this is a
doc string we have the
triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b return sum and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docs string
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing dot string method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different
in values the second one is basically a
help menu there's our help menu number
22 how do you use print without the new
line the solution to this depends on the
python version you are using in python
version 2 you can do print hi and then
you add a comma afterwards print how are
you and you have hi how are you in
version three print hi comma end equals
and it will add a space on the end there
you can put different characters in
there but you just want to put a space
to put a space on the end print how are
you and now we get hi how are you number
23 how do you use the split function in
python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is to split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object oriented paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for i and var print i so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six you'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 and the line 6. number 26 what is
asterisks args and asterisks quarks
args used in function prototype to
accept varying number of arguments it's
an iterable object def function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if i send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma b comma c it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever i send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic korg's i can actually tell it
what i want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyword arguments it's in both are
iterable objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal to so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this
this means i could return a function
could be one from another function i
could create a function and treat it
just like an object i can assign it to a
variable i can pass them as arguments to
other functions number 28 what is the
output of print name underscore
underscore name and justify your answer
the double underscore name double
underscore is a special variable that
holds the name of the current module
program execution starts from main or a
code with zero indentation thus double
underscore name dumbbell underscore name
has a value double underscore main
double underscore in the above case if
the file is imported from another module
then double underscore name underscore
double underscore holds the name of this
module number 29 what is a numpy array
and we briefly touched numpy array
compared to a list early in processing
speed now let's go ahead and look at
some of the more specifics a numpy array
is a grid of values all of the same type
so if they're either all float all
integer all string and is indexed by a
tuple of non-negative integers the
number of dimensions is the rank of the
array and the shape of an array is a
tuple of integers giving the size of the
ray along each dimension number 30 what
is the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as np you don't
necessarily have to use mp but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an np.array of one two
three four five and then if we want to
get our indexes of n at maximum values
in a numpy array we can do one way to do
it is to take our array sort it then do
minus in colon that means we're gonna do
once you've sorted it you can do minus
in n would equal then the number of
indices so it's not the actual letter n
colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of ray of arrays we
have zero one two one two three what's
important here is that one it's a numpy
so that leaves a out and then we're
stuck with three other options and i'm
going to say the d is out none of these
and let's look at uh np dot concatenate
versus np dot v stack concatenate would
put one set after the other so you would
end up with probably give you an error
because one set is one two three and
then we're going to concatenate array
zero one two and one array one two three
the array of arrays onto the end of that
what we really want to do is stack and
by the way you can actually switch
there's variables you can put into
concatenate obviously they can change
this so you could use the concatenate
with a lot of fudging around but really
we're looking for is v stack v stands
for vertical versus the hdac which is
horizontal and if we do a v stack we can
simply do train set comma test set and
stack them together and so we have c
resulting set equals np.v stack train
stack test set both option a and b would
do horizontal stacking but we would like
to have the vertical stacking option she
does this again you could add the axes
in and use the concatenate to stack it
the correct way number 33 how would you
import a decision tree classifier in sk
learn we have sklearn dot decision tree
import decision tree classifier from sk
learn ensemble import decision tree
classifier and we look at these they're
all import decision tree classifier that
actually up last part happens to be
correct and it's really just a
vocabulary knowing where is the decision
tree classifier stored what module is
that a part of and it is of course part
of the sklearn.tree number c number 34.
you have uploaded the data set in csv
format on google spreadsheet and shared
it publicly how can you access this in
python what's important here is to know
that we can read stuff with pandas so we
don't show it here but you can there's
actually a number of ways to do this
what's important here is to know a
couple things one we have our link
generated from the google docs and
spreadsheets and then we can do a string
io dot string io request get
link.content so there's our source and
then finally we know that pandas can
read a csv there's obviously many ways
to read a csv but data equals pd.read
underscore csv source number 35 what is
the difference between the two data
series given below below we have df name
and df location colon comma brackets
around asterisks around name comma where
and then we have df equals pd data frame
aabb xx uu comma 21 16 50 33 columns
equal name and age so let's take a look
and see what they're looking at we have
just glancing at the questions they want
to know is it the original data frame or
is it the copy of the data frame and you
can see here that one is view of the
original data frame and two is a copy of
the original data frame two is a view of
the original data frame and one is a
copy of the original data frame both are
copies both are views and if you're
working with pandas you know that unless
you specifically in certain things tell
it to do it in line and a lot of
functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so c both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp dot csv using pandas which
of the following could correct it so
here's our error traceback most recent
call last file input line 1 in module
unicode encode error ascii codecs can't
encode character oh i hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that d doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is pd read csv
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again
not an encoding or coding setup and then
we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import map
plot library pi plot as plt and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show so this is
a little bit of a vocabulary test the
vocabulary is it width equals three line
width equals three lw equals three or
something else and the vocabulary word
that we're looking for is lw equals
three which stands for line width in pi
plot library pi plot number 38 how would
you reset the index of a data frame to a
given list so this is a vocabulary
challenge and understanding what
re-indexing is
as we have the different values here we
have the first one which is reset the
index well we're not really resetting
the index reindex number b means we are
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where reindex
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our keyword
that is external and we have a data
friend to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in python the functions
used to copy objects in python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
x range functions in python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object x range returns an x range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an x-range object x range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that x range returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in x range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number forty
one how can you check whether a pandas
data frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here import our pandas as pd we create
our pen as data frame equal to an empty
array and is df dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the n minus
one column this can be achieved using
arg sort function let's take an array x
then to sort the n minus one column the
code will be x to
x to colon in minus two dot args sort so
let's see what that code looks like we
import numpy as np we'll create our
array
our numpy array which is uh one two
three zero five two two three four so we
have three different entities with three
different columns in there and we go x
of x and so we take x of
all the rows first entity well in this
case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot arg sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one arg sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number forty three how to
create a series from a list numpy array
and dictionary so we'll go ahead and
input import our numpy our pandas and
have my list and you can see here we
have my list equals list of a b c d e f
g over all the way through so my list
now makes a list of that for
array we have np.a range to 26 my
dictionary will create a dictionary with
a zip my list my arguments so i'll just
use the numpy array we just created with
my array to go into the dictionary and
the solution is simple with the
pd.series my list pd.series my array
pd.series my dictionary so it's all
about knowing the dot capital
s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget that
capitalization number 44 how to get the
items not common to both series a and
series b and you can see here we have
instead of series a and b we have series
one and two and we have one two three
four five four five six seven eight the
solution is we take a panda series we
have a series u equals a panda series np
union one dimension series one series
two so we can now make a union of them
we now have series one panda series with
an intersection and then we can remove
one from the other series u is series u
dot is in series one so if the union is
not in the intersection then you know
it's a unique value a little bit of
logic going on there playing with three
different terms to get the answer we
want 45 how to keep only the top two
most frequent values as it is and
replace everything else as other in a
series so again we're working with
pandas because we're talking series and
data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as pd we'll go ahead and create
our panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random state
100 so 100 and the numpy one and then we
have our panda series you can see here
where uh random integer numpy random
random integer one comma five by 12. and
so the solution for this is we go ahead
and we've created a pd dot remember the
capital s series solution we're going to
print the top two frequencies and that
is our series dot value counts and then
we take series values count dot index of
up to two so we're going to take
everything up to two and then we'll do
the series is in so if it's not in the
first two then it's going to equal other
and this would be something you'd want
to write down on paper if you're if it
looks confusing take a moment pause the
video
write this down and see if you can
figure out how the logic came together
and try to throw yourself a couple other
little logic puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of 3 from a series
and in here we're actually going to use
a numpy to solve it the first part
series lets you know it's going to be a
panda series and if we come down here we
have
np.org where this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile three is the remainder so if
the remainder equals zero then we're
going to generate that string where the
object divided by three equals zero has
no remainder so that we know it's a
multiple of three number 47 how to
compute the euclidean distance between
two series and this one's really cool
because we have our panda series p and q
and what i like about this one is they
give us two solutions you can go with
and really you should kind of know both
the first one would be yes you know what
the euclidean distance is and that is we
can take the first series minus the
second series squared and then sum them
up and then we do the square root which
is the same as taking the power to 0.5
doing the power to 0.5
is easier than doing the square root so
a lot of times you'll see that as a
switch but you could have also done the
square root and use the math in there so
there's solution one you should know
your euclidean distance and then
solution two is the numpy solution so we
have np dot lin-alg dot norm that's how
we're going to compute our euclidean
distance
p minus q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it five minus one
and this creates a 25 by 25 data frame
and so our solution is to do the df dfi
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon minus one so we're taking
all the rows all the columns minus one
so we're stepping minus one going the
reverse direction and then we're just
going to use across all the different
columns on there let me say that again
the first colon is going to be your row
starting row stopping row step minus one
that's all this is about is that step
minus one comma and then all the columns
49 if you split your data into train
test splits is it possible to overfit
your model and the answer is yes it's
definitely possible one common beginner
mistake is retuning a model or training
new models with different parameters
after seeing his performance on the test
set my favorite example of this is you
have your script put together and you
keep hitting the rerun button until you
get the answer you want not taking the
answer it first gave you or running it
over an array and recording all the
answers to see how they vary number 50
which python library is built on top of
matplot library and pandas
to ease data plotting the answer this is
seabourn seaborn is a data visualization
library in python that provides a high
level interface for drawing statistical
information informative graphs and with
that we have come to an end of day 6 of
software development i hope the session
was interesting and informative on our
last and final day of software
development we will learn the paramount
of software and web development the
javascript
many believe it's simple looking complex
programming language that is rigorously
used in day-to-day programming simply
learn is all about explaining the most
complicated concepts in the most simple
and effective manner
until next time thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe to stay tuned
for more from simply learn
you